So sieht's aus. Nach der Wahl ist vor der Wahl.
Wurden wir schon gewählt?
Ich weiß nicht. Die Frage ist, ob auch irgendjemand bereit ist,
die Stimmen auszuzählen. Und ob sich jemand traut, anzutreten.
Man könnte ja vielleicht aus der ganzen Podcast-Landschaft mal so Parteien formen.
Da müsste sich aber mal jemand anderes bemühen.
Könnte sicherlich einen schönen Blogpost geben.
Guck jetzt nicht mich an.
Da gab's noch diese geilen Nerd-Pollegs. Plakate so mit, wo dann sozusagen das
Design von echten Parteien genommen wird, auch von Schlimmen und das Ganze dann
aber auf so Nerd-TLAs runtergebrochen wurde.
Also anstatt der NPD trat dann die NTP an und so und warte mal, den Ding,
den Ding hat doch bestimmt jemand im Chat gerade mal zur Hand mit diesen geilen Postern. Fantastisch.
Mehr erinnere ich natürlich jetzt gerade nicht, weil ich bin ja Lausig vorbereitet.
So ist das. Denn hier ist ja Freakshow, nämlich Ausgabe Nummer 206 vom,
heute sagen wir auch mal das Datum.
Warte mal, wie ist denn das Datum? Ah ja, 11.10.17.
11. Oktober 17.
Was würdest du ohne deine Apple Watch tun?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, auf die wir auch gleich nochmal eingehen können. Aber erstmal...
Habt ihr schon so einen roten Punkt?
Stell ich... Nein. Wir können gleich mit Apple Watch anfangen, das ist ein gutes Thema.
Oh, übrigens...
Ich wollte nur mal kurz euch...
Ja, mach mal.
Weil jetzt hatten wir ja immer so lustige Kombinationen. Heute geht's recht klassisch zur Sache.
Wir haben Roddy dabei. Hallo Roddy.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Huckel ist auch wieder am Start.
Ein zünftiges Boomzack-Return an die Hörer da draußen.
An die Freak-Traditionalisten.
Und nach längerer Zeit beehrt uns auch Dennis mal wieder.
Wieder da, ja.
Und Letty.
Da versagt's mir gleich die Stimme.
Ich bin so nervös.
Ja, Dennis, wenn du nimmst, ist es auf jeden Fall.
Aber 206 ist ja auch Partial Content, ne? Also es passt alles irgendwie zusammen.
RFC 7233 Selten wurde der Sendungstitel so früh festgelegt.
Ja, wo du Apple Watch sagst, das ist ganz interessant.
Ich hatte ein Event und zwar, ich hatte einen Moment,
einen Apple Watch Moment und zwar fühlte sich erst meine Uhr so ein bisschen
komisch an und jetzt seht ihr wahrscheinlich schon, dass man hier so kurz in
die Runde halten darf, meine Apple Watch ist jetzt schön.
Ist da was drüber geklebt?
Ja, mit Tesafilm habe ich nämlich das Display wieder befestigt,
was nämlich aus den Fugen gegangen ist.
Das habe ich schon hier und da mal gelesen, dass das so bei der alten Watch
irgendwann mal passiert.
Ich bin aber immer noch eine vor dir. Ich habe schon zwei zerstört.
Ich habe sie ja gar nicht zerstört. Sie hat sich ja quasi selber zerstört.
Also sie funktioniert ja noch wunderbar. Also fast wunderbar.
Es ist nur, dass diese Klebung des Displays halt sich aufgelöst hat.
Also was auch immer sie da am Anfang für einen Kleber gewählt haben,
der war jetzt nicht für die Ewigkeit.
Und ja, dann hat sich das auf einmal so gelöst. Und ist aber halt jetzt nicht
weiter kaputt gegangen. Es ist halt einfach nur...
Das ist aber auch keine Series 1, sondern so das Original. die ganz erste.
Genau, das ist die ganz am Anfang und ja, dann hatte ich ein Support Gespräch mit Apple.
Die mich dann erstmal darauf hinwiesen, dass ich ja keine Garantie und Gewährleistung
und so weiter. Und ich meinte so, ja, ich weiß.
Und jetzt warte ich noch so ein bisschen auf die Reaktion. Ich sollte dann mal
ein paar Fotos schicken.
Das habe ich dann auch getan. Und ja, in dem Zustand befindet sich dieser Prozess gerade.
Ich glaube, es hilft, wenn du die Fotos auch auf Twitter packst.
Also, soweit wollte ich das jetzt noch nicht eskalieren. Aber man muss ja auch noch Optionen haben.
ich gehöre ja jetzt nicht zu den Leuten, die dann jetzt gleich so,
weißt du, auf dicke Hose machen und hier und,
viele Follower, gib mal kostenlos, weißt du ist ja auch ungeil,
aber ich sag mal so, würde dann kommen ich hab sag mal so, ich hab schon mal
davon gehört und ich hab auch schon davon gehört dass sie damit relativ kulant umgehen,
ähm soweit hab ich das gehört jetzt werd ich mal schauen, weil ehrlich gesagt,
okay klar, Gewährleistung, alles vorbei und keine Ahnung, ich dachte,
ich hätte eigentlich Apple kämpfen, aber irgendwie nicht.
Und tja, gucken wir mal.
Das fällt auch nicht so doll auf.
Sieht ein bisschen retro jetzt alles aus.
So trashig, ne? Als hätte ich das Ding so im Müll gefunden und so geht auch
noch hier ein bisschen TESA drum.
Gaffa Gandalf.
Also meine funktioniert auch nicht mehr richtig. Das liegt aber im Wesentlichen an WatchOS 4.
Das ist so dermaßen langsam geworden. Die Uhr, die...
Ist das so bei dir?
Ja. Das ist unglaublich. Bis die irgendwas tut. Also WatchOS 3 war ja schon,
Schmerz, aber ich bin jetzt...
Das war alles immer schneller als vorher.
Nee, mit 4 bin ich jetzt, glaube ich, drüber. Also entweder kaufe ich mir eine
neue oder ich weiß nicht, was ich damit mache. Also es ist irgendwie nicht mehr erträglich.
Ich finde es nicht... Also bei mir ist es nicht...
Also bis zu dem Punkt, wo halt auch Push-Notifications nicht mehr durchkommen,
weil die Uhr einfach nicht mehr schnell genug reagiert.
Dann solltest du sie vielleicht mal neu aufsetzen, weil diese Probleme kann
ich nicht bestätigen. Also das ist zumindest nicht endemisch.
Das leitet ja.
Oder du machst da auch Tesa drüber.
Mit Tesa?
Wäre das nicht passiert.
Wir haben in der Firma so ein Two-Factor-Authentication-Tool, das nennt sich Ping-ID.
Da lädst du dir irgendwie so eine App aufs iPhone runter und dann kannst du
über diese App kannst du dich halt irgendwie authentifizieren.
und prinzipiell funktioniert die auch mit der Apple Watch?
Aber nur, wenn die Apple Watch schnell genug ist.
Ping-ID? Ich verstehe den nicht.
Ping-ID heißt das. Das ist so ein Two-Factor-Tool, was dir Zahlen ausspuckt,
aber auch, dass irgendwie so interaktiv funktioniert.
Die Uhr ist so langsam da drin, dass die Zahl, wenn sie sie anzeigt,
schon gar nicht mehr gilt.
Ja, beziehungsweise der macht so eine Authentifizierung. Du meldest dich irgendwie
auf einer Seite an, kriegst da so ein Name, Passwort, dann sagst du okay und
dann sagt der ja, ich mache jetzt Two-Factor.
und dann kommt diese To-Factor-Authentication-Anfrage bei deinem Phone raus
und dann sagt das Phone, du hast jetzt per Push-Notification, du hast jetzt eine,
Authentifizierungsanfrage, dann also wenn du keine Uhr hast,
dann unloggst du das und dann gibst du irgendwie nochmal deinen Daumen ab für,
Touch-ID und dann bist du halt authentifiziert und mit der Uhr kannst du aber
halt, läuft halt auf die Uhr und dann kannst du auf der Uhr drücken,
ja, akzeptieren und das funktioniert aber nur, wenn die schnell genug ist.
Sonst sagt er dir, nee, die Authentifizierungsanfrage ist jetzt leider abgelaufen.
Aber du hast auch ein älteres Modell als das, was Tim ist.
Nein, nein.
Nein?
Series Zero, wie ich sie immer nenne. Also die allererste.
Wie alt ist die jetzt? Zwei Jahre oder zweieinhalb?
Zwei Jahre.
Also prinzipiell oder die jetzt?
Ich habe die im Mai 2015 erworben. Und ich meine, ich habe sie mir auch schon...
Also mir war von Anfang an klar, das Ding ist jetzt erstmal so die Beta-Version.
Also ich hatte nie die Erwartung, dass das jetzt schon der große Wurf ist und
ich habe dann noch eine Weile mit mir gerungen, okay, gibst du das Geld jetzt aus und warum?
und dann war es halt so ein bisschen so diese, ich wollte halt einfach wissen wie das so ist,
was so gehen kann am Arm, so gerade im Hinblick auf Podcast und so lustigerweise
sind wir jetzt seit zwei Jahren innerhalb von zwei Jahren auch noch nicht so
sehr viel weitergekommen also immerhin mit den Airpods,
jetzt soll demnächst halt Musikstreaming gehen und so weiter,
aber warum die Dinger keine Podcasts serienmäßig abspielen können,
versteht auch keiner also gerade Podcasts, die jetzt noch nicht mal groß streamen
müssen, die kein LTE brauchen
sondern wo es eigentlich nur darum geht, dass das Telefon mal die Daten da rüberballert
aber über diesen Bluetooth-Kanal scheint das ja nicht besonders,
schnell zu sein über WLAN kriegen die sich nicht kommuniziert keine Ahnung, was da falsch läuft,
auf jeden Fall ist da jetzt nicht so sehr viel passiert aber das war der Grund,
warum ich mir sie gekauft habe und dann fand ich sie erstmal so ganz okay und
tatsächlich finde ich hat sie halt so ein paar Funktionen ich vermisse das Teil,
wenn ich es nicht anhab und zwar ziemlich schnell wie.
In der Uhrzeit oder?
Ja, also erstmal ist es eine Uhr. Da kann man sich tatsächlich daran gewöhnen,
weil sonst immer dieses Handy rausziehen Ding.
Nicht, dass ich diese ganze Notification Geschichte gut in den Griff kriege,
aber es ist trotzdem besser, das da erstmal zu haben, als immer wieder aufs Telefon zu gucken.
Also überhaupt diese ganzen Telefon-Rausholzeiten, die reduzieren sich einfach extrem mit der Uhr.
Und dann finde ich halt so der Blick auf die Temperatur draußen.
Du hast ein Killer-Feature noch vergessen.
Es gibt da diverse Killer-Features.
Unlock das Mac mit der Uhr.
Ja, das ist ganz nett.
Also ich glaube, das würde ich nicht mehr vermissen wollen, weil ständig das
Passwort einzutippeln, das nervt halt.
Touch-ID.
Ja, gut. Ja. Aber trotzdem.
Aber trotzdem.
Drückst du eine Taste, dann sagt der Unlock mit Watch und fertig.
Ja.
Dann kannst du auch mal ein schönes, langes, starkes Passwort wählen.
Was hast du denn für Complications auf deiner Uhr?
Bei welchem Zifferblatt?
Welches auch immer du benutzt.
Also mein tagsüber Zifferblatt, da habe ich die Zeit. Also dieses mit den vielen
Complications, dieses technische.
Das ist ein Nerdteil.
Genau, der Kalender.
Also Anzeige des nächsten Termins.
Nee, links oben, also das Datum.
Ja.
Mittwoch, Elfter, heute. In der Mitte Outlook.
Ja, das Problem ist folgendes.
Willst du mir das wissen?
Ja, du hast recht, du willst es nicht wissen. Also es geht leider nur Outlook,
nicht der richtige Kalender, was total scheiße ist, weil Outlook total scheiße ist.
Es geht nur Outlook.
Weil, also das ist jetzt mein quasi Firmenzifferblatt.
Da sind die Termine drin, die ganzen Meetings, die ich so habe,
die tauchen da natürlich auf, was sehr praktisch ist, weil da immer steht,
wann ist es, was ist es und wo ist es.
Und wenn ich das mit einem Blick auf die Uhr weiß, was ich als nächstes habe
und wo ich dafür sein muss.
Und ob eine Glaskür auf dem Weg liegt.
Das zeigt es leider nicht.
Gibt es jetzt nicht Indoor-Maps?
Die meisten, die meisten, die meisten Glastüren, na egal.
Ja, nee, das ist, das Problem, das Problem mit Outlook ist, dass es sich nicht updatet auf iOS. ist.
Also du musstest eigentlich, das erste, was ich immer morgens mache,
ist erstmal Outlook starten, damit Outlook sich updatet, er dann die Kalenderereignisse
für den Tag lädt und dann die Kalenderereignisse auf die Uhr lädt.
Nein.
Doch.
Oh, das...
Also, es geht aber nur unter, naja, Microsoft-ischen Randbedingungen.
Ich kann nachvollziehen, dass du Dass du da einen Nutzen von hast.
Und was sind die anderen Complications?
Dann habe ich den Timer für den Tee.
Und den hast du tatsächlich auf einer Complication?
Ja, weil dann brauche ich nur einmal zu drücken und dann drücke ich noch einmal die drei Minuten.
Weil, also es ist nicht wichtig, mir ist nicht wichtig, dass der Tee genau drei
Minuten zieht. Mir ist wichtig, dass er kürzer als eine Viertelstunde oder halbe Stunde zieht.
Nicht 30 Minuten da rumsteht. Oh, ich hatte ja noch einen Tee.
Richtig. Und deswegen habe ich da diese Complication, damit ich da mit wenig
Aufwand einfach tapptapp und dann… Okay.
Zwei hast du noch. Jetzt bin ich gespannt, weil jetzt hast du eine, die ich nicht habe.
Sonnenaufgang, Sonnenuntergang.
Hab ich auch. Ist geil irgendwie, ne? Das ist eine Information, die ist relevant.
Ja, das ist immer ganz nett, wenn man mal so guckt und vor allen Dingen jetzt
in der Jahreszeit, wo es so schnell dunkler wird.
Genau.
Da, aber im Prinzip guck ich da nicht so oft drauf. Und dann noch diese farbigen Ringe.
Ach, die Ringe. Guck an. Die Sportringe.
Die Sportringe.
Die Aktivitäringe. Hab ich nicht. Ich hab mich für die Temperatur und den Akkustand der Uhr haltet.
Den Akkustand, den habe ich ja, wenn ich hier einmal hochziehe,
dann zeigt er mir ja direkt den Akkustand an. Das ist ja...
Das brauche ich dann nicht auf einer Complication, wenn ich Angst habe,
dass die Uhr jetzt krepiert.
Was ich aber selten habe, weil so oft krepiert sie mir nicht.
Die Hörer jetzt bestimmt genauso spannend wie für uns restlichen drei hier.
Du weißt ja nicht.
Wie viele Hörer eine Apple Watch haben.
Oder eine haben wollen.
Oder über ihre Complications reflektieren.
Aber man sieht keine Bilder. hier redet immer, ich seh gar nichts.
Das ist ein Podcast, mein Freund.
Aber der Roddy könnte uns ja mal die, welche Complication hattest du nicht?
Die Outlook-Complication.
Outlook hatte ich nicht und ich hab auch nicht den T-Timer.
Den T-Timer, genau, den könntest du mal zeigen.
Also der T-Timer, der hat sogar noch einen dämlichen Bug.
Seit WatchOS 4.
Und zwar Ist das von Apple oder Third Party?
Ne, ist von Apple. Also normalerweise startet der so, wenn du den anmachst,
mit so vordefinierten Zeiten.
So eine Minute, drei Minuten, fünf und so weiter und so weiter.
Und dann gibt es ganz, wenn du ganz runter scrollt, gibt es unten den großen Button beliebig.
Und wenn du den einmal wählst und irgendwas Beliebiges auswählst,
dann startet der immer mit diesem beliebig.
Der kommt nicht mehr zurück zu der Übersicht von automatischen voreingestellten
Zeiten. Das ist total bekloppt.
Ach, das machen wir nicht so.
Aber ja, der T-Timer halt, der ist nicht so übermäßig spannend.
Ich wurde ja letztens belächelt dafür, dass ich eine extra T-Timer-App verwende.
Ich nicht, ich habe den Einwand gesehen und dachte mir so, es sollte noch mehr
kleine Apps geben für den Mac.
Ich benutze sowas gerne und das gibt es eigentlich viel zu wenig.
Warum diese ganze iOS-App-Kultur noch nicht auch so eine Rückwirkung auf den
Mac gehabt hat, naja, will nicht
sagen, dass ich das nicht nachvollziehen kann, aber ich bedauere das.
Der Typ ist übrigens, der diesen T-Timer macht, der kriegt jeden Monat,
ich glaube, ich habe zwei Flatter Donations,
laufen konstant und ich glaube, seit drei Jahren kriegt er jeden Monat einen
Euro von mir von der Flatter Kohle für diesen T-Timer, der nichts anderes macht, außer T-Timer.
Er hat das Update nur für dich raus.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Sponsert bei Huckel. Wie hieß der nochmal?
Äh, Kupa,
Kuppa, kuppa. Und der ist auch nicht, also er ist nicht besonders fancy oder
schick oder was auch immer, aber ich habe den irgendwann mal vor Jahren gefunden.
Tut, was er sollte. Ich packe einen Link in den Chat, ja, ja, Moment.
Und irgendwann hat er dann das nicht mehr abgedatet, weil es auch nur so ein
Hobbyprojekt war und dann habe ich ihm nochmal geschrieben, ja,
das wäre total gut, weil ich diese App wirklich jeden Tag mehrfach benutze.
und dann hat er nochmal ein Update rausgehauen und jetzt hat es Open Source
gemacht, das ist aber auch im App Store und man kann ihm Donations,
ich habe ihm auch nochmal 10 Euro rüberwiesen, dass er schön weitermacht mit
der App. Hier, da ist der Link.
Noch was zum Tea-Timer, wenn ich also wirklich irgendwie jetzt den Timer brauche,
aber ich habe so schmutzige Finger, dass ich das Gefühl habe,
ich kann damit nicht mal mehr auf der Uhr rumtatschen.
Was machst du bei Ebay?
Zu Hause. Zu Hause.
Naja, Hefeteig zum Beispiel. Der ist klebrig.
Ich dachte, du als Programmierer musst so schmutzige Dinge programmieren.
Darüber möchte ich nicht reden.
Ja, dann benutze ich tatsächlich auch Siri auf der Uhr.
Aber da muss man sich halt darüber im Klaren sein, dass es erstens nicht immer
funktioniert und zweitens mal, dass auch das Timing nicht sehr akkurat ist,
Weil Siri halt zwischen einer Sekunde und 15 Sekunden alles mal brauchen kann,
um zu verstehen, was man von ihr will.
Und manchmal versteht sie die Zeit nicht, dann macht sie nur den Timer auf mit
0 Sekunden, was auch extrem cool ist.
Siri, das ist so dieses neurotische Au-pair-Mädchen aus den USA,
irgendwie aus Oklahoma rüberkommt, aber irgendwie kulturell nichts versteht
und ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich jetzt schon dieses ich probier's mal mit Siri
gehabt hab. Wie lange gibt's den Kram jetzt schon?
4S.
4S, ja.
Ewig.
War's nicht 3S?
3GS? Mein Netto-Nutzen von Siri...
Ja, kleiner ein Prozent.
Ja, also ich kann mich nicht erinnern, gibt es irgendeinen Go-To-Moment, wo ich wirklich gerne.
Ne. Also das Einzige, wofür ich so die Spracherkennung nutze,
ist tatsächlich, das funktioniert super.
Ja, klar, keine Frage, aber das ist ja nicht Siri. Oder gut,
das heißt jetzt vielleicht auch alles irgendwie Siri.
Das ist wahrscheinlich schon ähnliche Technologie, um die Sprache zumindest zu erfassen.
Aber. das ist in der Tat gut, also diktieren bin ich voll dabei,
aber so dieses Dubodamin funktioniert einfach mal gar nicht.
Das ist genauso gut wie die Suche in Apple Maps.
Ja, ähnliches.
Die auch wirklich so immer noch so kaputt ist, das ist wirklich unfassbar.
Ich merke das immer daran, weil ich mache schon immer Apple Maps bei Default.
Du bist immer da zuerst und mach dann mal so meinen Fallbeweis.
Es gibt andere Aspekte, die gefallen mir dann so ganz gut.
Volle Adressen gehen super, aber wenn du nach der XY-Straße suchst,
dann wird erstmal angenommen, dass du einen Hintertupf fängst.
Einfache Straßennamen in Berlin gehen nicht. Dann zeigt er dir irgendwas in Südamerika an.
Da hab ich aber nicht so Probleme mit. Was mich total nervt,
ist, dass diese Autovervollständigung nicht richtig funktioniert.
Also du musst eigentlich immer auf amerikanische Art und Weise die Straße angeben,
nämlich erst die Nummer und dann die Straße, sonst kriegt es Apple Maps überhaupt nicht gepackt.
Das stimmt auch nicht ganz, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht gut.
Es ist noch schlimmer, man weiß überhaupt nicht, wie man die Straße schreiben
soll, damit das richtig erkennt.
Ja, hilft es irgendwas mit einem Komma abzutrennen oder nicht?
Du kannst ja noch nicht mal sicher sein, dass er das richtige Berlin nimmt.
Aber was gut funktioniert, das muss man jetzt hier so gut licht und schatten.
Was mir in letzter Zeit auf iOS aufgefallen ist, dass so diese Adresserkennung,
die so in irgendwelchen Kontexten dir so Adressen rausfischt und dann machst
du die Maps-App auf und dann wird dir die schon suggested, obwohl du die gar
nicht copy und pasted oder sonst irgendwas hast.
so irgendwie aus WhatsApp-Nachrichten oder sonst irgendwas.
So, hä, hier Brunnenstraße? Habe ich doch nur in der Nachricht gelesen,
noch nirgendwo eingetippt und so.
Das funktioniert irgendwie magischerweise ganz gut in letzter Zeit.
Aber das ist auch nur so ein kleines Detail.
Aber ich frage mich dann immer, wenn ihr die Scheißadresse automatisch aus dem
Text erkennen könnt, warum nicht in der Suchmaske?
Wo ich allerdings sagen muss, was gar nicht verkehrt war, war öffentlicher Nahverkehr in der Apple Maps.
als jetzt der Sturm durchging, war Apple Maps interessanterweise besser in der
Lage, mir zu sagen, dass nichts fährt, als die BVG-App.
Das fand ich dann schon erstaunlich.
Das stimmt. Nahverkehr sind sie sehr gut.
Teilweise auch schon besser als Google Maps.
Auch beim Navi, nicht Nahverkehr, ich meine Unfälle.
ja also ich hatte mehrere Situationen im Sommer wo so Autobahnsperrungen und so weiter die benutzen.
Ja nach wie vor die TomTom Daten also sprich das Zeug was die über Vola von
machen und Google benutzt ja nur seine eigenen Android.
Maps was auch immer der Grund ist nur die Präsentation ich hatte so den Fall
bin zurück nach Berlin dann war die Autobahn so 100 Kilometer vor Berlin war
ein Unfall so und bei Google Maps weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau,
ich glaube das Maximum war, dass da irgendwo so ein kleines Warndreieck stand,
aber was jetzt irgendwie da Phase war, war vollkommen unklar.
Während halt Apple Maps halt einen schon großräumig frühzeitig und dann,
wie sich danach auch herausgestellt hat, absolut korrekt umgeleitet hat und
wenn man dann auf dieses,
was ist da los, draufklickt, zoomt sich da was raus und erklärt ausführlich, ja,
Gefahrgutlaster umgekippt, also so richtig so mit Erklärung, was Phase ist.
Das war dann schon so wieder so ein Living the Future Moment. So, okay, ist klar.
Besonders in der Kombination mit CarPlay, muss ich sagen.
Das mag sein, das habe ich nicht.
Ich hatte das ja auch nur in dem geliehenen Turan im Urlaub.
Aber das hat echt erstaunlich gut funktioniert. Da war halt so ein USB-Dingsi
und da dachte ich, ah, kannst du Telefon laden, steck ein, zack,
CarPlay kommt hoch. Und ich so, oh, aha,
Nicht schlecht.
Das fand ich auch ganz angehebend. Das hatte ich nämlich auch im Urlaub.
Traugt denn das?
Ja. Also es ist nicht alles Gold, aber Navi.
Aber es glänzt.
Aber es glänzt. Also Navi und Musik abspielen und so.
Sagen wir mal so, es kann fast nichts, aber das, was es kann, kann es sehr gut.
Ja. Also ich fand auf jeden Fall die Apple Maps Navi, die haben wir dann statt
der eingebauten Navi benutzt und das war auf jeden Fall sehr viel besser. Sehr viel besser.
Ja.
Und dann halt auch noch so Musik irgendwie so einfach hier mit Touchscreen oder
Dingsbums abspielen, war schon okay.
Naja, ich hatte ja da das Problem, dass ich mit der TomTom App hatte ich halt
Deutschland runtergeladen und dann gab es da irgendwie, oder war es Zentraleuropa
und dann gab es noch Nordeuropa, da wollte ich nach Dänemark.
Und dann war in der Zentraleuropakarte war halt Deutschland drin,
in der Nordeuropakarte war Dänemark drin.
Dann stellte sich aber heraus, man kann nicht beide Karten gleichzeitig benutzen.
Das heißt, Er war dann nicht in der Lage, mich zum Legoland zu routen über die
Grenze, weil er nicht beide Karten gleichzeitig im Speicher haben konnte. Oh Leute.
Das ist geil.
Ich benutze eigentlich größtenteils Google zum Navigieren, aber hat Apple eigentlich
auch so dieses Problem in Deutschland mit der Aussprache der Straßennahmen?
Ist besser geworden.
Weil das ist ja echt zum Heulen, wenn manchmal niemand neben dir sitzt und du
versuchst darauf zu achten, was die sagt und du hast es jetzt nicht irgendwie,
also ich stelle mir das Telefon mittlerweile schon so hin, dass ich es vom Lenkrad
aus auch direkt drauf gucken kann.
Aber wenn du irgendwie mal wieder nicht verstehst, in welche Straße du einwiegen
sollst, dann denkst du dir so.
Welche?
Ich habe ja das Problem, dass mein Siri, als es noch ging, überhaupt, wir kommen später dazu,
weil ich mein Telefon auf Englisch habe, du kannst Siri für den Rest des Betriebssystems
auf Deutsch umstellen, nur die Maps-App hat sich hartnäckig geweigelt und weiterhin
in Englisch mir alles erzählt.
Das heißt, du warst dann in der Kaiserin Auguste Straße oder hier die Shodowiki
oder wie auch immer, die ausgesprochen wird in Deutsch überhaupt.
Das war so gibberisch, überhaupt nicht auszumachen.
Immerhin wusste man dann eben, wie die Touristen dann wohl vermutlich diese
Straßennamen aussprechen.
Deswegen war ich dann schon geschult in deutscher und amerikanischer Aussprache. Aber ja, ich bin da.
Kannst du zumindest den Touristen dann korrekt sagen, wo sie hin müssen.
Straß.
Ja.
Ja,
so richtig 21. Jahrhundert ist auch irgendwie alles nicht.
Da geht noch einiges, da geht noch einiges.
Ja, aber jetzt wo du so sagst hier, WatchOS wird langsamer, also ich weiß nicht,
letztes Mal hatte ich das eigentlich schon erzählt, dass mein iPhone so am rumgammeln
war und es wurde auch immer schlimmer, also wirklich unbenutzbar, komplett unbenutzbar.
Aber wenn ich mal noch eine Webseite aufmachen konnte, war gut.
Dann dachte ich, okay, fuck it, ich mache jetzt nochmal so Clean-Install-mäßig jetzt Schritt 2.
Weil beim ersten Mal hatte ich halt nur einfach ein Encrypted-Backup gemacht.
Neu Restore geklickt und dachte, na, vielleicht gehen da die Zahnrädchen in die richtige Richtung.
Und dann meinte aber gleich schon einer auf Twitter, nee, mit dem Encrypted-Backup,
da spielst du ja die ganzen Fehler auch gleich wieder zurück.
Und dann so, ja, so war es dann auch.
Also war überhaupt nicht besser. und dann habe ich es nicht mehr ausgehalten,
weil es so am Horizont oder durchs Gebäck geflüstert hat, dass das iOS 11.1
noch ein paar Wochen dauern kann.
Dann habe ich mir, okay, fuck it, dann jetzt nochmal eine Stufe härter Clean-Install,
das heißt ein Unencrypted-Backup gemacht und dann von diesem Firmware-File,
restored, also nicht so einfach nur Restore im iTunes klicken,
sondern File runterladen und dann im iTunes Option-Restore File auswählen,
dann macht er halt so richtig einmal Clean-Install und dann,
als es durchgebootet ist, dann gesagt, Ich dachte, okay, jetzt nochmal die Fotos
wieder und die Apps zurückholen.
Und dann war es erstmal wieder super, also auch so fluffig. Und ich dachte mir,
jawohl, jetzt muss ich nur meinen Google Authenticator neu einstellen und Wi-Fi-Fassports
und Slack-Zugänge und was nicht alles.
Aber damit hätte ich leben können. Mail war noch da, Fotos waren noch da und so. Alles super.
Und jetzt ist es quasi wieder in dem gleichen Verranst. Also nicht ganz so schlimm,
aber ich kann immer noch nicht telefonieren.
Also nur wenn ich einen Reboot mache, dann kann ich direkt danach telefonieren.
Siri hat keine Stimme mehr.
Apps crashen nach wie vor, random sogar der App-Store oder was auch immer in
zufälligen Momenten, diesen Spinner, wo dann das ganze Telefon freeze und gar
nicht mehr reagiert und dann irgendwann der Abfilmer wiederkommt.
Alles so eine Späße habe ich jetzt wieder nach einer Woche oder so.
Das habe ich ja nie gehört.
Ich auch nicht, das könnte an deinem Telefon liegen.
Die Hardware.
Ja, aber dann nach dem Clean & Stall war ja alles fluffig, also das war ja zwei,
drei Tage alles super. und dann fängst du wieder an, also was soll das sein bitte für Hardware?
Ich hab nur halt...
Keine Ahnung, halt irgendwas in deiner Hardware,
wo, wenn...
Ich hab aber auch ähnliche Probleme.
Und ich bin ja auch nicht alleine, das sind ja... Also gerade die iPhone 6s-User
sind scheinbar davon betroffen. Es gibt zwar viele, die sagen, bei mir ist alles super.
Aber es haben auch genauso viele gesagt, ah, ich bin nicht allein mit den Problemen.
Ja, also das scheint schon so generell was zu sein.
Und jetzt kamen hier gerade iOS 11.0.3 raus, aber das fixt wieder nur irgendwelche Lappalien.
Die machen ja Silent Fixes. Ich hab das mal installiert. Bisher geht's,
aber das sieht man auch erst morgen, ob das alles kommt.
Also ich hab auch das 6S und ich hab diese ganzen Probleme nicht.
Allerdings bin ich auch so ein bisschen über den Beta-Upgrade-Fahrt gegangen.
Das kann natürlich sein, dass da Dinge installiert wurden, die diese Probleme
umschiffen und dass ein Clean-Install das eventuell eher schlimmer macht, weiß man nicht.
Ich habe halt, bei mir ist es halt bei der Watch so ähnlich.
Also das ist halt irgendwie, funktioniert halt nicht mal richtig.
Und wirklich, das ist ja, also ich habe noch nie clean installed,
aber ich habe es immer drüber installiert und eigentlich wurde es schon immer besser.
Und das ist jetzt das erste Mal so richtig viel schlechter.
Ich habe ja Hoffnung, dass dann 11.1 das dann doch nochmal fixt.
Und ansonsten, ja, keine Ahnung, also irgendwie bin ich auch so in letzter Zeit
von so Apple-Software-Releases genauso wenig wie von den Hardware-Releases irgendwie begeistert.
Also, weißt du noch, hier, ähm, Underwhelmed. Ja, so der Snowlapper,
du weißt, das war auch so ein technisches Release und was ist das hier so noch
in unseren Erinnerungen für ein goldenes Release irgendwie.
Ja, keine Clicky-Bundi-Features, einfach nur schneller, besser,
härter, weiter, wie auch immer.
Und auch High Sierra, vielleicht hat sich da total viel unter der Haube geändert,
aber es fühlt sich nicht so an.
Also ich habe keinen großen Unterschied bisher feststellen können.
Ich hatte zwischendrin vergessen, dass ich es installiert habe.
Es gibt auch Leute, die finden, dass es ein echtes Feature ist,
dass man das nicht merkt.
Ja, aber ich, also ich habe zum Beispiel, also wenn sie schon so einen Release
machen, eine App, die mir seit, wo ich mich seit Jahren frage,
sage ich, aber wirklich könnt ihr das nicht besser machen, ist zum Beispiel Keychain-App.
Wirklich, die lassen das einfach, dieses räudige Programm unverändert, obwohl.
Unter APFS haben sie es doch besser gemacht.
Naja. Das ist jetzt dein Passwort gesagt. Das war ja nicht Keychain, sondern Disk Utility.
Aber wirklich so, ich meine Passwort Manager, das ist jetzt so einfach Default.
Fast jeder benutzt das irgendwie.
Also ist es nicht so, dass es nicht besser geworden ist?
Ja, aber im mikroskopischen Bereich.
Nein, nein, im User Interface finde ich, also die Integration,
dieses ganze Einfügen von Passwörtern auf Webseiten, das ist besser geworden.
Ich würde mal behaupten, 90% der Leute machen das gar nicht auf.
Ja, das kann sein.
Das ist ja auch, ja, aber genau bei so einem Release, wo es nicht um End-User-Features
geht, da hätte ich halt einfach mal mir sowas gewünscht.
Ich gucke mal, ob mein Lieblings-Bug immer noch drin ist.
Dass das User-Interface mal irgendwie was taugt und also ist einfach grottig.
Dann irgendwie mit High Sierra hat auch irgendwie aufgehört,
das kann aber auch mit meinem iPhone jetzt zusammenhängen, aber so,
dass iMessages wieder auf allen
Geräten ankommt, das ist irgendwie wieder schlechter geworden gefühlt.
Also ich habe ja jetzt ein Mac Pro zu Hause, mein MacBook Pro und mein iOS.
Und dann kommt eine Nachricht an und es ist immer so ein bisschen Lotterie,
auf welchen der drei Geräte das dann ankommt.
Und irgendwie auch nicht geil irgendwie.
Der Chef von iCloud wurde ja entlassen gerade oder zumindest ist es weggegangen.
Die haben jetzt einen neuen.
Weil du Keychain sagst, mein Lieblingsbank, den ich glaube ich für 10.5 gepostet
habe, bei Apple mal eingereicht habe, der ist immer noch drin.
Und zwar, wenn du dir ein Passwort vorschlagen lässt,
Dann baut er dieses Passwort ja aus richtigen Worten zusammen und die kriegen
aber irgendwie das Encoding der Charakter aus dem Wörterbuch,
was sie verwenden, nicht richtig hin,
weswegen er Umlaute verschluckt und irgendwelche unprintbaren Zeichen da rein macht.
Wie gesagt, habe ich zu 10.5 oder 10.6 habe ich da mal einen Radar-Bug für gefeilt.
Eine Weile lang habe ich immer bei jedem Major Release dann nochmal dazu geschrieben,
ist immer noch nicht gefixt.
Habe ich inzwischen aufgegeben, aber ich habe es gerade nochmal ausprobiert.
Es ist auch unter 10.13 noch drin.
So viel zum Thema Diversität bei Apple. Wir haben immer noch keine Menschen
eingestellt, die mit Umlauten oder sowas umgehen können. Gibt es da keine Deutschen und denn?
Doch, kennen wir nicht sogar einen.
Wir kennen einen, ja.
Ja, aber die gibt es wohl noch nicht in ausreichendem Maße.
Und was mir, also das ist jetzt ein subjektiver Eindruck aber ihr könnt ja mal
sagen, wie ihr das so findet aber ich hab so das Gefühl jetzt so,
File Handling und IO und irgendwie ist auch irgendwie ein bisschen langsamer
geworden also nicht nur jetzt wegen APFS, sondern generell irgendwie so Dinge von,
USB oder über Netzwerk oder so Dinge kopieren so in größeren Mengen und so und
irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl es ist bestimmt langsamer geworden.
Aber im Verhältnis zu den Sachen, die du lokal auf deinem Rechner machst,
weil das ist verdammt schnell geworden, da kommt dann natürlich alles andere
mal jetzt total langsam vor.
Weißt du nicht? Also ich kopiere relativ häufig mal, zum Beispiel wenn ich im
Proberaum Laptop Sachen aufnehme und dann komme ich nach Hause und kopiere so
mal ein paar Gigabyte Audio-Files halt so rüber, entweder über Netzwerk oder wie auch immer.
Und irgendwie so seit High Sierra habe ich irgendwie mal das Gefühl,
ist alles so ein bisschen so...
Kann ich nicht bestätigen.
Okay, gut, dann ist das mein subjektiver Eindruck.
Naja.
Ich glaube, unsere Ansprüche steigern, das liest sich auch die ganze Zeit, deswegen...
Muss alles geiler werden, oder? Was ist zum Beispiel hier eine Sache,
die ich vielleicht auch, die ihr mir jetzt noch sagen könnt,
jetzt wo ja APFS da ist und du hattest ja auch schon irgendwie getwittert,
dass da irgendwie ein Feature dir noch fehlt und so. Was war das nochmal?
Backup. Backup auf APFS, weil dann geht es, glaube ich, jetzt richtig los mit,
Incremental Backups auf Blockbasis und nicht mehr auf Filebasis und so eine Sache.
Also ich glaube, das ist, glaube ich, das ist eigentlich auch das coolste Feature
an diesem APFS, wenn das dann mal kommen wird.
Also das gibt es noch nicht gut, das war nämlich nochmal so eine Frage.
Wenn du einen Backup-Disk erstellst und du willst sie formatieren oder du willst
einen APFS benutzen, dann sagt das geht nicht, aber er würde sie dir umformatieren
und wenn du dann guckst, was er macht, dann ist das wieder ein HFS Plus.
Also da muss man noch, ich weiß nicht, ob das dann 10, nee, was ist das jetzt,
10, 13, 1 dann wird oder so, oder ob das dann erst in einem Jahr kommt,
aber kommt auf jeden Fall, weil die wollen das HFS Plus auf jeden Fall loswerden.
Das wäre dann der nächste Schritt.
Was ich schon ausprobiert habe, du kannst tatsächlich ein Fusion Drive in ein
APFS umwandeln, weil es für APFS so ein Fusion Drive ähnliches Ding gibt, was irgendwie,
komplett anders gebaut ist. Mir ist es nicht gelungen, davon zu booten.
Und es geht wohl auch noch nicht, aber du kannst die Teile tatsächlich bauen
und du kannst die mounten und auch verwenden.
Aber das heißt, du kannst jetzt noch keine Spinning Disc mit APFS formatieren.
Doch, doch.
Aber wenn du die Metallmaschine verwenden willst.
Dann sagt er, der geht nicht, ist inkompatibel.
Lame.
Kommt schon noch, hoffe ich. Und dann hat irgendwer gemeint,
dass auch hier, ich habe ja,
Netatalk auf dem FreeBSD, wo, was ich sozusagen so eine Time Machine simuliere
oder so eine Time Capsule simuliere und da meinte irgendwer,
das würde wohl mit High Sierra nicht mehr gehen, aber es geht bei mir zu Hause
weiterhin einwandfrei, ich muss es auch gar nichts machen, der sieht das weiterhin,
macht da seine Backups hin und das funktioniert irgendwie alles,
ohne dass ich da irgendwas machen musste.
Also muss man sich da keine Sorgen machen.
Irgendwas gab es noch, was mir irgendwie aufgestoßen ist in diesem High Sierra,
aber jetzt habe ich das hier zufällig irgendwo hingeschrieben.
Also ich meine, ich habe den Speed-Durchbruch auch noch nicht so richtig gemerkt,
aber es ist natürlich, hängt immer extrem von deiner Nutzung ab.
Ich meine, was halt APFS bringt gegenüber AFS Plus, es ist halt Multithreaded.
Ja, aber davon spüre ich halt noch nicht so viel.
Naja, weil du halt nicht so viel gleichzeitig an Action hast,
wenn du jetzt so Mac OS X Server.
Ja, oder du hast nicht eine entsprechend schnelle Festplatte.
Also das musst du natürlich auch haben, weil wenn du Spinning Rust hast,
dann wartet dein File-System.
Ich habe BSSDs auf beiden Seiten, also daran liegt es nicht.
Ich habe auch APFS auf Spinning Rust, das kam mir auch nicht langsam vor.
Ich finde sogar, es flutscht irgendwie einigermaßen.
Also auch diese Konvertierung, also die er ja macht auf der Festplatte,
wenn er das dann umwandelt, wo er die Daten ja da liegen lässt und nur die Metadaten
drumherum neu schreibt.
Ich fand das ganz schön schnell dafür, dass das eine Festplatte ist.
Also ich war da schon erstaunt, wie flott die das hinbekommen haben.
Zum Thema Fusion Drive nochmal.
Wer vorhat, einen Mac Mini mit Fusion Drive zu betreiben? Zumindest der 2012 Mac Mini.
Man kann nur von der Festplatte booten, an die man leichter rankommt.
Das ist, wenn man das Ding vor sich hat, aufgeschraubt, das ist die obere,
wenn es normal auf dem Tisch steht, die untere.
Das nur so als kleiner Tipp, dass es mir passiert, ich hatte die verkehrt rum
eingebaut und dann wollte er einfach nicht von der anderen Festplatte booten.
Und von extern kann man nicht booten, um das erstmal zu fixen?
Doch, kann man, aber er bootet trotzdem nicht von der anderen Festplatte.
Und du musst es dann alle Daten einmal umkopieren, also es ausbauen und nochmal wechseln schneller.
Ja, du willst natürlich auch einen Fusion Drive so bauen, dass er halt dann von der SSD bootet.
Deswegen muss die SSD aber dann an der Stelle eingebaut sein,
an der Stelle, von der er bootet, sonst geht's halt nicht.
Weil du dann auch schon gar nicht, also du kannst kein funktionierendes Fusion
Drive erzeugen und und und und. Also es funktioniert alles nicht.
Hat mich ziemlich lange Zeit gekostet, herauszufinden, woran es liegt,
bis ich irgendwann dachte, das probierst du jetzt mal aus. und tatsächlich, daran lag es dann auch.
Es ist unangenehm, das Teil dann komplett nochmal zu zerlegen, aber hey,
das nur so als kleiner Tipp am Rande.
Ja, eine Sache, die mir noch irgendwie aufgefallen ist, die ich auch gerne noch
so als Feature in macOS hätte,
mein Gitarrennärer, der ist ja noch so ein alter Windows-User,
aber mehr aus Gewohnheit und will jetzt halt nicht wechseln,
weil sein ganzes Audio-Setup so darauf dependet, wie er das dazu zurecht gefrickelt hat.
Aber der benutzt halt auch immer relativ extensiv seinen Audio-Mixer,
wo du ja so für verschiedene Audio-Subkomponenten die Lautstärke unabhängig regeln kannst.
Was ja bei macOS nach wie vor eher nicht so existiert.
Und dann hat Ruck am Möber, waren das glaube ich, der hat noch irgendwie letztens
Geburtstag gefeiert und hat dann so einen großen Blogpost und so mal gemacht.
Dann habe ich mal letztens wieder gesehen, dass die ja auch so ein Tool haben,
wo du für jede Applikation irgendwie das Volume einstellen kannst. War das Ruck am Möber?
Ja, wenn, dann war es Rucka Möwe. Aber ich glaube, die hatten mal sowas, ja.
Wenn man was für was einstellt, Volume, also Lautstärkredest du jetzt.
Oder sind nicht mal bei Festplatt.
Ja, das war mir jetzt ein bisschen zu schnell gerade.
Du warst abgelenkt.
Ich habe schon zugehört, aber ich wollte nur ganz sicher gehen. Ja,
es gibt da...
Also ich glaube, es war von Rucka Möwe.
Es gibt ein anderes Tool, das heißt, glaube ich, Volume Control.
tatsächlich, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht irre.
Aber das ist doch nicht von Luca Möber.
Achso. Soundsource heißt das Tool.
Ja, Soundsource ist halt einfach die Quelle.
Ach, das ist die Quelle.
Nee, es gibt noch so ein Volume Control, was tatsächlich dieses Programm,
Volume Mixer?
Irgendwie sowas. Aber auf jeden Fall am Ende des Tages dachte ich mir dann halt
auch so das wäre eigentlich auch echt mal einfach an der Zeit,
dass Apple sowas ins OS mal einbauen könnte. Das fände ich gut.
Ja, das habe ich, als ich noch einen Windows-Rechner als Zweitrechner hatte,
auch exzessiv genutzt, dass man das einfach hin und her schieben konnte von
den Applikationen, die Lautstärke.
Ja, kann auch nicht so schwer sein eigentlich, denkt man sich so.
Genau, Volume-Mixer heißt das.
Aber geht das nicht mit dem Audio-Video,
Audio-Midi-Setup-Tool geht das auch nicht, ne?
Nicht so, wie ich es gerne hätte, auf jeden Fall.
Ach, ich sehe gerade, Ruka Möber hat ja auch dieses Loopback-Cable-Free-Audio-Routing-Format.
Das sieht ja auch ganz interessant aus.
wie eigentlich das, was Apple ins OS einbauen könnte.
Naja, also da ist auf jeden Fall auch noch Luft. Vielleicht wird es ja dann,
das nächste macOS Release.
Das war es irgendwie nicht. Gibt es das nicht mehr?
Ich weiß auch, ich habe auch leider nicht mehr auf dem Schirm Jack OS X.
Sagt ja einer im Chat gerade. Oder eine, man weiß es nicht. Das heißt, das T ist genderlos.
äh, naja, nee, Jack war glaube ich auch nicht so richtig.
Das war ein relativ schickes Tool, was ich da gesehen hatte,
wo man so die Apps sehen konnte und dann hm, Volume. Naja.
Vielleicht war das von Rogue am Höber und das gibt es nicht mehr,
weil das war sicherlich ein richtig fieser Hack in Core Audio.
Ich meine, sie hat ja in Geburtstagsblogpost dadurch, dass es so ein Geburtstagsblogpost
oder sowas war, kann das sein, dass sie da auch einfach reflektiert hatten,
was sie so alles Schönes gemacht hatten.
Also ich habe diesen Volume-Mixer hier und der, wenn ich sage,
kaufen, dann bringt er mich auf eine Webseite, die mittlerweile bei GoDaddy
wieder zum Verkauf angeboten wird.
Also ich glaube, das Tool hat irgendwie keinen Markt gefunden.
Okay. Na gut, ja, dann,
Trauerspiel. Ja. Dann bin ich jetzt auch fertig mit meinem Rand.
Naja, Rand ist ja nicht eher so Wunschzettel. Könnte alles besser werden.
Kann ich noch zwei Verbesserungsanmerkungen zur letzten Sendung machen.
Ja? Zu welchem Thema denn bitte?
Prozessoren. Das erste war, du hattest behauptet, der 68K wäre ein 16-Bit-Prozessor gewesen.
Das ist natürlich Unfug gewesen.
Da könnt ihr aber den Experten fragen. Was wollt ihr wissen?
Nein, das war natürlich immer eine 32-Bit-Architektur, aber es gab halt am Anfang welche.
Aber es waren nur 24 Adressleitungen rausgelegt.
24, genau.
Deswegen, genau, ja, für den 64K.
Und ganz ehrlich gesagt, intern, eigentlich war es auch ein 16-Bit-Prozessor.
Er hat halt, wenn du, die Register waren 32 Bit, aber wenn du halt 32 Bit von
einem Register aufs andere radiert hast, dann hat er intern zwei 16-Bit-Operationen
gemacht, was du auch an den Taktzyklen sehen konntest.
Das kann sein, ja.
Eigentlich war das, ja.
Und das Zweite war, du hattest aufgezählt, welche Prozessor-Architekturen macOS schon mal gelaufen ist.
Und da haben wir dann auch nur bei irgendein 64-Bit.
Und da hast du zwei Architekturen vergessen, weil du nämlich vergessen hast,
dass macOS ja mal Next Step war.
Und Next Step, Open Step lief nämlich auch unter MIPS und unter Spark.
Naja, das ist jetzt aber...
Ah, interesting point.
Deswegen lief das, was jetzt macOS ist,
eigentlich schon auf allen Prozessor-Architekturen, die da draußen sind.
Ja, gut. Also eigentlich, ja. Ja gut, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen die Definition,
was versteht man sozusagen.
Ja, ja, deswegen sage ich das extra dazu.
Aber ich habe, wir haben nicht sogar irgendwie, ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht
mehr so ganz so sicher, wie viel Unfug wir noch beim 78.000er noch geredet haben.
Nö, sonst ist mir nicht weiter was aufgefallen.
Aber eine 64-Bit-Variante gab es ja nie, ne? Bei 78.000. Dann gab es PowerPC, das war 32 und 64.
Genau.
Das hat ja auch beides gehabt. So, das heißt, dann haben wir wirklich drei Architekturen.
und dann Intel 32 und Intel 64.
Genau.
So, und im Prinzip halt jetzt auch...
Ja gut, ARM, macOS ist jetzt nicht wirklich auf ARM und iOS ist ja auch nur,
weiß ich nicht, 60, 70 Prozent Overlap.
Naja, ich meine, der Overlap ist halt genau an der Stelle, wo es halt schwierig
ist, auf einen anderen Prozessor zu gehen.
Also ich meine, wenn du eine neue Architektur machst, dann musst du halt vor
allem den Kernel erstmal in den Griff kriegen. Der Rest ist eigentlich Klimbim.
Ja, wie du so richtig sagtest, das Application Framework ist das,
was ein bisschen sich unterscheidet.
Zumindest der obere Teil, nicht der untere Teil. Die ganzen Basics sind auch
gleich, aber der obere Teil hat AppKit gegen UIKit.
Aber der Rest ist eigentlich alles relativ gleich.
Bis hin zu wie Sprachen gehandhabt werden und Locally und diesen ganzen Ja.
Ich meine auch unabhängig davon, ob es gleich ist oder nicht,
aber es ist halt kein Problem, diese ganzen High-Level-Frameworks auf eine andere
Prozessor-Architektur zu kriegen, weil die haben da genau 0 oder wenn überhaupt
nur 0,001% Dependency drauf.
Also ich lehne ich mir jetzt wahrscheinlich auch wieder aus dem Fenster,
aber ich würde sagen, wenn du jetzt das App-Kit von macOS auf dem Arm kompilieren
wolltest, dann kriegst du das wahrscheinlich ohne größeren Schmerz hin.
Weil halt der untere Teil Foundation eben auf beiden Plattformen gleich ist, so gut wie.
Und da AppKit ja auf dem unteren Teil Foundation, genauso wie UIKit auf Foundation
beruft, bist du da relativ schnell dabei.
Ja gut, jetzt hast du Swift und die Swift Standard Library ist sowieso Foundation,
mehr oder weniger, fast alles davon. Also keine Ahnung.
Ist auf jeden Fall alles kein großes Ding, sondern die wirklich schwerwiegenden
Anpassungen machst du im Körnel,
weil da musst du halt die Spezifika voll ausnutzen, da musst du wissen,
wie das mit der Memory-Architektur funktioniert, wie das mit der VM funktioniert,
das sind die großen Klopper.
Also der eigentlich große Klopper zwischen UI-Kit und App-Kit ist halt,
das App-Kit wurde halt zu einer Zeit gebaut, wo du einen wirklichen Redraw hattest,
ne? Also das alte macOS, kannst du dich nur erinnern, wenn du Fenster gezogen
hast, hattest du nur die Outline, die gezogen wurde.
Dann hast du die Outline fallen lassen und dann wurde tatsächlich alles neu
gerendert und AppKit funktioniert im Prinzip immer noch so,
während UIKit davon ausgeht, dass jeder View eigentlich eine Textur auf der Grafikkarte ist.
Okay, aber worüber redest du jetzt? Ich dachte, wir reden jetzt über Prozessor-Plattformen.
Nee, weil es letztes Mal darum ging, ob Apple denn jetzt ARM in den Mac einbaut,
weil die ARM-Architektur jetzt so schnell geworden ist.
Und was ich da nur zu sagen wollte, wenn man jetzt,
wenn du irgendwann siehst, dass in macOS plötzlich die alte Art zu rendern deprecated
ist und zwar einmal komplett durchdeprecated wird, dann kannst du davon ausgehen,
dass es bis zur ARM-Architektur nicht mehr weit ist.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass wir Armen sehr viel früher sehen werden,
als dass sich da irgendwie nennenswert groß an alten Apps was ändern muss.
Weil ich sehe überhaupt nicht, was sich überhaupt ändern sollte im Programm.
Du musst ihn mindestens recompilen.
Ja, das war es dann aber auch.
Und du musst so ein Rosetta-Ding wahrscheinlich an den Start gehen.
Ja, irgendeine Emulation wieder. Aber auch das ist irgendwie die Fortschritte
im Bereich VMs und wie heißt das nochmal da drüber?
Der Top-Level- Hypervisor-Kram. Hyper-Hyper.
Mache ich mir überhaupt gar keine Sorgen. Das ist im Zweifelsfall auch alles
schon mit eingepreist in diese ganzen Hardware-Designs.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das so machen, wenn sie eine neue,
also nicht eine neue, aber wenn sie ARM auf dem Desktop rausbringen,
glaube ich, dann ändern sie auch ihr OS stark ab, weil das machen sie in einem,
weil die weg wollen von diesem OS X.
Nein, die wollen, wenn sie vor allem, also das sehe ich anders,
wenn sie jetzt, ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mir mittlerweile sicher,
dass sie an Prozessoren arbeiten, die potenziell auch in Macs feiern können.
Bestimmt.
Zumal sie eben auch da denselben Vorteil rausholen können im Prinzip wie auf iOS auch.
Weil, warum geht's denn geschwindigkeitsmäßig gerade nicht so richtig voran?
Vor allem, weil halt alles von Intel abhängt. Es gibt da nicht so richtig viel Innovation.
AMD baut zwar im Prinzip kompatible Dinge, aber für ganz andere Märkte.
Und Intel wiederum versucht Pakete rauszubringen, die mehr oder weniger den
gesamten Markt abdecken, die alle,
Möglichkeiten haben und dann hast du da noch Abstufung und hier und da und mit
so und so viel Kern und mit so und so viel dieses und jenes aber so richtig
mal so optimiert auf den Bedarf hin eines MacBook Air oder wie auch immer das
aktuelle Modell dann wieder heißen wird,
irgendwann werden sie wieder das Air zurückbringen. Und,
Wenn man sich das jetzt anschaut, was Apple bei dem A11 gemacht hat,
im Vergleich zu den Prozessoren, die jetzt in der Android-Welt verbaut werden, die also von...
Ja, Faktor 2 und drüber.
Ja, aber es ist auch interessant zu sehen, warum. Also warum sind die eigentlich so schnell?
Und ein Punkt ist, dieser A11 ist einfach mal doppelt so groß.
Die haben da einfach viel mehr Zeug drauf. Die haben da Unsummen an Cache untergebracht.
So wie 8 Megabyte, Level 2 Cache, gib ihm und so weiter. Das ist so,
wenn wir die anderen halt so bei 2, 3 rumkrebsen.
Und keiner baut halt so eine Prozessoren, weil der Markt dann zu spezifisch
wäre und als allgemeiner Anbieter wirst du das halt so nicht los.
Und Apple wiederum weiß halt ganz genau, was sie eigentlich brauchen und macht
ihre Prozessoren mittlerweile genau auf diesen Bedarf hin.
Und wenn sie dasselbe Spiel jetzt auch noch in Laptops und warum nicht auch
in Desktops machen, ist da eine Menge zu holen.
Das Einzige, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, was problematisch ist und was so
ein bisschen ein Stolperstein in der Sache ist, ist halt,
dass du die ganze Serverwelt halt auf Intel läuft und das halt,
also ich kenne es halt, viele von den Backend-Entwicklern machen halt Docker.
Docker kann man jetzt toll oder scheiße finden, aber es wird halt verwendet. und die.
Ganze Serverwelt läuft nicht auf Intel.
Ja aber viele machen halt Docker also das ist gerade der heiße Scheiß warum
auch immer ja aber Docker.
Läuft auch auf anderen Prozessoren das ist davon nicht abhängig.
Ist mir jetzt so nicht bekannt also wenn du einen Docker Container baust was ist.
Das für Unix.
Naja, für Linux, für ein ganz bestimmtes Linux.
Ja, aber es ist ja nicht prozessorabhängig.
Ja, im Prinzip nicht, aber...
Das Thema ist sozusagen, wie geht es weiter mit den Prozessorplattformen und
welche Chancen hat ARM jetzt hier für Änderungen zu sorgen.
Und auf dem Servermarkt hast du sehr wohl mittlerweile auch armbasierte Server,
weil die halt genau denselben Vorteil bieten wie eben hier auf iOS und im Prinzip
eben auch in einem Laptop auch.
Die ziehen einfach weniger Strom und Strom ist ein echtes Thema.
Das macht Hitze, der muss irgendwo herkommen, der Strom.
Du brauchst halt so mega skalierende Factories,
die bauen sich da komplette Hallen voll mit irgendwie ihren CPU-Blades und da
ist dann halt einfach genug Strom überhaupt ranzukriegen, damit die Scheiße
überhaupt läuft, ist eins dieser Probleme und dann natürlich auch noch dafür zu bezahlen.
Du darfst halt deinen Tesla nicht laden.
Ja, aber deswegen kommt auch dort schon Arm zum Einsatz.
Ein weiterer Grund, glaube ich, also da habe ich jetzt keine Erkenntnisse,
aber vor einiger Zeit hat auch Apple angekündigt, dass sie jetzt überhaupt gar
keine Ready-to-Run Mainboards mehr in ihre Server reinstecken.
Wie?
Na, wegen Backdoors in den CPUs.
Die haben Supermicro als Vendor für ihre Motherboards rausgeschmissen,
weil die ja irgendwie ein Backdoor drin war oder so, die Supermicro nicht dicht
machen wollte oder was auch immer.
Wenn Apple mal eine ordentliche Server-Hardware auf den Markt bringen würde,
dann wäre ich der Letzte, der da weinen würde.
Die bringen die gar nicht in den Markt. Die bringen die in ihre Cloud.
Benutzen sie einfach selbst.
Ja, aber es gibt genug Firmen, die wollen ihre eigene Hardware haben.
Also ich kann mir bei uns nicht vorstellen, dass das durchgeht,
dass wir irgendwas auf einer Apple Cloud machen. Das ist einfach nicht drin.
Nein, darum geht es ja auch nicht. Apple hat eine Cloud. Und da stehen so viele
Büchsen drin, dass es sich lohnt, dafür eigene Systeme zu entwickeln.
Die können sich das ja auch machen.
Die Google das sicherlich auch macht.
Aber trotzdem glaube ich nicht, dass Apple einfach nur demnächst ein Laptop
rausbringt, wo dann anstatt ein Intel in den Arm drin ist.
Das glaube ich ist einfach als Schritt so wenig. Wenn die schon so einen Move
machen, dann können die doch da gleich noch viel mehr mit durchschieben.
Ich glaube schon, dass sie dann irgendwie das OS X oder iOS oder was auch immer,
also von welchem es mehr sein wird, aber dass es ein neues wird.
Wahrscheinlich ist es App-only, nicht mehr offen, nicht mehr offenes Filesystem.
Die wollen doch gleich da die Boundaries verschieben.
Nein, das ist halt schon unverstanden.
Welchen Vorteil hätten die denn nur die CPU zu wechseln, außer so ein bisschen Geldvorteil?
Doppelt so schnell, doppelt so viel Akku und für sie der halbe Preis.
Kannst du dich an den letzten CPU-Wechsel erinnern? Kannst du dich an den letzten CPU-Wechsel erinnern?
Da haben sie nicht mal das Gehäuse der Geräte geändert.
Die sahen nach wie vor genauso aus. Und wenn du nicht wusstest,
dass wenn da MacBook draufsteht statt Powerbook, dass da ein anderer Prozessor
drin ist, dann wusstest du auch nicht, dass da ein anderer Prozessor drin ist. Das war so gewollt.
Man schiebt den Leuten eine andere Architektur unter. Die meisten Apple-Kunden merken das nicht.
Sie haben jetzt ein anderes Gerät. Das sieht genauso aus, das fühlt sich genauso
an und denen ist es dann letzten Endes egal.
Wenn du allerdings anfängst, alles zu ändern, dann ist irgendein Problem an
der Maschine und dann schieben sie es auf die Prozessor-Architektur.
Das willst du auf jeden Fall nicht haben.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, die wollen dieses OS X loswerden oder zumindest
dichter kriegen. Das ist denen alles viel zu offen.
Und ich glaube, mit einem Arm würden sie das versuchen, den Leuten unterzuschieben.
Nee. Wir reden wirklich von zwei unterschiedlichen Fragen.
Diese Frage, wohin entwickelt sich OS X oder macOS?
Irgendwohin.
Wo soll es sich hin entwickeln? Man merkt, dass sie in den letzten Jahren nichts gemacht haben.
Das würde ich so jetzt nicht sagen, dass sie nichts gemacht hätten.
Na, auf jeden Fall nicht viel Signifikantes.
Wir bringen jetzt iOS und OS
X langsam wieder zusammen. Rettel auf beiden Seiten und so weiter, APFS.
Was heißt nicht Signifikant? Können wir gleich nochmal debattieren.
Ich will nochmal kurz diese Plattform, ich will es einfach erstmal trennen.
Die Frage, auf welcher Hardware läuft der Scheiß und wohin geht unser OS?
Zwei Fragen. Selbst wenn sie heute komplett, also wenn jetzt 2018 kein einziger
Intel-Mac mehr erscheint.
Müssen sie ja diese ganze Geschichte noch mindestens fünf, sechs Jahre lang mitziehen.
Software, die läuft, die nicht angefasst wird, die noch lange emuliert werden
muss. Das ist alles noch da.
Bis erstmal alle Developer… Hat das so lange gedauert bei PowerPC auf Intel?
Fünf, sechs Jahre nicht.
Oder? Ja, aber kannst du aber mal schwer davon ausgehen, dass auch noch fünf
Jahre, nachdem der erste Intel rausgekommen ist, dass es irgendwo wichtige Installationen
gab, wo Power-PC-Software gibt, die noch nicht und dann auch nie wieder konvertiert wurde.
Ich ziehe den Redebeitrag zurück.
Genau, also das ist nichts, was man heute auf morgen abstreifen kann.
Trotzdem glaube ich, dass sie das extrem beschleunigen können.
Weil an all den Bereichen, wo sie einen Finger drauf haben, sie sehr schnell handeln können.
Mit dem nächsten OS musst du dann halt irgendwie nochmal alles submitten und
das Bundle für den Arm muss einfach mit dabei sein.
Oder sie konvertieren dir das automatisch schon im App Store und alle Apps,
die du runterlädst, sind schon mal so halb beschleunigt und pipapo, keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall, da können sie eine Menge machen. Die ganze Infrastruktur ist
mittlerweile so viel besser.
Ja, also als sie da von 68k auf PowerPC gegangen ist, was war das damals für ein Krampf?
Da hatten sie ja noch nicht mal eine Entwicklungsumgebung auf diese Einfluss hatten.
Doch klar, Xcode gab es doch damals schon.
68k auf PowerPC.
Achso, das, ja, okay. Ja, okay, das war ja...
Da war der einzige Compiler-Hersteller noch nicht mal, der war Inhouse.
Es gab aber den Macintosh-Programmers-Workshop.
Code Warrior, alle haben Code Warrior gemacht, aber die Bude gehörte ihnen halt
nicht. Und deswegen hatten sie da halt auch keinen Einfluss.
Und davon sind sie mittlerweile meilenweit entfernt.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Das heißt, ich glaube, dass das technisch, es ist zwar kein kleines Unterfangen,
Aber das kriegen sie gewuppt. So, wenn sie das wollen, dann gehen sie da so,
generalstabsmäßig ran und dann werden wir Konversionsraten sehen,
dass du nach drei Jahren hast du
irgendwie 80% der Rechner, auf denen kein Intel-Code mehr schlummert. So.
Sag ich jetzt mal so. Und das OS wird sich genauso graduell weiterentwickeln
und es wird auch noch lange, lange, lange Zeit noch für Intel geliefert werden,
bis dann die letzten Intel-Rechner hinten rausfallen,
da vergehen dann halt wirklich nochmal sechs, sieben, acht Jahre.
Ja, du hast halt nicht diesen Handy-Schweine-Zyklus von zwei Jahren.
Ja, doch da leben die Geräte ja noch fünf Jahre.
Ja, aber du siehst in den Zahlen sehr deutlich, dass die fünf Jahre leben, mehr, länger nicht.
Und du hast nach drei Jahren sind die schon im einstelligen Prozentbereich,
die Geräte, die noch verwendet werden.
Ja gut, auch im Handy-Bereich. Ja, ja, im Handy-Bereich. Powered by 2009 Architecture.
Deswegen sag ich ja, du hast beim Rechner nicht den Schweinezyklus vom Handy,
wo es halt so schnell geht. Deswegen dauert es ein bisschen.
Genau, außerdem müssen sie den Mac Pro bis in alle Ewigkeiten unterstützen.
Das werden sie bestimmt nur für dich tun.
Genau.
Dann holt er seine Twitterkraft nämlich raus und kriegt dann von Apple höchstpersönlich.
So, aber wenn sie diesen Schritt jetzt machen, wo du meinst,
was haben sie denn davon?
Ich hab's ja gerade schon aufgezählt. also sie können erstmal Prozessoren bauen,
die genau auf den Bedarf des Geräts hin zugeschnitten sind ne,
Ist schnell bei den typischen Anwendungen, die darauf gefahren werden.
Verbraucht unsäglich wenig Strom im Vergleich zu dem, was wir derzeit haben.
Kostet sie selber, weil sie da die Economy of Scale haben, wahrscheinlich nochmal
viel weniger, weil sie halt auch nicht irgendwie noch eine andere Firma mit aushalten müssen.
Diese ganzen Middlemen werden halt auch nochmal weggegraben.
Und sie werden natürlich auch viel des Developments ohnehin schon machen,
weil sie das eben für iOS ohnehin brauchen. Aber ich sehe überhaupt gar keinen
Grund, warum die nicht in der Lage sein sollen, da bombastische Multicore-Prozessoren rauszukommen.
Nein, in der Lage sind die locker. Das ist ja nicht das Ding.
Aber ich glaube, dass sie auch gerne ihr OS, selbst wenn das OS X so bleibt,
aber dass sie es gerne dicht hätten.
So mit Signierung und dem ganzen Zeug, dass du halt überhaupt gar keine Chance
mehr hast, da ranzukommen.
Das geht zwar schon so ein bisschen unter OS X, aber eigentlich kann ich immer
noch in den Emergency-Modus da booten. Irgendwie rumspielen, wieder zurückbooten.
Ja, aber das ist auch unabhängig vom Prozessor. Das ist eine vollkommen andere Debatte.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch ein bisschen, wenn sie das ändern, dann macht das ja
Sinn, dass wenn sie eine neue CPU bringen, das alles auf einen Schlag zu machen
und nicht ein halbes Jahr später schon wieder eine größere Änderung,
sondern die überlegen sich dann großen Schwung, ihre Haufen an Features,
die sie gerne hätten und dann bringen die das alles auf einmal.
Naja, also ich meine, so ein OS, was irgendwie nicht vulnerable ist,
finde ich ja auch echt ein Feature.
Ja, das werden nicht einfach nur die CPU wechseln, da werden schon noch viele,
viele andere Änderungen mit kommen.
Nee klar, aber ich rede ja jetzt nur über diesen Aspekt des CPU-Wechsels und
die Wahrscheinlichkeit oder die Machbarkeit dessen.
Und ich halte es halt für, ich bin zu 100% davon überzeugt, dass alles,
was sie derzeit an Hardware haben, da läuft auch heute schon macOS drauf.
Kannst du mir nicht erzählen, dass es da nicht irgendein A11-Powered-Rechner gibt?
Bin ich voll einer Meinung mit dir.
High Sierra Budits gibt es. Das ist kein Prototyp für die nächste Generation, aber läuft einfach.
Sie werden das benchmarken bis zum Get-No und wollen einfach wissen, was sind die Odds.
Und wenn sie sich halt dann dazu entscheiden, dann können sie das halt so machen,
dass sie irgendwie zwei oder drei Varianten dieses Prozessors bauen,
der dann halt irgendwie vom normalen MacBook zum Pro,
zum iMac und weißer Geier vielleicht halt auch zu einem Mac Pro hin,
durchskaliert oder andersrum, die nichts kostet.
Du kannst dann ein Mac OS auf einem iPad Pro booten. Das wäre ja auch mal nicht verkehrt.
Doch, es wäre verkehrt, weil es kein richtiger Computer hat, keine Escape-Taste.
Er hat keine Tastatur erstmal, aber ich meine, wenn der Escape-Taste ist ja kein Argument.
Hat meiner auch nicht.
Achso, ist ja auch kein richtiger Computer.
Tja.
Soviel dazu. Also ich denke mal, wir sind da nicht mehr so weit voll entfernt.
Ne, ich hab ja gesagt 2017, aber es wird eng. Ich glaub, dieses Jahr wird das nix mehr.
Ne. Ich glaub auch noch nicht an nächstes Jahr.
Doch, doch, doch.
Aber ich sag mal so ab 2019, 20...
Also jetzt wollen sie erst mal wieder einen ordentlichen Mac Pro rausbringen.
Das haben sie ja quasi versprochen im Roundtable.
Jetzt kommt erst mal der iMac Pro, oder?
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie einen Mac Pro mit einem Armprozessor
rausbringen, das geht für mich nicht so ganz zusammen.
Der ist dann zwar total modular und kann ausgetauscht werden,
aber es gibt die CPUs nur von Apple.
Man kann ja über Intel sagen.
Was man will, aber so im High-End-Bereich, die Dinger rocken da schon ordentlich
los. Also wenn auch jetzt die frischen AMDs da vergleichen.
Ja, aber kosten auch ordentlich.
Klar, kosten auch ordentlich, aber die Leute kaufen das auch.
Also dieser 6-Core-Intel ist, glaube ich, immer noch deutlich schneller als
der 8-Core-AMD, war das so?
Also klar, ist wahrscheinlich trotzdem teurer, aber auch Single-Thread-Performance
ist deutlich besser bei Intel, glaube ich.
Aber das iPhone neu ist schneller als unser Mac Pro. Oder genauso schnell.
Single-Thread.
Ja, hat doch. Tim, was hast du in der letzten Sendung erzählt,
als wir hier gegeekbencht haben?
Ja, iPhone ist schneller. Also der A11 ist schneller als im Single.
Du hast 15 Zoll? Ich glaube der 15er ist gerade noch ein paar Tacken.
Aber nur.
Aber so in der Liga.
Verstehe.
Und Multicore ist auch ganz ordentlich. Aber da sind die MacBooks noch besser. Also 1.8.
Plus haben wir jetzt in der Firma als Testgerät bestellt. Oh,
ich habe damit noch nicht so viel gemacht.
Das war jetzt nicht so spannend. Sie holen diese Geschwindigkeit halt aus dem Custom-Design raus.
Also es ist halt gar nicht mal so, dass sie da jetzt irgendwie so eine ganz
neuartige Art und Weise haben, Instruktionen zu verarbeiten. Ich glaube da...
Geht ja auch nicht, das kaufen sie ja von Arm ein, das ist ja immer gleich eigentlich.
Nein, sie kaufen nur die Architektur.
Sie lizenzieren glaube ich...
Lizenzieren ausschließlich die Architektur. Das Design, Apple ist der einzige,
Hersteller, der selber das Arm Design macht.
Ja.
Und damit auch Produkte verkauft.
Das heißt, den Microcode machen sie schon selber?
Ja, sie machen alles selber.
Okay, okay.
Also im Prinzip lizenzieren sie den Befehlssatz und stricken da einen Prozessor drum.
Das ist auch das, was sich, glaube ich, wenig Leute klar machen,
wie stark Apple an der Stelle schon aufgestellt ist.
Die kaufen nicht irgendwie was Fertiges und kleben ihren Apfel da oben drauf,
sondern die holen sich quasi im Wesentlichen die Erlaubnis.
Ja.
Und ich meine, die haben da Top-Prozessor-Design, Leute. Ich meine, da muss man...
Das ist diese Power-PC-Bude, die sie irgendwann aufgetaucht haben.
Das ist diese alte PA-Risk, hieß die, glaube ich, damals.
PA-Semi.
Genau, PE-Semi, genau. Und ich weiß nicht, wie viel Prozent der ursprünglichen
Mannschaft da noch überhaupt an Bord sind, aber diese Prozessor-Entwicklungsabteilung,
von der man halt eigentlich fast nichts mitbekommt, also eigentlich gar nichts,
ist eine der krassesten Entities in diesem ganzen Apple-Schiff,
weil die hauen einfach mal top-notch Hardware raus.
Testen wahrscheinlich gerade den A12.
Und testen wahrscheinlich gerade den A12 und designen den A14.
Die können sich halt auch austoben wie nix Gutes.
Ich hab mir gerade mal diese Zahlen neulich mal angeschaut.
Also wie viel mehr Cash da drauf ist.
Also sie machen das einfach mit viel, weil sie sich halt erlauben können,
so große Dice da drauf zu bauen, weil sie wissen, von dem Teil bauen wir jetzt
so und so viele Millionen.
Und der ist halt jetzt auch in jeder Hinsicht genau auf den Bedarf dieses Telefons
ausgelegt, was sie dann noch alles drauf haben jetzt mit ihrer Machine Learning
Beschleunigungs-Hardware und die GPU, die sie ja jetzt auch noch machen.
Ja, aber sie können auch mehr Geld nehmen. Also ein großes DAI kostet halt auch
mehr Geld, weil die Ausfallrate halt höher ist.
Je größer das DAI ist. Dann wiederum in der Kalkulation der kompletten Marge
des Telefons, deswegen funktioniert das.
Also die anderen könnten sich das gar nicht erlauben, solche Dinger zu bauen,
weil das der Markt nicht hergibt, weil jeder einzelne Komponentenhersteller,
der in dieser kompletten Toolchain drin ist, die bei Apple halt einfach nur Apple ist,
wollen natürlich alle noch irgendwie mitverdienen, müssen das Ding auch am Markt
an mehr als einen verkaufen, damit es sich lohnt und das lohnt sich halt nicht.
Und deswegen sieht das da eben so aus, wie es aussieht.
Sie könnten ja so einen Stein in die alten MacBook Airs reinhauen,
weil ich meine, dieses 11 Zoll MacBook Air wäre so ein tolles Reisenotebook,
wenn das mal ein Update bekommen würde.
Dafür wäre es halt wirklich genau das Richtige.
Aber sie wollen dir ja so ein MacBook One Port.
Niemals.
Ja, aber da setzt man sich einmal aus Versehen drauf und mehrere Teile oder
ein angenehmes Sitzkissen, je nachdem. Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber ich meine, ich fand das halt schon sehr stabil im Vergleich zu dem 12 Zoll.
Also es wäre halt einfach, wenn wir schon bei der Wunschkiste sind, also das wäre so meins.
Was genau wäre deins?
Ein Update auf das MacBook Air 11 Zoll mit so einem schnellen Prozessor,
der wenig Strom verbraucht fürs Reisen und, ja ich muss sogar sagen,
da würde ich auch noch fast wahrscheinlich auf einen Retina-Display verzichten.
Ja, das wäre aber auch noch ein guter Teil des Updates.
Genau, also es wäre ganz, ganz geil das zu haben, aber das ist das Einzige,
worauf ich dann sagen könnte.
Genau, mit genau der Tastatur, Trackpad, es ist alles perfekt,
es ist alles super mit dem Ding.
Und das hättet ihr euch mal vor drei, vier Jahren wünschen können.
Das habe ich mir vor drei, vier Jahren schon gewünscht.
Tja.
Ich kann mich gar nicht erinnern, mir jemals was anderes gewünscht zu haben.
Manchmal werden Wünsche eben doch nicht wahr.
Wie motivierend.
Naja, noch nicht. Ich sag dir, die scheitern mit diesem Scheißdreck.
Dieser ganze Touchbar-Kram, Apple hat im letzten Quartal 5% Einbruch gehabt. 5% weniger Mix.
Ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass sie Tracking darüber haben,
wie stark das tatsächlich benutzt wird und wahrscheinlich alle bedröppelt da
sitzen und merken, niemand verwendet die Scheiße. Also ihr habt ja letztes Mal darüber geredet.
Ich benutze es auch nur fürs Locken.
Lauter leiser, heller, dunkler.
Nee, nicht mal das. Nur Locken.
Aber wie machst du lauter leiser? Übers Menü oder was?
Gar nicht auf Arbeit wahrscheinlich. Gar nichts, immer aus. Also ich habe statt
lauter leiser habe ich Ton an, aus da noch, aber die benutze ich eigentlich auch.
Und Helligkeit hast du eh externen Bildschirm, hast du eh volle Pulle.
Richtig.
Ja gut, du benutzt dein Laptop ja auch nicht als Laptop.
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Aber Touch-ID braucht jetzt auch keiner mehr. Ich meine, sollen sie da mal ihren
A13 da reinbauen, dann haben sie da noch Face-ID drin in dem Laptop und dann
lächelst du einfach mal kurz rein und dann hast du schon was geshoppt.
Geil.
Ja, ich benutze ja.
Aber das mit dem Face-ID.
Da sagst du was.
Face ID bei Laptop, I want.
Ja, das wird kommen.
Ja, ich hoffe.
Aber dann kannst du es nicht mehr abkleben.
Aber dann brauchen sie auch diesen Prozessor.
Naja, dann bauen sie ihn halt rein.
Jetzt wo sie gerade die ZenQ-Englave geknackt haben, ne?
Was?
Ja, hat was geknackt.
Gab es doch so einen Artikel, die haben das über so...
Strom-Power-Attacken irgendwie aufgehackt. Die legen da den Strom,
lassen den Strom so lange flattern, bis die Secure-Enklave irgendwie so doll
Fehler macht, dass sie irgendwie in so einen Zustand kommt, wo sie da irgendwie reinkommen.
Da war so ein Artikel vor ein, zwei Wochen, irgendwie bei Heiß oder wo auch immer.
Ach echt?
Ja, irgendwann wird alles gehackt, Jungs.
Na gut, aber nur wenn man das Teil auf dem Tisch hast jetzt sozusagen.
Nee, sie konnten das mit dem Strom, weil es gibt ja Strom- Sparfunktionen im
OS, sie konnten das über Remote machen.
Also nix mit offenes Gerät, sondern Remote.
Was heißt Remote?
Remote übers Netz.
Wie soll ich das Netz?
Strom flackern?
Jungs, also die hacken sich irgendwie in euer Telefon rein erstmal und sind
rot. Dann legen sie los und nutzen die.
Das geht ja auch total einfach.
Passiert sowieso alle drei Tage. Dann fangen sie an, die Stromsparfunktionen
ist noch nie passiert, dass einer sich rot holt und auf dem Telefon...
Nein, haben wir noch nie gesehen.
Bist du jetzt gerade bei Android?
Mit.
Wo meinst du, wo die ganzen Jailbrakes auf dem Telefon, wo die alle herkommen? Alles Routexport.
Aber was für Jailbrakes gibt es denn gerade für das aktuelle OS?
Ja, musst du dich mal drum kümmern. Gibt es auf jeden Fall immer wieder.
Und wenn es jetzt keinen gibt, gibt es den in drei Wochen.
Ja, aber nichts ist endemisch.
Ja, Jungs, wollt ihr mir das jetzt ausreden, dass das alles voll sicher ist?
Ich habe nur gesagt, nichts ist bisher endemisch.
Jedenfalls können die bei Remote, über die Stromsparfunktion für die Syncure-Enklave
lassen sie die so lange hin und her flippen, bis das Ding anfängt Fehler zu
machen, bis sie dann da rankommen, wo sie ran wollen.
Ich habe das jetzt nicht hundertprozentig im Kopf, aber ihr könnt euch das ja mal durchlesen.
Okay. iPhone 5S, ne? Um das mal...
War das das 5S? Ich weiß nicht, welches das war.
Ich habe eins zu Hause. Das ist jetzt der Artikel, den ich jetzt auf Heise gefunden habe.
Und wann ist denn der?
18.8.
Zwei Monate.
War kürzer. Aber kann sein, dass das der ist.
Ja, such doch mal. Ich weiß noch nicht, ich habe es noch nicht so weit durchgelesen,
um zu sagen, dass es jetzt hier mit Strom hin und her gewackelt wurde.
Hier ist auf jeden Fall ein Schlüssel gelegt. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie er den geholt hat.
Äh, bla bla bla.
Der Hacker Xerub. Oder Ad Xerub.
Ja, okay, ich finde auch nur, dass hier vom 18.8. so circa alles.
Kann schon sein, dass das das dann ist.
Fake News, Dennis, Fake News.
Ist es Fake News? Ne.
Naja, so kommst du mir jetzt hier gerade rüber.
Zumindest dünnes Eis.
Ja, also willst du Präsident werden oder was?
Euer Problem ist, dass ihr gerne hättet, dass es sicher ist,
aber es ist eigentlich... Natürlich hätten wir das gerne. Nix ist sicher.
Das wissen wir alle, aber das klang jetzt gerade sehr vereinfacht und so,
als ob jedes Script-Kiddy das mal eben machen könnte.
Olfo.
Die haben das auch nicht released, haben das auch an Apple durchgereicht,
aber da das halt das kannst du halt nicht so einfach fixen, da den Strom flippen
zu lassen, da müssen sich schon ein bisschen was Besseres einfallen.
Also wenn die da eine 9-Volt-Batterie an meinen Lightning-Port ranhalten und
dann fällt da unten mein Fingerabdruck raus, dann bin ich dabei.
Hab ich nie gesagt.
Side-Channel-Attack.
Ja, aber dann kriege ich das Flattern auf jeden Fall. Trotz aller Idee.
Natürlich muss das gesichert werden. A7 ist halt jetzt auch schon wieder so vier Generationen her.
Aber trotzdem. Face-ID, mal ehrlich. Im Laptop würde das mal total Sinn machen.
Ich benutze es nicht.
Wieso nicht?
Ich dachte, du willst so ein Phone haben.
Skeptisch bezüglich was? Dass es nicht funktioniert?
Nee.
False positives.
Nee. Also hier nochmal bei also Fingerabdruck zum Beispiel, also im Vergleich zum Passwort,
zumindest in Deutschland, in den USA ist es vielleicht anders und in anderen
Ländern auch, aber wenn du jetzt in eine Polizeikontrolle kommst und so weiter,
kann sie dich halt nicht zwingen dein Passwort zu verraten, aber sie können
dich halt zwingen mal den Daumen da drauf zu halten.
Jetzt gibt es ja den SOS-Mode in iOS 11.
Ja, ich meine wie das dann integriert ist, ist ja eine ganz andere Frage.
Aber so dieses ich gehe von meinem Tisch weg, das Ding lockt,
ich komme irgendwie bei der Teefüche wieder und so.
Ich finde das auch ein bisschen creepy, wenn die ganze Zeit einfach diese Kamera an ist.
Wirklich? Das findest du creepy?
Ja, deswegen hat Lendi ja auch dieses Ding hier auf dem Phone,
damit das nicht passiert. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es Dauer offen.
Ja, das halte ich aber nur zu dir, Lid.
Die macht das auch nur darauf, damit sie nicht wieder abkratzen muss,
weil sie regelmäßig in die coolen Clubs rein muss.
Welche coolen Clubs?
Das darf ich jetzt nicht sagen. So cool sind die.
Da darfst du nicht mit Telefon rein? So cool sind die?
Nein, dir wird auf jeden Fall die Kamera abgeklebt. Findest du gar nicht?
Weil es auch so secret ist, wie rannt sich diese Clubs dann so von innen aus.
Die Clubs sind wahrscheinlich nicht so interessant. Wahrscheinlich haben die
Leute wenig an. Ist das der Dings Clubs hier?
Wie heißt der? Nein, nein, nein.
Nein, das ist wirklich. Ich war irgendwie als...
Kick-Klub.
Nein, ich glaube jetzt nicht.
Nee, nee, ich war auch irgendwie im Sommer zwölf Uhr so after,
aber am Sonntag irgendwie so nur noch so ein paar verstrahlte Seelen,
die da so in der Sonne lagen und gehen dann so rein, alles total schnell, so Kamera abkleben.
Echt so, ich gucke mich so um, irgendwie alles so ranzig halt,
wie so ein Club bei Tag aussieht. so, ne? Okay, okay, ja.
Ja, es ist ja ein ethisch-moralisches Statement, das ich auch nachvollziehen kann.
Nämlich dieses, wir können dir zwar nichts garantieren, aber die Ansage ist, lass es bleiben. Ja.
Oder geht's da drum, dass du keine Verschatteten...
Ja.
Ja, wer macht denn sowas?
Ja, wer macht denn sowas? Also, hat man davon schon mal gehört,
dass Leute andere Leute auf Partys...
Also, In meiner sozialen Bubble, zumindest im Nerd-Umfeld, ist das nicht vorgekommen.
Ja, weil Leute, die das machen wollen, die lassen sich doch nicht von einer abgeklebten Kamera.
Nein, es geht natürlich nicht.
Es ist ja auch eine Sensibilisierung gleich am Eingang.
Sehr schön, das ist vielleicht das Wort, was ich gesagt habe.
Eine Sensibilisierung, das ist einfach ein Statement. Es ist so ein,
weißt du, du müsstest jetzt das Ding wieder abmachen, bevor du mal eben ein Foto schießen kannst.
Wenn du da, ich meine, du kannst natürlich fünf Telefone in der Hosentasche
haben und wir wissen alle, dass das sozusagen niemand davon abhält.
Aber es ist halt ein Appell, der eben sich durch diesen Inconvenience-Kleber quasi ausgeschafft.
So und dann kommen wir mal zu dieser bescheuerten Kamera zurück,
die dann die ganze Zeit an ist. Im Club sagst du, okay, lass mir das Ding drüber kleben.
Und wo schleppst du überall deinen Rechner mit hin?
Und wo bleibt der gegebenenfalls dann doch mal aufgeklappt stehen?
Und da ist dann nichts drüber, aber im Club ist es dir wichtiger?
Na, ich weiß ja nicht.
Also mir gehen dann so ganz andere Fantasien gerade durch den Kopf.
Ein weiteres ethisch-moralisches Problemfeld sein.
Ja, aber die Kamera ist ja nur dann an, wenn du einen Unlock machen möchtest.
Sprich, wenn du eigentlich gelockt hast.
Ja, genau. Und vielleicht passiert es, dass man weggeht, weil man,
naja, egal. Also ich kann mir das schon vorstellen, dass das einfach,
also ich finde das nicht geil.
Ich bin auch zu oldschool für, ich tippe mein Passwort gerne ein.
Ich auch.
Ich preise noch mal die Uhr an.
Dann würde ich mir eher noch die Uhr kaufen, als meine Gesichtin.
Ich hatte schon vor,
oh Gott, das muss ja ewig lange her sein, vor so 10, mein iPhone ist jetzt 10
Jahre alt, das muss dann also so 12 Jahre her sein oder noch länger, da hatte ich so ein,
Telefon von Sony Ericsson. Genau, Sony Ericsson. Und, ähm.
Dieses hellblaue Ding da?
Ja, so ein bisschen blau.
Du hattest ein Sony Ericsson.
Ich hatte ein Sony Ericsson Telefon. Das war damals relativ cool,
weil das hatte halt schon irgendwie Bluetooth.
Und es hatte auch irgendwie so eine, also smart würde ich jetzt mal nicht sagen,
aber da lief schon Software drauf.
So die Dinge tat. Und.
Snake.
Es gab dann den Salling.
Salling Clicker?
Damals auf dem Mac, mit dem du dann dein Telefon als Präsentationsremote benutzen
konntest, was der Brüller war.
Also man hatte das erste Mal, nein, das war für jeden der Brüller,
der Präsentationen gemacht hat, weil so Funk remote,
waren einfach not a thing zu dem Zeitpunkt und auf einmal ging das sozusagen
mit deinem Telefon, was du halt im Zweifelsfall auch mal dabei hast.
Und dann hat er dann irgendwann auch nochmal dieses Unlock-Feature eingebaut,
was sicherlich nicht besonders sicher designt war, aber es ging.
Ich ging weg von meinem Rechner und weil mein Telefon nicht mehr gesehen wurde,
hat er halt automatisch gelockt und als ich wieder reinkam, hat er automatisch geanlockt.
Und das war so future-mäßig, das war so grandios. Hatte natürlich so ein paar Probleme.
Ich war dann auf so einem Hack-Meeting in Italien, das war ganz lustig und jemand
fragte, ja kann ich mal hier kurz brausen und so weiter.
Ja mach mal, ich geh mal kurz einen Kaffee holen, bin halt irgendwie die Treppe
hoch und dann hat sich natürlich die Kiste gleich wieder gelockt,
weil mein Telefon halt nicht mehr zu sehen war.
Ich hatte ja dieses schöne P800, das war das erste nicht-Compact-Gerät,
glaube ich, wo die Gate5-Software auch drauf lief. Oder zumindest eins der wenigen.
Wie nannten wir diese Geräte damals? PDAs?
Ja, aber es hatte hier so eine schöne Überklapptastatur, damit du nicht mit
dem Stift die Nummer eintippen musst, sondern auch immer noch das Tastengefühl hattest.
ja, das war mein, ich glaube, das war mein erstes Smartphone, Sony Ericsson T800.
Ja. Die Nausebote ist, das war aber nicht deins. Convenience,
nein, irgendwie nochmal so ein dünneres Vorgänger-Teil.
Convenience ist einfach geil. So, ich meine, du willst nicht dieses Passwort
eingeben, das mag zwar jetzt so einen romantischen,
Klang haben, so und in gewisser Hinsicht übt ja auch schon das Eingeben von
Passwörtern auf die wie heißen bei,
Harry Potter noch gleich Muggels, ja, also auf die Computer Muggels hat das
ja sozusagen, ist ja so das Bedienen eines Terminals oder eben auch nur das
Eintippen von Kennwörtern, das ist ja schon was Scharfes, ne.
Aber diese Blicke, die man heutzutage so bekommt, wenn man so im Terminal arbeitet
irgendwo. Das ist schon ganz interessant.
Aber würdest du nicht auch sagen, dass Convenience der natürliche Feind von Sicherheit ist?
Nur bei schlechter Software.
Ja, naja.
Und wir kommen im 21. Jahrhundert.
Eigentlich schon.
Wo Apple sogar den Passwort hin mit deinem Encryption-Passwort versieht.
Ich meine, es wäre viel sicherer, wenn du da erstmal ein Abundschloss öffnen
müsstest, bevor du deine Tastatur benutzen kannst.
Ja, mit einem dicken, fetten Schlüssel. Am besten mit zwei Schlüsseln.
Kombinationsschloss ist besser mittlerweile.
Also du willst eigentlich so ein Loch durch das Notebook haben,
wo du das vorher geschlossen hast. durchmachen kannst.
Wie die Floppides.
Ja, du willst da Selbstschussanlagen. Natürlich, also Sicherheit und Convenience
waren immer schon diametral voneinander entfernt.
Und da aber die richtige Konstellation hinzubekommen, das ist halt die Herausforderung.
Und natürlich öffnet Touch-ID wieder neue interessante Vektoren und Face-ID auch.
Macht aber dann wiederum die Anwendung von Sicherheit auf einmal so einfach,
dass eben viel mehr Leute viel öfter, viel regelmäßiger überhaupt Sicherheitsfeatures
in Angriff nehmen, weil der Default ist. Es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Schutz.
Die Kiste bootet gleich in deinen Account rein. Das Passwort ist leer.
Ich meine, das ist die Realität.
Ja, damals die alten Macs, nix anmelden. Buten loslegen.
Abstürzen, Neubooten. Abstürzen, Neubooten.
Alles. Jetzt haben wir ganz neue Herausforderungen, was Sicherheit betrifft,
aber warum soll es nicht auch convenient sein?
Warum nicht auch sowas optional?
Klar wünscht sich das jeder, aber in der Realität funktioniert es halt selten,
dass Dinge, die super convenient sind, auch funktionieren. Ja,
und das nötige Sicherheitsverständnis überhaupt wecken.
Das ist ja hier diese ganzen, das nennt man dann Snake Oil war das doch,
wo du kaufst irgendeine bunte Kiste, wo dann draufsteht, hier installier dir
das und drück den Knopf und dann ist plötzlich alles sicher.
Aber wenn die Leute halt überhaupt nicht verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert
und das überhaupt nicht einschätzen können, dann ist es eher das Gegenteil.
Und auch so Verschlüsselung oder alles mögliche, wo Leute so denken,
ah ja, jetzt mache ich mal E-Mail-Verschlüsselung, versetzen sich damit aber
nicht auseinander, weil es natürlich auch nicht convenient ist.
Und dann irgendeine One-Click-Solution wird dann ausgewählt,
die dann alles ganz viel schlimmer macht.
Also es ist halt so, ja, so ein Spannungsfeld und irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, ich bin da, ich will das nicht convenient haben,
ich will die ganze Zeit an den Prozess und so erinnert werden.
Du nutzt auch kein Touch-ID?
Nee. Was?
Ich benutze Touch-ID auf dem MacBook nicht.
Also jetzt, wo es den SOS-Mode gibt, auf dem Telefon, denke ich drüber nach.
Aber, also du kannst jetzt fünfmal irgendwie den Nee.
Fünfmal musst du nicht. Du musst einfach nur...
Tapen oder Button?
Nee, fünfmal.
Drücken festhalten, glaube ich.
Dann hast du geändert.
Nee, dann machst du aus.
Nee, dann machst du aus. Fünfmal kurz drücken.
Ja, okay. Fünfmal was?
Hier an der Seite, wie heißt der Knopf? Der...
Fünfmal.
Der Button, der Power-Button.
Ja.
Du glaubst nicht, dass wenn die Polizei dein Telefon haben will,
dass du dann auch schaffst, da fünfmal zu drücken?
Kannst du in der Tasche machen.
Die lassen sich nicht mehr in deiner Tasche.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, deswegen.
Naja, das ist Grenzsituation.
Naja, schon klar, aber.
Naja, also ich hab das ja so, dass ich nur den linken Daumen gelernt hab,
weil ich als Linkshänder halt eigentlich auch immer nur mit der linken Hand das Telefon hab.
wenn ich in die Situation komme, dann nehme ich es halt in die rechte Hand und
den rechten Daumen kennt er nicht und dann habe ich drei vier Versuche und dann war es das.
Und so meinst du, das wissen die dann nicht und probieren nicht beide.
Ihr wisst, wie sie den Typen von Silk Road bekommen haben? Habe ich letztens gehört, die Story?
Ich dachte, der hätte seinen Username auf...
Nee, der hat sich von irgendwie eingeloggt und so weiter in einer öffentlichen
Bibliothek, also im öffentlichen Netzwerk und saß da mal an so einem Tisch und
sie brauchten halt als Beweis seinen Rechner, von dem er sich aktiv gerade da
einloggt, aber halt eben,
sind sie davon ausgegangen und war wahrscheinlich auch so, war das Ding verschlüsselt.
Das heißt, sie brauchten das entschlüsselt.
Das heißt, ihn irgendwie so einkassieren mit verschlüsseltem Rechner,
hätte er nichts genutzt.
Deswegen haben sie gewartet, bis er in diese Bibliothek rein ist.
Dann haben sie irgendwie einen reingeschickt, der nicht auffällig aussieht,
ist so an ihm vorbeigeschlichen und hat sozusagen,
ihn umarmt oder wie auch immer so, dass sie ihm den Rechner wegnehmen konnten,
ohne dass er noch irgendwie zuklappen oder ein Kommando absetzen konnten oder wie auch immer.
Also so, wenn die an deine Daten ran wollen, dann kriegen die das hin.
Tja, aber wenn es dann mit deiner iOS, mit deiner Apple Watch Entfernung beim
Wegtragen quasi gelockt wird.
Selling Clicker klingen die Scheiße.
Nee, das tut's ja nicht.
Achso, es lockt nicht, wenn du weggehst mit der Apple Watch?
Nee, nee, es ist unlockt.
Aber Selling Clicker hat gelockt.
Ne?
Ja.
Eben. Und ich meine, das ist natürlich auch herstellbar. Ich meine,
gerade bei Face ID im Laptop könntest du halt sagen wenn.
Mein Gesicht weg ist.
Nur wenn du da drauf schaust und wenn es irgendwie zehn Sekunden irgendwie das
Gesicht weg ist dann Ende genau,
Das ist so Hardcore-Security, ne?
Ja.
Weil es ist ja auch die Frage, wie stellst du deinen Timeout ein?
Ab wann lockt das Ding? Lockst du dann immer von Hand? Nee, machst du nicht,
weil es ist inconvenient, so.
Und wenn du halt irgendwie, du bist weg und dann ist das Ding irgendwie pfff.
Mal gucken, ob sie das auch für Stromschmerzfeatures nutzen.
Wenn du nicht hinguckst, kann der ja runterdimmen, wenn da ganz,
wenn dein Kopf nicht mal mehr zu sehen ist, dann irgendwie ganz aus.
Und so, nervt natürlich ein bisschen, weil es dann dauernd an ausflackert, mach du, aber...
Ich gebe ja zu, ich habe mich mit diesem Face-ID, ich habe da in der Kino nicht
so wahnsinnig viel, weil da waren wir schon müde halt.
Als das kam.
Ja und außerdem, es war mir schon gleich klar, es ist jetzt nichts,
was mich jetzt persönlich anspricht direkt, aber wie sieht es da aus mit,
wenn jetzt jemand quasi mit genau so einer Technologie quasi einen Print von
deinem Face macht, dann so eine Silikonmaske.
Haben sie alles getestet.
Haben sie getestet, weil du ja Infrarot hast. Du müsstest die Silikonmaske von
innen beheizen, das könntest du natürlich tun.
Also ich glaube, das ist...
Oder mal kurz über den Toaster halten und dann aufsetzen.
Ich habe ja gehört.
Da sind Experten dabei, das sich anzugucken. Also die wir kennen.
Der Aufwand wird halt irgendwie immer größer.
Ich weiß nicht genau wie es funktioniert was diese Unterscheidung von Masken betrifft,
ich hab mir nur gedacht sie sind ja sehr schnell im Erkennen und sie können
dann im Zweifelsfall wenn sie ein Bild sehen, könnten sie ja im Prinzip auch
noch auf eine Regung warten weil das dein,
Gesicht sich nicht auch geringfügig ändert, während du reinschaust halte ich
wiederum für so unwahrscheinlich Während so eine Maske sich halt nicht bewegt.
Kriegt man aber auch noch hin.
Naja, wenn du die Maske entsprechend aufs Gesicht klebst, sodass sie sich halt,
mitbewegt mit deinen Gesichtsmuskeln.
Aber dann hast du immer noch das Problem, dass du sie beheizen musst.
Ja, aber wenn sie auf deinen Gesichtsmuskeln ist, dann drückst du ja dann dein
Gesicht in das andere rein, sodass das dann auch schon vielleicht nicht mehr
das Richtige ist. Also keine Ahnung. Wir werden es sehen.
Ja, da ist aber immer noch ein bisschen Machine Learning dabei und du musst
ja ja, du musst natürlich auch es muss ja auch funktionieren.
Selbst wenn du jetzt Kandidaten dabei hast, die nicht ganz so viel Regung zeigen.
Ja, also wenn du irgendwelche Weihnachtsmänner siehst, die irgendwie Gesichtsmasken
von dir aufhaben, dann vielleicht einfach...
Außerdem gehen wir jetzt ja auch noch davon aus, dass man den Test ja schon
macht, indem man dem Telefon die Maske beibringt, um dann mit der Maske wieder zu probieren.
Aber der Trick ist ja, ich müsste ja, oder Der Angreifer müsste ja eine Maske von mir haben.
Und ich glaube, das ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach, oder? Ich weiß nicht.
Kommt halt drauf an, wie schnell man genau mit so einer Kameratechnologie,
die jetzt ja wahrscheinlich nicht auch außerhalb von Apple existiert,
sozusagen auch so einen Scan quasi von dir anfert, den kann so im Vorbeilaufen oder U-Bahn oder so.
Kann man sehr gut, ja.
Wenn man so ein iPhone X macht, man kurz ein Bild mit allen Daten und dann submittet
man und dann kriegt man eine Woche später von Apple die Maske zugesendet.
Kann man machen, mal schnell ein Selfie.
Genau, Selfie. Selfies werden wieder unpopulär, weil jetzt jedes Mal 3D-Scans durchgeführt werden.
Ja, schon.
Wäre nicht das Schlimmste.
Ja, aber es ist schon nochmal wieder eine neue Ebene auf jeden Fall.
Ist das dann ein Drellfi?
Ich gebe weiter Passwort ein.
Ja, diese 3D-Scanerei, das hat auch nochmal Implikationen. Ich frage mich halt
auch, ob sie diese Funktionalität an die Apps durchreichen.
Wahrscheinlich erstmal.
War etwas in, also es gibt auf jeden Fall ein Kit um Face, doch,
doch, du kannst Faces Ach so.
Weil diese auch Emoji-Geschichten und so, es wird da bestimmt jetzt jede App unter.
Aber nur im Subset, oder?
Ich habe es mir ein bisschen angeguckt. Was du bekommst, ist im Prinzip eine
Beschreibung der gesamten Muskeln.
Also sowas wie Mundwinkel rechts nach oben, Mundwinkel rechts nach unten.
Also dafür kriegst du halt überall so Werte von 0 bis 1.
Das ist nicht die Form des Gesichts, sondern nur, ob du gerade...
Doch, die 3D-Form kannst du, glaube ich, auch abfragen, aber du kannst halt
auch den Verzerrungszustand des Gesichts abfragen.
Das ist dann ähnlich wie bei der Kinect mit den Muskeln, dass du die Punkte
siehst, auch dann quasi im Gesicht, wenn du entwickelst?
Nee, das sind nur so Parameter, wie Mundwickel hoch, runter, sowas in der Hand.
Du kannst sie quasi aber nicht mappen während der Entwicklung,
um das mal wirklich so zu testen, wie das dann ausschlägt.
Keine Ahnung, aber du kriegst auch das 3D-Netz. wenn du sowas machen willst
wie Face-Painting oder so, dann brauchst du ja das 3D-Netz, um dann hinterher
deine Textur auf das 3D-Netz drauf
zu machen, was du dann vor das Bild projizierst. Also das gibt's auch.
Klar, fällt aus der API raus.
Wir werden sehen.
Ja, in drei Wochen.
Aber ich merke schon, wir wollen heute auf jeden Fall mehr über Macs reden.
Haben wir schon.
Was haben wir denn noch auf der Uhr?
Mac-mäßig?
Fruchtfliegen. Jede Menge Fruchtfliegen, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Hier lag eine Bananenschale, ich bin unschuldig.
Fruchtfliegen würden Metaebene wählen.
Hier steht noch was zu macOS Content Caching.
Ja, das ist ein neues Feature. Habe ich aber bisher noch nicht zum Laufen bekommen.
Ich kriege nur Fehlermeldungen. Aber wenn du mal in High Sierra auf die Systemeinstellungen gehst.
Content Caching.
Ja, und dort ins Sharing.
Ja, Sharing.
Sharing. Because Sharing ist.
Hast du schon High Sierra auf der Mac Pro?
Ja.
Sharing ist Freigaben, ne?
Ja. Und die Pumper-Updates hast du auch bekommen, ja?
Ja.
Ja, auch.
Ah, Inhaltscaching.
Genau, Inhaltscaching. oder halt auch Content Caching.
Was ist denn das?
Damit steuert man einerseits, wie sehr die Büchse iCloud Content speichert, also wie sehr ist gut,
an, aus Caching oder Caching nicht und es gibt auch eine Funktion Share Internet Connection.
Jetzt kannst du nämlich nicht nur Internet von deinem Telefon zu deinem Rechner
holen, jetzt kannst du auch Internet von deinem Rechner zu deinem Telefon geben.
Dann ein Schock.
Das heißt, man muss es, wenn man irgendwo nur Ethernet kriegt, aber keinen WLAN hat.
Könntest du das mit deinem Rechner an deinem Telefon durchreichen?
Ja gut, das geht natürlich jetzt auch, weil du mit deinem Rechner dann WLAN
aufmachen kannst, aber wenn du in einem WLAN bist, aber du hast nur für den
Rechner den Zugang wegen Mac-Adressen, mehrere Devices, dann könntest du darüber
auch noch machen. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher, was der...
Aber schon selten, also wüsste ich jetzt nicht, weil ich das mal gebraucht hätte.
Aber das...
Das ist auch, glaube ich, mehr so ein Developer-Ding, wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe, wenn du das anschaltest, dann cached er auch irgendwie Software-Updates. Steht ja hier auch.
Aber das war doch das, was in Mac oder Server vorher drin war.
Reduces bandwidth usage and speeds up installation on supported devices by storing
Software-Updates, Apps and other content on this computer.
Mach mal Options hier. Was kommt denn bei Options?
Da kannst du noch einstellen, wie viel Speicher er dafür verpulvern soll.
Genau.
Das ist alle Mütze.
Und es gibt noch Bearbeiten.
Ich schalte es ein und dann kommt irgendwie Fehlermeldung. Also irgendwie so ganz,
Ja.
Aber das macht ja Sinn, dass sie jetzt diesen macOS-Server, den sowieso irgendwie
niemand ernst genommen hat, jetzt langsam ins eigentliche macOS umziehen.
Ja, natürlich. Geben tut es noch. Aber das Erste, was sie halt umgezogen haben,
ist, dass sie macOS also Xcode-Server von dem macOS-Server in Xcode umgezogen haben.
Also du brauchst jetzt keinen Xcode-Server, äh, kein macOS-Server mehr,
um die Server-Funktion von Xcode zu verwenden.
Was total sinnvoll ist, weil du dann mehrere Xcodes parallel benutzen kannst
und nicht immer nur einen.
Es gibt immer noch macOS-Server, zwei von fünf Sternen.
So viel.
Oh, das kostet ja immer noch Geld.
Ja, 22 Euro.
Na, ich habe immer den Entwicklercode geklickt und fertig.
Na gut, also das war...
Wollen wir denn eigentlich noch für die uninformierten Massen da draußen noch
diesen Encryption-Bug erwähnen? Oder ist das schon so?
Du kannst den ja mal kurz, ja.
Also nur für die, die es noch nicht mitbekommen hatten, es gab ein Security-Update
und auch vorher schon so ein paar Twitter-Posts, wo wirklich alle so,
man hatte landesweit das Facepalment hören können,
weil sie es fertiggebracht hatten, dass wenn man seine Festplatte verschlüsselt,
mit Disk Utility oder irgendeinem Volume mit Disk Utility verschlüsselt und
einen Passwort-Hint mit dazu gibt,
dass statt des Passwort-Hints das eigentliche Passwort in Klartext gespeichert
wurde, sodass, wenn man dann das Ding wieder mounten will, sagt,
ich habe mein Passwort vergessen, der Hint wird angezeigt, dann wird stattdessen
das Passwort angezeigt.
Und das war schon also glorreich verkackt.
Ja, sie haben das Passwort sowohl als Passwort als auch das Hint gespeichert.
Das war genau verdreht.
Nee, das war nicht, sie hatten beides gespeichert. Das Passwort in beide Keys reingespeichert.
Da hatte irgendjemand, hatte dann den Diff von den Sourcen, waren es die Sourcen?
Ich weiß es nicht genau. Irgendjemand hat den Diff gepostet,
wo klar zu sehen war, dass da eine Zahl war falsch.
Ist auf jeden Fall gepixt.
Go to fail, sage ich nur.
Also wenn ihr das letzte Security-Update da installiert hattet.
Das war jetzt auch schon eine Woche her.
Ja und gleichzeitig hatten sie auch noch einen Keychain-Bug gefixt in dem gleichen
Security-Update, den ich jetzt aber schon wieder vergessen habe.
Naja. Aber eine Mac-News habe ich auf jeden Fall noch eine gute.
Ja, es gibt auch gute Sachen zu berichten, auch über dieses MacBook,
im Speziellen das MacBook Pro, denn ich habe es gestern fertiggebracht,
mal wieder so ein Getränk über meinem Notebook zu entleeren.
Diesmal war es nur Leitungswasser, aber es war so ein ordentlich großes so hier
Kaipi-Glas von Ikea, also so schon 0,4, 0,5.
Der Pokal.
Der Pokal, ja. Ist hier auch so richtig quer rüber geschwappt und ich sah so
dabei zu, wie es dann so an den Seiten auch so raus, also ich hatte den Eindruck,
es würde hier aus diesen Schlitzen auch rauslaufen.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass das in diesem ganzen Wassergeplansche irgendwie nur so schien.
Dann habe ich das mal so umgedreht. Es lief auch die ganze Zeit weiter.
Dann lief das so aus der Tastatur raus.
Es war nur Wasser.
Und dann hat so der Kollege rübergeguckt, willst du das jetzt nicht ausmachen?
Und ich so, ich starte jetzt mal hier nochmal ein Geekbench und mach mal nochmal
Minecraft an oder so, damit die Kiste noch mal ein bisschen so auf Temperatur kommt.
Damit die Lüfter mal das austrocknet.
Nee, nur damit das hier so warm wird und das aus der Tastatur raussifft und,
Was soll ich sagen? Also Tastatur funktioniert einmal, also alles geht wunderbar.
Es hat so eine komplette Flutung wunderbar überstanden.
Tastatur funktioniert besser als vorher.
Und die Lautsprecher, ich glaube auch durch diese Feinsiebung ist da nicht viel
eingedrungen. Also die funktionieren auch nach wie vor.
Die Feinsiebung ist ja keine Siebung, ist ja nur Alibi-Pünktchen.
Das geht ja gar nicht durch.
Sondern wo kommt der Sound her? War er ganz anders oder was?
Na, ich glaube von diesen Dingern hier. Bin mir nicht so sicher.
Aber irgendwer meinte mal, die gehen gar nicht mehr durch.
Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden
Fall war ich dann über dieses Feature des MacBooks doch sehr erfreut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange haben sie denn diese Ablaufwanne da für die Tastatur?
Ist das erst seitdem oder gab es das schon vorher?
Mir ist das gar nicht bekannt.
Mir auch nicht.
Das war IBM früher.
Oder?
Ne, ne, die Thinkpads hatten das schon sehr, sehr lange. Und Apple hat das aber
auch mit irgendeiner Gerätegeneration, meinten sie so, sie hätten jetzt hier,
die Tastatur wäre auch so eine Wanne.
Ich bin neu.
Naja.
Ja. War gut.
Jetzt ist er wieder sauber. Ja, jetzt ist er wieder sauber.
Prima,
Krübelwanne.
Es ist wie beim Toaster, wenn man mal alle Jubeljahre unten diese Schublade rauszieht.
und sich dann so über die gesammelten Werke freut.
Da ist was dran.
Die Bilder im Kopf.
So, jetzt haben wir mal was ganz anderes. Wir, die Freunde des gepflegten Gear
Acquisition Syndromes, die fast täglich neue Geräte ausprobieren und,
uns in den Kartons, in denen sie kamen, wälzen.
Tim guckt sich auf seinem Sofa um, auf dem sich diverse Gerätschaften und Kartons türmen.
Da hat auch schon seit Jahren keiner mehr sitzen können.
Ganz oben ein großer Karton vom großen Tee.
Wann hat man da zum letzten Mal sitzen können auf dem Sofa?
Noch nie.
Doch, doch, doch.
Wir hatten irgendwann mal Gäste in der Sendung, da saßen zwei auf dem Sofa.
Ich gebe zu, dass das immer alles noch sehr unaufgeräumt aussieht,
aber tatsächlich aussieht.
Sieht nicht nur so aus.
Naja.
Da ist Ordnung dahinter.
System. Nein, das ist eine lange Geschichte. Auf jeden Fall ist es viel besser, als es aussieht.
Voller Missverständnisse.
Ich verstehe Tim da, weil mein Sofa sieht gerade sehr ähnlich aus.
Ich habe jetzt vor kurzem mal angefangen so ein bisschen von meinem Audio-Kram,
den ich ja auch sehr leidenschaftlich in den letzten Jahren gesammelt habe.
Kurze Einmerkung. Es sind im Wesentlichen leere Kartons, ob die ihr gerade schaut.
Doch, doch.
Ich habe jetzt auf jeden Fall mal angefangen, so ein bisschen auszusortieren.
Was benutze ich denn eigentlich wirklich nicht mehr?
Und ich hatte immer so ein bisschen Hemmungen, das jetzt so zu verkaufen,
weil ich einfach mit Ebay und so dieser Ebay-Scheiß, ich habe einfach auch keinen Bock auf Ebay.
Dieses Interface ist einfach seit eh und je scheiße.
Und auch so ihr Gebührenmodell und Angebote nur für sieben Tage und dann ist
es wieder weg und dann muss man es nochmal einstellen und blablabla, den ganzen Krempel.
Und in den USA gibt es schon eine Weile eine Webseite Reverb.com und ich habe
jetzt schon immer mal auf irgendeinem Banner gesehen, ah, Reverb gibt es jetzt auch in Deutschland.
Und das ist im Prinzip ähnlich wie Ebay, nicht ganz so. Es ist nicht auktionsbasiert,
sondern eher so Kleinanzeigen mäßig.
Aber es ist halt nur für Audio- und Musikinstrumente. Also da ist nichts anderes
quasi. Und das Interface, wenn du jetzt was verkaufen willst,
ist einfach super straight forward und.
Ja, sinnvoll. Also im Gegensatz zu Ebay auf jeden Fall deutlich benutzbarer,
sehr viel moderner, responsiver.
Und ich war erstaunt, weil viele haben da wahrscheinlich noch nicht von gehört,
aber es gibt wirklich extrem viel Equipment da.
Ja, der einzige, das einzige Manko und das wollte ich jetzt dem Support,
der auch übrigens per Chat sehr responsiv ist, sind halt Amis,
man muss das zu Ami-Zeiten dann anschreiben, aber das einzige Problem,
was ich mit der Seite noch habe, wenn du nur browsst nach Equipment, dass sie,
scroll mal nochmal kurz hoch, Tim, wie heißt das da, links in der Sidebar, genau,
Ships to Germany und die Seller-Location ist immer auf Anywhere und ich würde
die gerne auf European Union permanent global festsetzen, das muss ich halt
jedes Mal klicken, wenn ich dann so ein bisschen browse,
weil ich will halt keinen Zoll in der Regel bezahlen für Sachen aus USA oder
so, wo die meisten Sachen,
auf Reverb.com herkommen.
Aber auch in European Union, wenn man das da drauf beschränkt,
gibt es wirklich erstaunlich viel Kram und ich habe dann einfach mal das erste
Gitarreneffektpedal da so mal reingestellt und gedacht, okay,
mal gucken, was passiert und sie da am nächsten Tag auch gleich verkauft.
Das funktioniert im Prinzip so, man stellt es rein und sagt,
das ist der Preis, den ich haben will und du kannst ein Häkchen setzen, I accept Offers.
Also dann können ja halt Leute noch sagen, na wie sieht's denn aus?
Also finde ich jetzt ein bisschen teuer, kommst du auch, also können wir uns da irgendwie einigen.
Fünf Schäke? Bist du wahnsinnig?
Was ist das letzte Preis?
Genau, aber man kann das eben auch abstellen. Also ich hatte zum Beispiel einen
aus Dänemark, nee aus Holland, der hatte einen Effektpedal verkauft,
was sechs Jahre alt ist und es gibt eine neue Version und er hat das alte Pedal
für den Neupreis der neuen Version verkaufen wollen.
Da meinte ich so, Alter, kommst du mal klar?
Und der hat dann auch so ganz freundlich reagiert und meinte,
ja, ja, okay, pass auf, ich mache dir einen anderen Preis.
Aber du kannst eben auch dieses Häkchen abklicken und dann ist einfach der Preis der Preis.
Und das Angebot bleibt auch unbegrenzt lange da drin,
und sie nehmen halt sozusagen eine Vermittlungsprozentzahl, für,
wenn du es verkaufst, was auch human war.
Das waren jetzt keine Unsummen, die da fallen.
Woher wissen die denn, dass du das verkauft hast?
Du kannst, ja, also teilweise, wenn die Leute das direkt über die Webseite kaufen,
dann ist es halt gleich klar.
Aber ich habe zum Beispiel das erste Effektpedal hat einer vor Ort dann abgeholt
und hat gar nicht auf den Kaufbutton geklickt.
Das heißt, ich habe dann selber gesagt, die ist jetzt geendet und dann fragen sie dich,
hast du es irgendwo anders verkauft oder wie das hat gelaufen und ich war jetzt
mal ehrlich und hab gesagt, nee, hab's über Abholung verkauft und dann hab ich dann meine,
weiß nicht, zwei Euro oder so dagelassen. Ähm,
Ja, und das wollte ich mal den Audio- und Musiker-Nerds durchaus nahe legen, da reinzuschauen.
Ich habe jetzt fast alles schon verkauft, was ich da reingestellt habe.
Also ich bin wirklich sehr überrascht, wie viel Betrieb da so herrscht.
Das war auch alles super easy.
Hat es nach Deutschland verkauft?
In meinem Fall ja, ich habe aber jetzt auch schon zwei Sachen aus Holland mal gekauft,
was auch problemlos ging und also nur European Union auf jeden Fall,
aber ich habe meine Sachen glaube ich alle in Deutschland verkauft, ja. Ja, genau.
Ne, stimmt nicht. Ha, wieder falsch. Ein Effektpedal habe ich auch nach Holland
verkauft. Also Holland scheint da auch sehr aktiv zu sein.
Ja, und das ist eigentlich schon so als Tipp für die Leute, die eben in dieser
Kategorie von Gear Acquisition Syndrome unterwegs sind, vielleicht auch mal was loswerden.
Dass ich sie da loswerden möchte.
Oder auch, also ich habe tatsächlich jetzt eben auch, weil da ganz viele diese
Make-and-Offer-Optionen anhaben, ich habe jetzt für zwei Sachen nicht gekauft,
aber ich habe auch bei beiden Malen gesagt, also ich würde es dir ja für 30
Euro oder 50 Euro weniger abnehmen und dann, ja okay, hier bitteschön.
Und wenn du jetzt verkaufst, also sind das alles Privatleute?
Nee, es sind auch Shops. Also du machst auch im Prinzip, wenn du da auf Sell
klickst, Dann wird automatisch so dein Shop angelegt, wo ich erst so ein bisschen
verwirrt war. Heißt das jetzt, dass ich hier so ein Gewerbe haben muss oder so?
Nee, das ist einfach nur so deren Nomenklatur.
Aber es gibt da auch richtige Läden, die sozusagen das Interface benutzen,
um ihren Second-Hand-Bestand oder was auch immer zu verkaufen.
Das sieht man relativ oft auch. Ja, ist so ein bisschen gemischt.
Aber ich meine, eBay Kleinanzeigen habe ich auch schon öfters mal benutzt,
aber auch das Interface ist, ihr wisst Bescheid.
So mega schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht mit Ebay.
Bisher bin ich immer alles ganz ordentlich losgeworden und hab eigentlich auch
für meinen Geschmack ganz brauchbare Preise erzielt.
Andererseits ist es natürlich schon so, ich hab jetzt, wo du das nämlich sagst,
ich hab mir auch gerade so zwei, drei Sachen, die hier nochmal aus dem Studio
demnächst mal rausfallen müssten, weil ich sie dann doch nicht zum Einsatz bringen werde,
oder nicht mehr im Einsatz habe, ich gerne loswerden wollen würde.
Was mich dann immer Frage ist so, wie ist das so, erzeugt dieses Ding dann auch
so Verkaufsbelege und sowas?
Ja, du kriegst auch so ein, wenn du was verkaufst, kriegst du so ein,
mal sehen, ob ich das hier finde von denen, die ich verkauft habe,
so ein Shipping-Sheet, wo sozusagen Adresse von beiden Parteien,
was wurde verkauft, was ist der Preis und so weiter und so fort.
Ob dir das jetzt so mit den, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was da alles drauf steht,
ob dir das jetzt schon reicht, können wir ja da nochmal gucken.
Also meine Frage ist, wenn du was kaufst, kriegst du dann auf jeden Fall was
ordentliches von Reverb direkt aus der Webseite, mit dem du sofort so einen Kaufbeleg hast.
Weil das ist irgendwie die große Schwäche bei Ebay. Ich guck mal gerade.
Kannst du dir dann irgendwie deine Bestellseiten ausdrucken oder kannst halt
glücklich sein, dass du noch eine richtige Richtung ausgestellt bekommst von irgendjemand.
Aber einfach mal nur so eine Kauf Bestätigung, wo der Verkäufer mit drauf ist,
Das fände ich auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz fancy, ne? Man muss das ja auch
nachweisen, gerade wenn Sachen noch nicht abgeschrieben sind und so.
Ja, gucke ich gleich dann nochmal in Ruhe, wenn dann vielleicht schon das nächste Thema ist,
damit ich jetzt hier nicht im Dings versinke, was auf jeden Fall,
was wollte ich noch sagen, achso genau, es gibt auch so ein bisschen andere Refund Policy,
bei Ebay ist ja immer so, hier kauf wie es ist und gibt nichts,
das kannst du hier auch als Option sagen, aber es wird auch sozusagen ein bisschen
dafür geworben, dass wenn du Sachen verkaufst und die Leute sind nicht happy damit,
dass man schon in Erwägung ziehen sollte, das einfach wieder zurückzunehmen
und nochmal jemanden anderem reinzustellen.
Das fand ich irgendwie auch tatsächlich relativ sympathisch,
weil viele Angebote das so machen.
Und halt, was bei Ebay mich zum Beispiel richtig nervt, sind so Nachrichten.
Ihr kennt das ja vielleicht, wenn man mal mit irgendjemandem in Verbindung treten
will und nochmal eine Frage hat, dann kommst du erst an diese,
ja, jetzt guck mal erstmal in unserem Katalog von Fragen und dann,
nee, ich will den Bayer kontakten, dann musst du noch ein Capture eingeben,
dann schickst du die Nachricht und wenn du die Nachricht finden willst,
die du geschickt hast, Dann bist du,
wo sind jetzt die Nachrichten und dann gibt es in den Nachrichten gesendete
Nachrichten, beantwortete Nachrichten, alle Nachrichten und irgendwie schon
allein dieses Nachrichteninterface ist einfach total braindead,
ist hier sehr viel intuitiver und auch so dieser Überblick von deinem Dashboard,
was du gerade so verkaufst, beobachtest oder wie viele Leute sich deine Angebote angeguckt haben etc.
pp. Das ist wirklich einfach sehr viel nutzerfreundlicher in jeder Hinsicht
und die App taugt auch dazu.
Also ich bin da bisher sehr zufrieden und sehne mich nicht nach Ebay zurück.
Ich finde Kleinanzwängen ganz brauchbar eigentlich.
Das Problem ist halt bei Audio-Equipment sage ich mal noch dazu,
warum ich da jetzt auch so dadurch, dass es so spezialisiert ist,
zum Beispiel habe ich mir letztens einen Verstärker gekauft und die Firma heißt Blackheart.
Die gibt es jetzt auch nicht mehr, aber dann guckst du auf Ebay nach Blackheart
und du findest alles, nur nicht diese Amps, so Haarspangen mit irgendeinem Blackheart
und CDs, die irgendwo Blackheart im Album haben.
Und wenn du halt auf Audio- und Musikinstrumente aus bist, dann hast du halt
da ein Interface, wo du nur das findest und das ist eigentlich, glaube ich, der größte,
Anziehungspunkt für mich gewesen, dass ich dann nicht meine Zeit damit verschwende,
durch irgendwelche was auch immer, Kindersocken und sonst was durchzustöbern.
Ja, bei so speziellen Sachen, das stimmt, ich habe auch jetzt schon einen Teil,
habe ich sogar verkauft bekommen bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen, aber so Schnittmuster,
die ich nicht gebrauche, aber da hast du halt genau so ein ähnliches Prinzip oder Problem.
Du willst eigentlich deine Filter sehr, sehr genau setzen können,
wenn du auch als Suchender irgendwie unterwegs bist.
Also ich meine, da hast du bei Ebay, egal auf welchem, kannst du noch irgendwie
Hobby und Garten angeben.
Und dann bist du aber auch schon, weiter geht's dann halt nicht.
Ja, also jetzt kurze Werbesendung ist auch schon wieder vorbei,
aber vielleicht interessiert euch ja was.
Kann man mal ausprobieren. Kann man mal drauf gucken.
Vielleicht packe ich da mal tatsächlich mal meinen Krempel drauf.
Ich meine, es scheint ja auch so eine gewisse Mindestfrequenz an Leuten schon zu erreichen.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich war wirklich relativ überrascht, weil das erste,
was ich verkauft habe, war schon ein sehr nischiges Effektpedalgerät und es
ging relativ flott weg. Und ich glaube, das Ding ist halt auch… Aber.
Auktionen gibt es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht. Ist schon geil bei Ebay.
Ich finde es nicht so geil, weil ich ende immer unter dem Preis,
den ich eigentlich habe. Also außer ich mache sofort kaufen.
Also eigentlich bin ich immer, klicke ich eh immer sofort kaufen.
Dann hast du es nicht schön genug beschrieben.
Ja, aber du hast jemals eine Auktion gehabt, wo du wirklich deutlich mehr,
also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hast du auch das richtige Equipment verkauft
oder Temperatlaufstand daneben.
Aber Nee, ich hab da meinen Augen gar nicht dazu.
Wichtig ist der richtige Endzeitpunkt auch.
Ja, aber weißt du, mit diesem ganzen Scheiß will ich mich nicht beschäftigen.
Ich will die Kohle, die ich gerade im Kopf habe.
Am besten die Auktion endet am Sonntagabend um 9 Uhr.
Zum Beispiel.
Weil da haben die meisten Leute Muße nochmal hektisch mitzubieten.
Wenn das wenn das weiß ich nicht, Montagvormittag um 10.30 Uhr endet,
da hängt keiner auf Ebay ab und bietet.
Aber genau diesen ganzen Hazel will ich einfach gar nicht haben.
Ich weiß, was ich für die Geräte haben will. Ich schreibe den Preis rein.
Wenn es jemand haben will, peng, bitteschön.
Ich weiß zum Beispiel gar nicht, was ich für die Geräte haben will.
Also so einen Mindestpreis müsste ich unter Umständen...
Das ist bei Reverb. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das bei Ebay jetzt gerade so ist.
Aber wenn du dein Zeug da reinstellst, dann haben die auch schon Autovervollständigung
und in der Regel finden die auch genau das Gerät, was du da gerade verkaufst.
Also haben das schon im System, weil das andere Leute schon mal vorher verkauft
haben und sagen dir dann gleich, was ist so die Preishistorie von den letzten
was weiß ich, 10 Verkäufen von genau diesem Gerät in deiner Region und dann weißt du schon so,
ah okay so in dem Rahmen spielt sich das ab, dann kannst du auch noch mal im
Zweifel bei Ebay gucken, für was die Dinger gerade so im Sofortkauf weggehen und,
so nehme ich dann meine Preisspannung, aber ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel meine
Gitarre meine eine verkauft,
und die ist so eine Nischengitarre weil Gitarrenbau gibt es auch wie Sand am
Meer da habe ich mir halt selber so einen gefühlten emotionalen Wert der Trennung
ausgedacht und hat auch funktioniert.
Gefühlter emotionaler Wert der Trennung was ist mir diese Trennung wert ne ja.
Wann bin ich bereit mich zu trennen.
Da war ich ganz aufschauen ich hatte dich ja mal gefragt, eben wo man Gitarren
gut verkaufen kann, weil ich auch eine Akustik Gitarre hatte,
die war ganz nett aber ich hab die halt nicht gespielt und ich mein,
ich muss halt 200 Euro da irgendwie nicht rumliegen ich dachte mir so,
okay, versuchen wir sie halt mal reinzustellen.
Ich habe halt gesehen, dass eine ähnliche mal für 300 sogar weggegangen ist.
Da dachte ich mir, okay, ich stelle es für 220 oder so rein.
Das hat ewig bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen gedauert. Ich habe dann mittlerweile schon
vergessen, was ich überhaupt da angegeben habe.
Ich habe es ja dann eigentlich in der Tat zum Preis, den ich halt auch gezahlt
habe, wieder verkauft, wo ich ganz glücklich war.
Also noch mehr? Nee, wirklich null gemacht habe. Oder? Hast du vielleicht 10 Euro mehr?
Also nicht viel, wenn ich da was an Gewinn hatte.
Also hast du die denn schon gebraucht gekauft?
Ja, die war gebraucht in den 70ern halt. schon dann gebraucht.
Also die war definitiv gebraucht.
Aber da war ich ganz erfreut, dass ich da jetzt nicht irgendwie noch so einen
großen Verlust dabei gemacht habe.
Ja. Am Ende des Tages ist mir auch eigentlich scheißegal, wo die Leute sich
jetzt lieber aufhalten, ob Ebay oder Rebub.com.
Ich wollte das halt nur auch eigentlich immer als Alternative anpreisen,
weil ich bisher jetzt in den letzten drei Wochen sehr gute Erfahrungen damit gemacht habe.
Geil, mal gucken, ob das die weiß, was ich verkaufen will oder kaufen könnte, überhaupt dabei ist.
Eins. Brand new.
Doch, durchaus sehr spannend, aber ich habe da vielleicht auch ein bisschen anderen Blick drauf.
Ja, du musst jetzt leise sein.
Ich bin leise.
Aber unbestritten ist ja wohl, dass die User Interfaces und User Experience
sowohl von eBay als auch eBay-Kleinheiten zeigen, sehr verbesserungswürdig sind.
Ich sagte, ich bin leise.
Gut, dann belassen wir es dabei.
Es ist nicht so schlimm wie Facebook.
Bei Facebook finde ich meine Nachrichten zumindest.
Also gerade dieses Nachrichten-Interface, das ist wirklich...
Hast du aber noch nicht bei Amazon nach deinen Nachrichten.
Achso, gibt es da Nachrichten bei Amazon?
There you go.
Ja, naja, wie auch immer.
Ja, weil ich ja durch meine ganze Buchhaltungswahngeschichte wollte ich ja wirklich
für jeden Scheiß irgendwie meine Quittungen und Rechnungen zusammensammeln.
Bin da halt irgendwie gerade mittlerweile auch schon echt total anal unterwegs.
Und du musst ja dann immer unterscheiden. Also wenn du halt von Amazon selbst
was kaufst, dann ist es so wie kein Thema.
Dann wird das Ding geschippt und dann hast du sofort in deinen Bestellungen
einen Link, Rechnungen, zack, bumm, PDF, alles in Ordnung, alles super.
Kaufst du aber bei jemand anderem, der quasi Amazon nur als Plattform benutzt,
ist also Amazon selber nicht der Verkäufer, dann ist es mittlerweile Weil tatsächlich,
also es hat sich auch in letzter Zeit gebessert, habe ich so den Eindruck,
dass du in der Regel immer dann auch schon eine Mail bekommst mit gleich dem
PDF mit der Rechnung dran.
Das ist jetzt so langsam Standard, aber das weiß ich, das war vor einem Jahr
oder zwei noch nicht so das Ding.
Und dann kannst du ja deine Rechnung anfordern und dann landet das halt irgendwie
in deiner Inbox und dann findest du die da irgendwie nicht, weil du noch gar
nicht wusstest, dass es sowas wie eine Inbox da überhaupt gibt bei Amazon und so eine Geschichte.
Hm.
Tja.
Ja, ja.
Amazon ist überhaupt unheimlich gut da drin, einem bürokratisch alles möglichst schwer zu machen.
Ich finde ja auch, und das ist ja auch so eine Nischenmeinung,
ich finde ja auch das User-Interface von Amazon grottenschlecht.
Und das Ding ist, bei Vuga damals, da wurde ja sehr viel AB getestet,
also auch so User-Interface-mäßig.
Okay, wir geben jetzt mal 5% unserer User einen roten Button oder so.
Und Amazon ist ja auch quasi damit Vorreiter gewesen, ihr gesamten Flow quasi zu AB testen, konstant.
Und was dabei herausgekommen ist, ist vielleicht eine der besten Click-Through-Raten
von User suchen was und kaufen es dann auch.
Aber das, was visuell, also ästhetisch dabei herausgekommen ist,
ist halt irgendwie für mich eine totale Katastrophe.
Ich bin kein Amazon Prime-Kunde und für mich sieht das in etwa so aus.
Ich tue was in den Einkaufswagen.
Klicke auf den Einkaufswagen, sage, ja, nehme ich. Dann kommt irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht, ob gleich als erstes dieses Amazon Prime Pop-Up kommt.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die denken, dass ich ein Student wäre,
aber ich kriege eine Werbung präsentiert, Fullscreen quasi.
Ja, jetzt als Amazon Student kriegst du Amazon Prime.
Jedes Mal, der Button ist riesengroß und der Text, das du nicht willst, ist so ganz klein.
Genau, so ein kleiner Link unten drunter.
Nein, danke.
Ich gehe ohne Amazon Prime weiter. Dann kommt so dieses Interface,
wo irgendwie drei Kaufen-Buttons sind und dann gibt es die Adresse und Geschenkoptionen
in verschiedenen Bereichen des Bildschirms irgendwie verteilt,
wo man immer so guckt, okay,
da ist die Versandadresse und da ist jetzt mein...
Also irgendwie kann mir keiner erzählen, dass das jetzt wirklich die geilste
User Experience ist, da was einzukaufen.
Vielleicht ist es bei Amazon Prime, wenn man dann nur auf diesen One-Click-Button
oder wie auch immer das dann funktioniert, geht, ist das dann was anderes, aber...
Du musst dir diesen Button zum Hinkleben.
Ja, stimmt, genau, diesen Küchenmagneten, ne?
Prime ist ja eigentlich...
Ändert nichts am User in der Face, sondern macht nur das so für Versandkosten Spaß oder so.
Genau.
Ja, und die Krage fällt weg.
Ja, und dieses Pop-Up fällt weg, ja, okay.
Ja, war mir nicht so klar, dass mittlerweile die Leute schon mit Waffen verfolgt
werden, wenn sie keinen Prime haben.
Ne, das ist schon immer, seit es Prime gibt, das Pop-Up und ich bin auch seit,
ich weiß auch nicht, warum die denken, dass ich Student wäre,
keine Ahnung und ich finde das auch eine Frechheit, dann diesen kleinen Link,
ich meine, die verdienen ja an mir mehr, wenn ich nicht Prime hab, ne, nicht an mir.
Ja, ne, ne, die wissen schon, warum die das machen. Du zahlst ja so eine Abo-Falle
eigentlich. Ist ja ein Abo-Scheiß und die Preise haben sich ja auch erhöht,
ist ja nicht mehr so billig wie am Anfang.
Scheiße teuer geworden, weil der ganze Fernsehkack mit dabei ist.
Was kostet Amazon Prime jetzt?
50 Euro im Jahr oder so.
Und was war es früher? Zehn? Zwanzig?
Ja, dreißig.
Naja.
Also es ist auch schon grenzwertig. Ich habe mir auch schon ein paar Mal überlegt,
machst du das jetzt oder nicht?
Ja, jetzt im Fernsehen, Klimbim, das hat mich relativ wenig.
Ich habe mal ein bisschen rumgeguckt, was da so im Angebot ist.
Das ist halt, ich weiß nicht, also mir ist schon die Zeit so schade,
da in diesen komischen Icon-Interfaces hin und her zu schaufeln,
um mir irgendwie die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Comedy-Romanzen Kacke und,
deutsche Fernsehfilme irgendwie anzuschauen, das,
geht mir auch mit Netflix und so weiter auch nicht anders, aber bei Amazon war
das jetzt irgendwie auch keine gesteigerte Qualität.
Ich hätte einfach ganz gerne irgendwie da Shipping-Fee, Flatrate,
irgendwie lasst mich irgendwas zahlen, aber lasst mich bitte mit euren Medienimpana in Frieden.
Aber gut, da werde ich dann irgendwann mal den Absprung machen müssen oder nicht.
Ihr schreibt gerade einen User im Chat oder einen Hörer im Chat ein User-Interface
wie die Treppen von Hogwarts.
Schön, ja.
Soviel zum Online-Shopping.
Nee?
Doch, nee, ich würde nur ganz gerne mich bedanken bei einem unbekannten Hörer,
der mir etwas von meiner Wunschliste geschickt hat.
Opa! Oilala, was gab es denn Schönes?
Ein Card-Reader, also so ein USB-C, USB Alt- und Micro-USB-Teil,
wo man eine Mikro-SD-Karte und die größeren reinschmeißen kann.
Perfekt, wenn man halt mehr Rechner hat.
Mit unterschiedlichsten USB-C. Mit USB-C-Krankheiten und normalem USB. Genau.
Wird langsam, ja.
Danke sagen.
Ach, naja. Also ich habe bei meinem USB-C-Rechner immer noch das Problem,
dass er kann zwar zwei Monitore ansprechen, aber wenn er im Sleep-Mode war,
wacht er nur noch mit einem wieder auf.
Muss ich den zweiten abstecken, wieder anstecken. Ich habe schon alle Kombinationen durchprobiert.
Ich habe nach wie vor das Problem, dass wenn ich an meinem USB-Adapter irgendwie.
Maus und externe Tastatur dran habe und sie an dem USB-Adapter dran lasse,
aber das aus dem USB-C rausziehe und wieder reinstecke, dass sie erstmal nicht mehr angehen.
Und das habe ich schon Ewigkeiten mit dem Ding. Es nervt auch wie Hölle.
Es nervt. Da kann jetzt der Deesser.
Es nervt total.
Das nervt nochmal so richtig angreifen.
War schon, zum Thema OSBC. Mehr Klagen gibt's nicht.
Nein, wir wollen hier hören ja auch nicht langweilig. Was?
Oh, jetzt gibt's einen Editing-Konflikt. Ich hab's nämlich auch gerade hochgezogen.
Ach, dann können wir zwischendrin ein Spiel besprechen. Und zwar für die Freunde
der lustigen Point-and-Click-Adventures.
Ich dachte...
Die Firma, die Book of Unwritten Tales gemacht hat, hat jetzt auf Kickstarter
ein neues Projekt geworfen.
Shakes and Fidget The Adventure.
Ich habe da einfach mal unbesehen gebackt. Ich habe mich nicht mal das Video richtig angeguckt.
Weil die haben bisher nur geile Adventures gemacht und dann habe ich da jetzt einfach mal Vertrauen.
Hast du das alte Shakes and Fidget gespielt?
Nee.
Ah, okay. Ich habe das alte in der Tat mal, oh Gott, als ich studiert habe, gespielt.
Okay, da weiß ich ja, wie ich mich ja darauf vorbereite.
Das war irgendwie, ich kann mich da nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern,
es war irgendwie ein bisschen langweilig dann irgendwann.
Kannst du mal für so einen Spielagnostiker kurz näher bringen, was das so ist?
Was, ein Point-and-Click-Adventure?
Das und das halt dann auch noch im Speziellen. Ich sehe hier pfurzende Hunde. Pfurzende Hunde.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hab das nur so vorbeifliegen sehen und hab da mal Early Bird geklickt.
Also ein Point-and-Click-Adventure. Ich meine, wer hat,
noch nicht Monkey Island gespielt?
Ich.
Ich auch.
Ah!
Sorry, ich hab euch doch von meiner Spiele...
Hattest du kein Leben oder was?
Nein, als das rauskam, da waren Spiele für mich schon Vergangenheit,
das hab ich in meiner Jugend...
Zugegebenermaßen, ich hab's auch ein bisschen später gespielt.
Ich bin noch alt.
Aber Monkey Island, das ist Pflichtprogramm.
Oder wie heißt es? Manic Mansion.
Manic Mansion, das hab ich zum Beispiel nicht gespielt. Aber ich meine Thimbleweed Park.
Leather Sweet Larry. Sweet Larry.
Thimbleweed Park.
In The Lands of the Launch Lizard.
Ja, siehst du, dann hast du ein Point-and-Click-Adventure-Fan.
Das hatte ich auch, sieben Diskettenwarns oder so, aber gespielt habe ich es
nicht, weil es irgendwie zu blöd ist.
Da wild alles anzuklicken, was irgendwie so aussieht, als wenn man es klicken hat, ist doch total Ja.
Das war ja so das erste leicht latent schnüpprige Game, deswegen war das irgendwie interessant.
Naja, anyway, das Prinzip ist ähnlich wie auch bei anderen Adventure-Games,
nur dass die anderen Adventure-Games teilweise auch sehr viel unterhaltsamer sind.
Also Monkey Island 1 im Speziellen hat halt auch sehr viel Nerdkultur geprägt.
Also Der dreiköpfige Affe zum Beispiel.
Der dreiköpfige Affe ist das prominenteste Beispiel, ja, aber also genau,
und davon gibt es ja jetzt ab und zu immer mal wieder welche und wir hatten
ja auch vor einiger Zeit dieses Thimbleweed Park von dem.
Macher von Monkey Island.
Und das fand ich ja auch sehr großartig und das ist halt jetzt ein weiteres solches Spiel.
Und ich hatte Book of Unwritten Tales ja auch schon,
vorgestellt, wo es im zweiten Teil dann auch um die schwangere Elfe ging und
dem Gnom, der Zauberlehrling ist, aber nicht zaubern konnte und das erst herausgefunden hat,
dass es so gar nicht geht, als
jemand den Zauberstab geklaut hat und plötzlich und so weiter. Also das,
Und zumindest, wenn das auch nur in Ansätzen so absurd ist wie Book of Unwritten
Tales, dann ist es wahrscheinlich allein von der Absurdität der Geschichte wert,
gespielt zu werden. What the fuck?
Ich sehe gerade, Tim macht gerade die Wikipedia-Links klar und bei Leisure Suit
Larry, das wurde für die Playstation 2 und 3 released.
WTF und Xbox.
TRS80.
Guck mal, wie viele Plattformen dieses Software überlebt hat.
3 Xbox 360.
Ja.
Krass.
Also das ist dann ein Point-and-Click-Adventure.
Wo habe ich denn das gespielt? Ist das auf dem Mac gespielt?
Also ich weiß, dass ein Freund von mir das auf dem Atari hatte,
glaube ich. Oder Amiga. Shit, jetzt weiß ich es wieder nicht.
Also auf jeden Fall, das ist jetzt bei Kickstarter, man kann das backen.
und wenn die meinten so ungefähr, wenn sie damit durchkommen und das Gebäck
kriegen, dann wird es vielleicht auch ein Book of Unwritten Tales Teil 3 geben.
Wo ich natürlich auch sehr schon mit den Hufen scharre. Weil wie gesagt,
Teil 2 war wirklich richtig großartig.
Was genau?
Also Was genau?
Ich weiß, dass ihr euch solche Fragen nicht so richtig vorstellen könnt,
Aber was ist das Spannende daran?
Das Spannende daran ist, dass du absurde Rätsel vorgesetzt bekommst, die du lösen musst.
Habe ich jetzt mal ein gutes Beispiel? Hast du mal ein gutes Beispiel?
Ich weiß noch, bei Monkey Island 1, da musst du an irgendeinen Punkt kommen
und wirst zu einem Laden, dem Schwertladen oder was auch immer geleitet.
und da ist so ein grumpy old man und da hängt auch so ein Schwert an der Wand
und immer wenn du versuchst, das Schwert zu nehmen, sagt er dir,
Finger weg, irgendwie das nicht zu verkaufen.
Und dann kannst du mit ihm quatschen und ihn fragen, ob er mal den Schwertmeister
fragen könnte, ob er ihn trainieren würde und so.
Ja, okay, ich gehe mal kurz aus der Tür raus und gehe mal zum Schwertmeister
ihn fragen. Und dann denkst du dir, alles klar, ist aus der Tür raus,
kann ich mir jetzt wohl das Schwert nehmen.
Gehst zum Schwert und in dem Moment kommt er wieder rein, Alter,
ich habe dir gesagt, das Schwert ist nicht zu verkaufen, raus aus dem Laden.
Und dann irgendwie, ich habe Stunden, also gefühlte Stunden,
so, wie, wie, das muss hier sein und dann kommst du irgendwann auf den Trichter
okay, wenn er es mir nicht verkauft, dann gehe ich jetzt mal raus und in dem
Moment, wo du aus dem Haus dann rausgehst, kurz nachdem er raus ist,
siehst du, wie er so am Ende der,
Szenerie so um eine Ecke huscht und dann so,
ah, er geht jetzt ja gerade zum Schwertmeister und laufe ich ihm einfach hinterher.
Und dann geht es sozusagen darum, dass du eigentlich ihm folgst,
aber erstmal darauf zu kommen aus dieser Situation.
Also es wird dir erstmal so eine total viele falsche Fährten gelegt und dann
ist es so, ah natürlich, einfach hinterherlaufen.
Es gibt halt lauter so kleine Gimmicks und die sind halt von der Story auch
schön erzählt oder witzig gemacht.
Und ja, ich weiß nicht, mir macht das voll Laune, da sich so in diese Welt reinzufisseln.
Oder musste man nicht irgendwie, man musste irgendjemand aus dem Gefängnis befreien
und man hatte irgendwie in der Bar gab es aber diesen Grog, den man schnell
trinken musste, weil er sich schnell durch die Krüge durchgefressen hat.
Und dann war, dann musstest du irgendwie drei Krüge zusammen suchen,
musstest einen Krug mit Grog auffüllen, musstest dann irgendwie ein Dings weit
gehen, dann den in den nächsten Krug umfüllen, bevor der sich durchätzt.
dann gehst du weiter, füllst es wieder um und dann kannst du den ätzenden Grog
auf das Schloss kippen und dann ätzt es das Schloss weg und so weiter.
Also solche absurden Rätsel musst du da halt lösen.
Und genau das mit Monkey Island, gerade im ersten Teil war ja auch so der Schwertmeister,
das war halt auch so eine Finte, ne, die ganze Zeit wird vom Swordmaster geredet
und alle total viel Respekt auf der Insel, dann,
triffst du den Swordmaster und dann ist das halt so ein Mädel,
so, was auch gleich mal entwaffnend hier mit dem Schwert umgeht und dann,
überredet, musst du dich erstmal überreden, dass sie wirklich dich trainiert
und dann fängst du an und denkst so, okay, jetzt lerne ich Schwertkämpfen und
dann sagt sie gleich als erstes so, ja, Schwertkampf,
da geht es nicht um hier die Klinge schwingen, das kann jeder hier irgendwie
mit dem Ding in der Luft rumfuchteln, worum es richtig geht,
ist den Gegner so zu beleidigen, dass er kurz nicht aufpasst und dann,
dann lernst du halt so Beleidigung und wie du da drauf konterst,
also so immer einen draufzusetzen und du musst halt diese ganzen Kombinationen
auswendig lernen und ich weiß noch, wie ich mit einem Kumpel dann da gesessen habe, so,
okay, also wenn sie das sagt, dann ist die richtige Antwort,
du kriegst immer drei Antworten, um das zu kontern und die sind auch alle so
ein bisschen absurd und so, gerade wenn man noch nicht so gut Englisch kann,
dann alles aufgeschrieben, die ganzen Kombinationen und dann musst du dich da
mitten im Dschungel immer wieder da durch diese Witze dadurch Oh.
Das war so gruselig, vor allen Dingen sie sagt immer was und dann hast du diese
drei Antworten, das ist völlig nicht offensichtlich, was die richtige Antwort ist, ne?
Also es macht, wenn man halt so ein bisschen Bock auf Knobeln,
Puzzeln und so weiter hat, ist das schon.
Und also gerade Monkey Island besticht halt auch durch diesen extrem schrägen Humor.
Also das ist wirklich, weil du redest ja ständig mit den Leuten und dann erzählen
die irgendwelches Zeug.
Oder du guckst dir Dinge an und dann ist die Beschreibung von denen.
Da gibt es auch diesen Boat Salesman.
Ganz furchtbarer Typ, der so tut wie so ein Gebrauchtwagenhändler und auch so
auftritt und mit so einem Cowboy-Hut und so.
Und alte Piratenschiffe, die anpreist, die so halb versunken im Hintergrund. Der ist großartig, ja.
Und die Special Edition?
Das gibt es ja jetzt von Monkey Island 1, 2 von Day of the Tentacle,
wo sie, hatte ich ja auch schon mal erzählt, die alten Wasserfarben,
Zeichnungen, Konzeptbücher genommen haben und die jetzt umgesetzt haben.
Früher war das ja alles 8-Bit-Pixel-Grafik und jetzt hast du halt wunderschön
gezeichnete Szenerien, die halt auf den Original-Watercolor-Drawings basieren.
Und sie haben es halt auch vertont, also es gibt jetzt richtige Sprecher statt
irgendwie nur diesen Text, der da unten runterrattert.
Und gerade bei Monkey Island haben sie sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben,
dann den ganzen Charakteren auch wirklich die passenden Stimmen zu geben.
Also gerade dieser Gebrauchsschiff-Verkäufer, der ist so richtig so ein typischer Ami-Auto-Verkäufer.
Das Typ, richtig gut.
Ja, bei Book of Unwritten Tales bist du halt irgendwann in so einem Sumpf drin
und da hat halt dann irgendwie der Tod sein Lager aufgeschlagen und hat hinter
sich irgendwie das große Buch der Toten, wo er immer alle einschreibt,
die jetzt tot gegangen sind und weil du aber für eine bestimmte Aufgabe irgendwie
tot sein musst du es schaffen, dich in das Buch einzutragen,
und dazu musst du aber den Tod ablenken und dann bist du halt irgendwann tot
und dann musst du dich aber irgendwie wieder lebendig machen,
dann musst du den Tod davon überzeugen, dich aus dem Buch der Toten wieder auszutragen
und so lauter so ein Absurdkram halt Die.
Habe ich leider nie gespielt, aber ich habe irgendwann auch mal von einem Freunden
ein Point-and-Click-Adventure gespielt und das war wirklich so ein er gibt mir
einen Nachmittag seinen Gameboy und meint so,
hier kannst du spielen und er kam irgendwie am nächsten Tag wieder und meinte
so, hier kannst du wieder haben, ich will das nächste. Also es war halt echt cool.
Und wenn mich irgendjemand fragt, was meine Lieblingsspiele ever sind,
dann sind es meistens schon eher die, die mich so in eine ganz andere Welt so
reingezogen haben und für die Technologie, die es damals gab, so richtig irgendwie,
bis jetzt da drin, Monkey Island war definitiv eins davon.
Myst war eins.
Ja, Zelda fand ich auch auf dem Gameboy, hat mich auch so komplett weggezogen,
weil das auf einmal so eine Spieltiefe hatte und die Welt war einfach,
du warst dann in der Zelda-Welt und Metal Gear Solid 1 auf der Playstation ist
auf jeden Fall auch eins so der Meilensteine für mich in der Spielehistorie,
weil das war wie einfach ein Kinofilm, dieses ganze Spiel, nur das...
Was halt nicht linear ablief, sondern man hatte dann eben auch in dem Spiel
andere Handlungsstränge, die man langlaufen konnte und es war einfach totales Kino.
Und ja, Monkey Island war definitiv eins der ersten, was mich so richtig mal
weggezogen hat aus Realität, auch wenn das eine witzige Piratenwelt war.
Ja und Day of the Tentacle, das kam vor, nee, das ist jetzt mittlerweile auch
schon ein, zwei Jahre her, aber das ist auch so eins dieser legendären Point-and-Click-Adventures
und das ist jetzt auch re-released worden in Special Edition und allem.
Und iOS.
Und iOS, okay.
Das ist schon zwei Jahre her.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall schon eine Weile.
Ah, okay.
Nun gut, aber wir haben ja hier drei ignorante Nee.
Ich Nein, was heißt ignorant? Ich sage nicht ignorant.
Steht nicht drauf.
Nee, agnostisch. Also ich,
kann das ja alles ganz gut nachvollziehen, was du sagst. Ich frage mich halt
nur die ganze Zeit, warum das bei mir nicht Feuer schlägt.
Du warst halt schon zu alt.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch...
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich jetzt keine Berührungspunkte hätte mit Adventures
oder so. Ich habe frühen Zeiten...
Was sind denn die frühen Zeiten?
Na, Text-Adventures halt.
Borrowed Time.
So, hier Hitchhiker's Guide. Hitchhiker's Guide, ja. Text-Adventure und wie
hießen die anderen Dinger noch? Trinity.
Infocom-Adventures.
Die Infocom-Adventures.
Zorg.
Zorg und sowas. Wobei, das kenne ich zwar so ein bisschen, aber auch da bin
ich halt immer so, also ich weiß noch nicht, ich habe mich immer mit einem Text-Adventure
mal so intensiver beschäftigt.
Welches?
Weiß ich nicht mehr. Weil es hat dazu geführt, dass ich mir den Source-Code angeschaut habe.
Ich bin so schnell von ich spiele mit diesem Spiel zu, ich lerne jetzt nochmal
programmieren, weil mich das irgendwie viel mehr interessiert hat,
gegangen, dass so Spiele für mich irgendwie von Anfang an immer nur so ein bisschen
so Nebenbeschäftigungen waren.
Also diese Gamer, dieses Gamer-Selbstverständnis.
Na, das hatte ich aber auch nie.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen extrem. Gestern lief auch
so ein Kid an mir vorbei mit so einem T-Shirt irgendwie Gamers,
don't die, we respawn und so. Ja, klar kann man alles machen.
Und verstehe ich auch alles gut, nur mir ging es irgendwie nie so.
Ich habe so ein paar Spiele intensiver gespielt und ich hatte da auch so meinen Fun damit. Aber,
Ja, ich weiß, alle schütteln jetzt schon den Kopf und fragen sich,
was mit mir eigentlich los ist. Ich weiß ja auch nicht. Was ist eigentlich los mit dir?
Es kann einfach sein, dass ich einfach so ein kleiner Schisser bin und nicht kompetitiv genug bin.
Ja, aber wenn man hier eintritt.
Dass es mir ja gerade nicht kompetitiv ist. Genau, das ist ja gerade das Schöne
an Point-and-Click-Adventures, dass sie nicht kompetitiv sind.
Doch, sind sie, klar, natürlich. Es ist der Computer gegen mich. Und gegen die Zeit.
Ja, und wenn ich dann da irgendwo nicht weiterkomme, dann mache ich was anderes.
Ja, zugegebenermaßen, ich bin so ein bisschen so ein Sightseeing-Gamer. Also ich mag, ja.
Doch, total.
Doch, total, ich mag das halt. Also gerade so Open-World-Games.
Du hast überhaupt gar keinen First-Person-Shooter-Type,
weil da darfst du überhaupt gar nicht rumstehen.
Also nicht weniger Camper, sondern halt einfach durchrennen und mich von der
Welt beeindrucken lassen. Also das ist so.
Wobei das bei World of Warcraft habe ich das auch gemacht, aber die ist halt auch wirklich schick.
Das denke ich mir halt auch so. Ich habe manchmal so Tage, wo ich mir denke,
jetzt mal eine Stunde wieder WoW zocken und einfach nur durch die Welt dort rennen und fliegen.
Das wäre schon ein bisschen fein, aber ich habe so lange schon nicht mehr gespielt.
Das hat mich ja auch überhaupt nicht gefangen. Dennis ist da ja komplett drin versunken.
Aber so Adventure-Spiele sind halt sehr stark storygetrieben.
Also das finde ich halt gedriven. Das finde ich halt gerade schön da dran,
weil es gibt halt so viele Spiele, wo es halt, wo es halt mehr so sportlich
ist und dann musst du Punkte oder,
oder weiß ich nicht, oder andere Leute abballern oder weiß ich nicht was,
äh, und, und bei, bei, bei so einem Adventure hast du halt wirklich eine Story,
die sich, die sich halt ausbreitet und die du, die du halt mit jedem weiteren
Rätsel gelöst kriegst und, und irgendwann hast du halt auch so dieses Gefühl dafür, ähm,
Da liegt jetzt dieses Teil rum. Das ist irgendwie komisch und auffällig.
Das wird noch interessant.
Mal im Hinterkopf behalten und dann bist du, weiß ich nicht.
Und dann so kombiniere, kombiniere.
Genau, da war doch dieses Teil.
Aber ich muss zugeben, zum Beispiel bei Stimpleweed Park habe ich,
glaube ich, zweimal in Walkthrough geguckt.
Weil dann mir, was du jetzt sagtest, so mit Sidescengamer, da dachte ich nämlich
genau daran, dass jetzt habe ich einfach nicht mehr die Zeit wie früher,
wo ich mit einem Kumpel wirklich tagelang, wo es keine Walkthroughs im Internet gab, einfach.
So an diesen, wie kriegen wir jetzt dieses Schwert da von der Wand?
Und so, das muss jetzt gehen. und immer die gleiche Ecke.
Und jetzt, wo ich Thimble Week Park gespielt habe, ich bin erstaunlich weit gekommen.
Und ich fand auch, ich dachte so, ich habe noch so diesen Point-and-Click-Adventure-Flow,
der Denke, was du gerade meintest mit da, da lag doch irgendwas rum und so.
Aber dann zwei Stellen gab es da auch, wo ich dann zu viel Zeit schon reingesteckt
hatte und dachte mir, okay, fuck it, ich hole mir jetzt mal kurz den Walkthrough
ran für diese eine Stelle und dann geht es weiter.
Ja, vor allen Dingen das Schlimme ist, wenn du unterbrichst,
dann vergisst du diese ganzen Sachen und dann kommst du auch nicht mehr rein.
Also das ist halt auch so ein Spiel, solche Spiele muss man im Prinzip dann
in einem Rutsch durchspielen, sonst geht's nicht.
Ich glaube, da war meine Aufmerksamkeitsspanne schon zu kurz für so eine Games.
Aber mein erster Rechner war ja ein Mac und da gab's ja nix, wir hatten ja nix, ne?
So spieletechnisch und Monkey Island, also die LucasArts Games waren halt welche,
die auf dem Mac damals schon dann am Start waren und Monkey Island 1 hab ich
auf dem Mac auch auf Diskette gehabt und das war halt so eins der,
paar Spiele, die man an einer Hand abzählen konnte, die wir so hatten und als
wir das bekommen hatten, war das halt so, neuer Stoff.
Ein Spiel.
Ein Spiel, ja. Und deswegen, weiß nicht, das war dann halt ja, war es ganz natürlich.
So wie Marathon.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel.
Aber ich glaube auch, dass mir mittlerweile die Ausdauer fehlt,
da länger dabei zu bleiben.
Ich habe ja irgendwie vor so einem Jahr, wie hieß es doch gleich,
ein Spiel gespielt, wo ich den Namen vergessen habe.
Ja toll.
Da muss ich direkt mal in die Aktion.
Ich hab vor einem Jahr mal ein Spiel gespielt.
Don't Starve, jetzt weißt du, ja, Don't Starve. Und das fand ich so geil,
aber ich hab das irgendwie geschafft, vielleicht mal ja, irgendwie zwei Stunden
am Stück zu spielen, wobei eine Nacht hab ich irgendwie auch mal mit Freunden,
haben wir so eine kleine uns getroffen und irgendwie wirklich so die gesamte
Nacht mal durchgezockt.
Aber jetzt merke ich halt so, ich komm da nicht mehr ran. Also wenn ich da irgendwie
zehn Minuten dabei bleibe, dann bin ich gut.
Aber meistens höre ich so nach fünf schon wieder auf.
Ja, also ich spiele auf jeden Fall auch sehr viel weniger und Thimbleweed Park
war mal so eins der wenigen nach Jahren, wo ich mal gedacht habe, okay, here we go.
Cola, nee, Mate.
Tür abgeschlossen, alles, Wochenende, kein Einkauf erledigt.
Obwohl The Witness habe ich auch fast ganz durchgespielt. Da bin ich relativ weit gekommen.
Was ist das?
The Witness ist, das ist ein extrem spannendes Spiel und es ist extrem schwer
zu erklären, worum es eigentlich geht, weil du überhaupt keine Erklärung in dem Spiel findest.
Das Spiel beruht darauf,
dass du, da gibt es so quadratische Tafeln, wo du eine Linie ziehen musst in
dem Muster, das da drin ist, in dieser quadratischen Tafel.
und es gibt,
verschiedene Gesetzmäßigkeiten, die durch weitere Symbole erzeugt werden,
die dazu führen, dass du den Weg nur auf eine ganz bestimmte Weise ziehen kannst.
Das Spannende an dem Spiel ist, wie gesagt, du kriegst nichts gesagt.
Es fängt damit an, dass du vor der ersten Tafel stehst, wo nur ein Strich ist.
Das ist offensichtlich, wo man da langziehen muss.
Und nach einer Weile lernst du die ganzen Gesetzmäßigkeiten dieser Regeln,
dieser abstrakten Tafeln, wie die funktionieren, zu kennen.
Und kannst dich damit durch so eine Welt durchspielen, weil dir die Tafeln,
wenn du dir löst, manchmal neue Türen oder Brücken oder sonst was öffnen.
Also es ist extrem bunt und von der Grafik her auch sehr, sehr schön.
Aber es ist mitunter ziemlich schwierig.
Aber es läuft dann immer auf so Plattformen, die ich überhaupt nicht habe.
Zum Beispiel wie?
Hier steht PC und Playstation.
Achso, kann sein, dass ich das auf meinem Windows-PC gespielt habe.
Und jetzt wohl auch iOS, guck an.
Und jetzt auch iOS. Ja, stimmt, ist relativ teuer. Und ich glaube, macOS ist es jetzt auch.
10 Euro?
Ja, auf macOS kostet es glaube ich 30 oder so.
Achso, das läuft sogar auf macOS.
Ja, das ist erst seit kurzem.
Requires metal for rendering.
Also das ist, das fand ich, das fand ich auch und das ist wirklich,
man muss, man muss dann wirklich auch viel im Hinterkopf behalten und einfach
herausfinden, wie diese Gesetzmäßigkeiten sind.
Manchmal liegen da so komische Kassetten rum, die man sich dann anhören konnte.
Dann erzählt irgendwer irgendwas Philosophisches.
Das habe ich dann irgendwann nicht mehr gemacht, weil ich das komisch fand.
Aber ansonsten, man löst halt immer diese Tafeln. Und das ist ...
Also, ich fand das sehr gut.
Tafeln lösen klingt wie in der Schule.
Ja, aber es ist ...
Wo lädt man denn das runter? Da ist gar kein Link.
Ein Download, nichts. Ist das dann auf Steam oder was? Oder wie?
Ich glaube auf Steam ist es, beziehungsweise im App Store ist es.
Im App Store? Ah, da hätte ich ja mal hinlegen können.
Okay. Das ist, ja.
Aber die Backstory, so weit bin ich noch nicht gekommen. irgendwie findet man
da noch die Backstory raus, aber da.
Nix Apps war.
Nix Apps, was ist?
Das ist schön, wenn sie sagen, so ja, es gibt das hier irgendwie.
Aber Aber auf der Hauptseite ist doch unten der Buy-Button gewesen,
thewitness.net, einfach hier ohne News.
Schreibe ich Witness falsch?
Ja, Add to Card.
Hier, The Witness im App Store für den Mike.
Entweder hast du es falsch geschrieben.
Oder ich habe einfach das Icon übersehen.
Oder du hast das Icon übersehen Genau, das Icon von dem Spiel zeigt schon eine
von diesen Tafeln, da sind halt so Wege drauf und da sind Punkte Ach ja.
Tatsächlich, ja Das sah irgendwie aus wie so ein Utility-Programm Ja.
Ja, genau Nee, aber das sind diese Rätseltafeln, die man lösen muss Und immer
wenn man eine, oder meistens wenn man eine gelöst hat, geht da dieses Stromkabel
an und dann passiert, kann man gucken, wo das langläuft und dann passiert am
anderen Ende von dem Stromkabel was.
44 Euro und auf iOS kostet 10?
Ist ja lustig.
Ja, wo soll denn da der Unterschied sein?
Ist viermal größer.
Ist doch dasselbe Game, oder nicht?
Fragt mich nicht.
Wen soll ich denn sonst fragen?
Die Pfannkuchen.
Nee, und man muss da halt auch sehr viel einfach beobachten.
Weil manches eben auch nicht in der Tafel steckt, sondern in der Umgebung außenrum.
Die Sachen, die einen helfen, um herauszufinden, wo man seinen Weg auf der Tafel machen muss.
Also so ein bisschen so ein modernes Myst.
Ja. Allerdings ist es halt viel stärker nur auf diese Tafeln ausgelegt.
Myst war ja irgendwie, da war ja jede Welt komplett anders und jedes Rätsel
in diesen Welten war ja irgendwie komplett anders.
Okay.
Nun gut.
Nun gut. Jetzt haben wir viel über Spiele geredet.
Kann doch auch mal sein.
Ja, das ist auch ganz interessant.
Neulich mal noch mal wieder so ein bisschen ein Blick auf die Podcast-Landschaft
geworfen und wie sie sich so entwickelt, gerade in dieser ganzen ongoing Debatte über Geld.
Wird da ja viel geredet und was sich leider jetzt so ein bisschen durchsetzt,
ist halt so die Paywall Methode und da sind ja die Game-Podcasts auch ganz weit vorne.
Paywall für Game-Podcasts?
Jaja. Also die haben halt so angefangen über Patreon und so halt da voll Welle
zu machen, haben dann irgendwie so fünfstellige Beträge da abgerufen und haben
dann irgendwie auch so ihre Produktionszyklen,
gesteigert, wo ich mich halt immer frage,
wie kann jemand die ganze Zeit so viel über Spiele wissen wollen?
Also, was bitte gibt es über die fünf Spiele zu erzählen?
Es gibt einfach sehr, sehr viele Spiele.
Naja.
Ja, aber wenn du jetzt...
Waffen sind jetzt lila und schießt es das Blutblau.
Nein, aber wenn du jetzt jemanden hast, der sich sehr stark damit beschäftigt,
der eigentlich den ganzen Tag nichts macht, als die neuen Spiele alle anzutesten,
zu testen, um hinterher zu sagen, das und das und das ist geil und der Rest ist scheiße,
dann kann es sehr hilfreich sein für jemanden, der halt nicht unbedingt die
Spiele spielen will, wo andere Leute schon gesagt haben, dass die scheiße sind.
Offensichtlich ist das so. Aber tatsächlich hat halt eben dieser hohe Zuspruch
dann dazu geführt, dass halt dann immer mehr Exklusiv-Content gemacht wurde,
der dann halt hinter die Paywall kommt.
Diese ganzen Spendenplattformen wandeln sich ja jetzt langsam in so Paywall-Systeme eigentlich.
und ja, die Patreon-Bonus-Story. Genau, und das ist dann alles so ein bisschen
so Winner-Takes-It-All-mäßig, weil die Leute natürlich dann irgendwann so ihre
zwei, drei Sachen dann finanzieren und dann irgendwie andere natürlich da nicht
mehr hinkommen und dann sozusagen hinten runterfallen.
Also sozusagen das nicht ganz so demokratische Modell. Ohne das jetzt hier groß
kritisieren zu wollen, aber das findet einfach statt an der Stelle.
Aus dem Chat klingt gerade der Mann aus dem Mac-Podcast fragt,
was man denn die ganze Zeit über Spiele wissen wollen kann.
Was kann man denn die ganze Zeit über Max wissen wollen?
Oder Kalender.
Kalender ist doch schon längst durch. Das ist doch schon weg in Nokia, das Thema.
Ja, jeder hat da so seine eigene Welt und das ist auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Wir treiben doch alle zwei Wochen eine neue Sau durchs Dorf.
Ich habe doch nicht alle zwei Tage.
Nö.
Ja, aber das ist der Veröffentlichungszyklus, von dem ich spreche jetzt.
Ja, zwei, drei, vier, teilweise jeden Tag.
Du, ich finde die Let's Play-Leute noch viel absurder, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, dass die sich da halt irgendwie zwölf Stunden am Tag hinsetzen,
Spiele spielen und das dann auf YouTube veröffentlichen, das finde ich noch viel krasser.
Aber… War das nicht ein Twitch oder wie das heißt?
Gibt's auch, ja.
Also das scheint, aber das scheint a thing zu sein und es scheint Leute zu geben,
die da wirklich richtig Geld mitmachen und dann sei das halt so.
Bei Twitch gibt es auch Leute, die live coden. Letztens irgendwie entdeckt.
In den Weiten des Internets.
Wer solltest du mal live stricken auf Twitch?
Das ist ja langweilig. Glaube ich. Das geht nur mit Michaela.
Aber das Ding ist ja, bei diesen Let's Play Sachen ist ja nicht unbedingt super
interessant, was die spielen, sondern ich fühle mich ja von den Personen teilweise unterhalten.
Wie sie es kommentieren. Und du musst es nicht selber spielen.
Es gibt ja Spiele, die sind halt ein bisschen schwieriger.
Da hast du halt die Muskelreflexe nicht und dann guckst du halt an,
wie jemand anders das durchzockt.
Ich habe ja letztens den Film gesehen, Free to Play. Ich glaube,
der ist schon von 2011 oder so.
Der geht da drum, dass hier das Spiel Dota 2, das ist so fünf Mann gegen fünf
Mann irgendwie, so eine Art Capture the Flag, so ähnlich halt.
Wo jetzt der Open-AI-Bot den Meister platt gemacht hat.
Genau. Und der kommt auch in diesem Free-to-Play-Film vor, weil der hat damals,
da war in Köln die Gamescon, und da haben die da, ich glaube, es war die Gamescon,
da haben die halt so ein Dota-Turnier gemacht, der Gewinner kriegt eine Million
Dollar, was das größte Preisgeld ever war und der Film geht halt wie,
das begleitet sozusagen drei Leute aus drei verschiedenen Teams,
wie die denn da antreten und wie deren Erwartungen sind und auch ein bisschen
deren Family kommt mal zu Wort.
Also wer mal wissen will, wie so E-Sports und so weiter, das so ein bisschen
abgeht und was die Kids da so machen, vielleicht auch Eltern,
die sich da interessieren, der sollte sich vielleicht diesen Film Free to Play mal angucken.
Da kommt das so ein bisschen rüber und ich kannte dieses Dote auch nur vom Namen,
dass das so ein Riesending ist, aber ich wusste auch nie, was das genau ist
und da habe ich das dann mal da so ein bisschen gesehen und so.
Ich habe das das erste Mal gehört, als es dass man diesen Open AI-Bot ging.
Ja, ich auch. Das habe ich mir kurz davor ein Freund gezeigt,
der meinte, dann gibt es ja noch diesen Film, da sieht man ein bisschen mehr, was Dota ist und so.
Also wenn ich nicht total daneben liege, was sein kann, weil ich ja auch nicht
in dieser Spielewelt mehr so tief drin stecke, kam das ursprünglich aus so einem Mod für Warcraft 3.
Das ist Dota. Also Warcraft kennt ihr ja vielleicht noch aus alten Zeiten.
Warcraft 1 gab es ja auch auf Mac tatsächlich sogar.
Zwei auch noch.
Ja, und zwei auch noch. So eins dieser, wie nennt man diese spiele doch gleich.
Taktik-Spiele?
Ja, Strategie, genau, Strategie-Spiele oder so.
Ich glaube, es ist mehr Taktik als Strategie.
Und dann gab es halt irgendwann, genau, Warcraft 3 und da, ich weiß nicht,
ob es ein Mod war oder hier sagt einer im Chat eine Fun-Map,
wo sie sozusagen das Spiel genommen haben und es so ein bisschen anders interpretiert haben.
Und daraus ist dann sozusagen so eine komplett eigene Kategorie von E-Sport
und Turnier und Challenge irgendwie geworden.
Niemand spielt jetzt mehr sozusagen Warcraft 3, sondern alle nur noch diesen
einen Modus, was eben so ähnlich wie Capture the Flag oder so ähnlich daherkommt.
Wie gesagt, gespielt habe ich das auch selber nie, aber ich kannte auch mal
oder ich hatte auch mal Kollegen, die da in dieser Welt drin waren und der hat
mir dann mal so einen Grobabriss gegeben.
Klang aber nicht interessant genug für mich.
Der hatte das immer während der Arbeit, hat der so diese Turniere sich angeguckt irgendwie.
Während der Arbeit?
Da waren Arzis, die haben die ganze Zeit irgendwas am Laufen da.
Die einen gucken Serien, die anderen gucken Dota 2 Turniere.
Oder Dota, Dota.
Wie auch immer.
Ich hänge ja mehr so auf. So hat jeder so sein Medien Junkertum.
Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich nicht an irgendwas hänge.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt schon ein
bisschen an mir zweifle, weil ich jetzt irgendwie schon seit fast einem,
Ja, dreiviertel Jahr voll an dieser Polit-Amerika-Polit-Spritze hänge.
Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen gebe ich mir irgendwie diesen ganzen Amerika-Fanis. Warum eigentlich?
Welche Podcasts hörst du denn?
Naja, so das Übliche und dann Querbeet.
Achso, erzähl uns mehr.
Das Übliche und dann noch Querbeet.
Podsafe Amerika, also diese… Podsafe Amerika. Ja, also das ist.
Da habe ich zweimal reingehört, das hat mich nicht gefixt.
Aber warum machst du das? Du hast da irgendwie, das ist so ein bisschen wie Fußball, oder?
Ich meine, du hast da auch am Spiel, also auch hier bei Union,
du bist ja Union-Fan beim Spiel, du kannst eigentlich gar nichts mit auswirken,
du bist wirklich nur Zuschauer, also Konsumer eigentlich und das bist du doch
eigentlich bei dieser Politik-Diskussion auch, oder?
Du kannst nur Spaß dran haben oder dich darüber aufregen, aber du kannst eigentlich nichts dran ändern.
Es hat ja mit Spaß nicht so sehr was zu tun, sondern mehr, dass ich halt versuche,
möglichst nah an dem Geschehen zu sein, was unter Umständen den nächsten thermonuklearen,
Weltkrieg gerade vorbereitet.
Aber wäre es doch nicht sinnvoll, Survival-Training irgendwo zu nehmen oder
so andere Sachen zu machen?
Vielleicht macht er das jetzt schon am Wochenende.
Er macht aber nicht.
Ich kann dir das nicht sicher sagen, warum ich das tue. Ich sage nur,
ich tue es halt gerade so.
Und ich bin irgendwie in einem Maße über amerikanische Innenpolitik informiert,
wie es in meinem Leben noch nie war.
Wärst du halt Amis wahrscheinlich.
Senatoren-Namen rauf und runter und so weiter. Das ganze amerikanische politische
System habe ich mittlerweile verinnerlicht, was natürlich absurd ist,
weil es ist halt vor allem der helle Wahnsinn.
Andere gucken House of Cards, du guckst das in echt.
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen wie so ein Verkehrsunfall. Verstehst du?
Du stehst da und schaust dir einfach in super Slow-Mo an, wie das Auto über
die Leitplanke gleitet, so,
Funkenflug.
Aber es will leider nicht runterfallen.
Aber so wirklich so 10.000 Frames pro Sekunde irgendwie.
Und sich langsam überschlägt und dabei irgendwie der Tank anfängt zu explodieren und so ist das.
Naja, ehrlich gesagt, das Auto ist schon lange über die Leitplanke hinweg.
Ja, ja klar, das läuft ja jetzt schon. Ist schon die Klippe halb runter. Ja, halb. Genau.
Und jetzt will ich das auch noch sehen, bis das Ding endlich auf dem Strand aufschlägt.
Ja, so und dazu gehört natürlich auch dieser ganze Late Night Cosmos wo man
halt sagen muss, dass die Late Night Comedy Ach Göttchen,
Mensch also ich hab ja so meine Probleme mit den Amerikanern aber das Entertainment
Ding alter Vater, das haben die echt raus,
Wie der Stephen Colbert und diese ganzen Stephen Colbert.
Und wie heißt der Südafrikaner.
Trevor Trevor Noah.
Der ist auch so geil. Und Seth Meier, den gucke ich auch gerne.
Richtig.
Das sind die drei.
Genau, das sind glaube ich so mit die Besten und die anderen haben dann zwischendurch
finden die auch mal einen Korn.
Und ja, ist ganz interessant.
Oder weinen mal.
Aber ist auch teilweise ganz interessant, wie verlogen dann das Ding halt dann auch wieder ist.
Wie jetzt zum Beispiel mit dem Sean Spicer.
der da also monatelang irgendwie die Propaganda das Propagandamegafon in der Hand gehabt hat aber.
Der war doch so geil, also ich meine Sean Spicer der ist doch nicht zu toppen
der ist doch nicht zu toppen, oder?
Ne der ist wahrscheinlich genau, der ist wahrscheinlich nicht zu toppen und
das ist halt was interessantes dass der Typ ist halt eigentlich im Prinzip so
das Sprachrohr dieses merkwürdigen amerikanischen,
Möchtegern Neofaschismus der da irgendwie versucht sich irgendwie gerade Bahn
zu brechen, aber dabei einfach kolossal sich Wunden holt.
Man weiß halt auch immer nicht, sind die alle nur verrückt und es wird irgendwann
alles in einem großen Bruhaha enden und wir werden uns die Bäuche halten oder,
starten die irgendwann nochmal an der Stelle so durch, dass das einfach irreparable
Schäden nach sich zieht.
Ich glaube, das ist so im Prinzip das Setting, was man jetzt gerade verfolgt.
Ich glaube, man kann jetzt schon diskutieren, ob das, was sie bisher geleistet
haben, schon irreparabel ist.
Glaube ich nicht. Zum Beispiel.
Wurde schon mal irgendwann irgendwas besser?
Ja, ja, klar.
Von Gesetzen, die kamen, dass die wieder weggingen, zum Beispiel auch diese
deutschen Terrorgesetze aus der deutschen Herbst, sodass die da eingefügt haben,
das wurde nicht zurückgenommen bis heute, oder? Also da besser wird dann nichts mehr.
Ja, naja, also ehrlich gesagt, schwierige These, aber global betrachtet wird
ja eigentlich alles die ganze Zeit immer besser.
Finde ich nicht, sondern das kann man ja wissenschaftlich, belegen.
Kann man das?
Ja, kann man.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, doch, ich glaube, man kann das schon relativ objektiv sogar sagen.
Du kannst ja mal hier auf Our World in Data schauen, da habe ich auch mal einen
Podcast zu gemacht, deswegen kenne ich das Projekt ganz gut.
Bei Forschergeist, das ist sehr interessant.
Das ist halt eine Arbeit, wo Studien zusammengesucht werden zu unterschiedlichen
Kategorien, die die Entwicklung der Welt umsetzen.
betrachten in dieser jeweiligen Kategorie. Und das ist halt alles.
Gesundheit, Bevölkerungswachstum, Umwelt, Technologie,
allgemeine Arbeitsbeschäftigung, Mindesteinkommen, Kriege, Morde, Rechte.
Aber hat nicht letztens erst der Typ, der hier den Nobelpreis bekommen hat,
dieser sowieso Thaler, also mit TH geschrieben, weil er irgendwie meinte,
die Wissenschaft seit 50 oder 100 Jahren, die macht zwar alles sehr schön in
Zahlen, so wie jetzt dein World in Data,
aber sie machen das Unrationale des Menschen, was man halt nicht so erfassen
kann in Zahlen, das ging halt unter und seitdem,
passt das halt auch alles nicht mehr so richtig, weil alle nur noch gnadenlos
nach ihren Zahlen irgendwie da verfolgen. Da war ja über den Typen so.
Alle nur noch, das macht ja niemand, das ist ja irgendwie neu.
Also es hat sich ja bisher noch niemand mal wirklich die Entwicklung angeschaut.
Also ich hab sowas vorher noch nicht gesehen, dass Projekt gewinnt ja am laufenden
Meter auch an Popularität.
Und um es mal kurz zu sagen,
also abgesehen vom Klimawandel, also von dem Umweltding, was einfach das große
Problem unserer Zeit ist, die ganzen klassischen Probleme der Menschheit,
da wird immer alles besser.
Es gibt immer weniger Kriege, es sterben immer weniger Leute an Hunger,
es leben immer weniger Leute in Armut, die Bildung wird immer besser.
Also du kannst dir all diese ganzen Punkte anschauen und wirst feststellen,
dass einfach 99 Prozent der Fälle long term, also ich rede jetzt wirklich von,
immer so weit, wie es Daten gibt.
Das geht teilweise 100 Jahre zurück, also je nach Thema. Manchmal ist es auch
nicht relevant weiter zurückzugucken.
Teilweise halt hunderte, teilweise tausende Jahre. Je nachdem,
wie man das eben wo es da eben auch entsprechende Studien gibt,
die dann entsprechende Quellen auch aufgearbeitet haben.
So, also das ist Big Picture. Big Picture ist, eigentlich wird immer alles besser.
Im Kleinen, also in unserem Zeitraum werden natürlich Dinge auch mal massiv schlechter.
Das heißt nicht, dass sie dann nicht in the long term auch wieder sehr viel besser werden.
da muss ich halt nur 20, 30 Jahre zurück schauen,
da war Terror in den 80ern, ich bitte dich, das war doch einfach ein Dauerthema,
ich meine es hat doch jeden Tag irgendwo geknallt war.
Es letztens irgendwie so Terror in UK.
70ern.
80ern ohne Ende, seit 2000 rum eigentlich irgendwie fast gar nichts mehr und
die Terrorgesetze jetzt wenden
die wahrscheinlich jeden Tag an und damals irgendwie sehr, sehr selten.
Ja und Spanien unter Faschismus und überall haben sie sich irgendwie die Köpfe
eingehauen und ohne Ende Kriege ganz aus Asien war irgendwie überzogen mit Kriegen etc.
jetzt ist es auch ganz aus Asien überzogen mit Hotelketten.
Ja.
So. Und na klar gibt es irgendwie Probleme und sicherlich ist alles noch,
müsste alles noch viel besser werden und sicherlich gibt es einzelne Bereiche
die sich gerade ein wenig gegen den Trend entwickeln,
nur letztlich zeigt sich halt immer wieder, dass so in the long run die Dinge
sich dann doch letzten Endes positiv auswirken.
Wie sind wir jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen? Ach ja, genau, Amerika.
Genau, dieser Verkehrsunfall. Also Podsafe Amerika vielleicht nochmal,
also Crooked Media heißt das Projekt, also die machen gleich mehrere Podcasts, wie das so ist.
Das Ganze, von daher schon mal ganz unterhaltsam als das so drei,
ne? Im Wesentlichen drei, vier.
Sind das nicht drei und manchmal der vierte, der von Pod Save the World dabei ist?
Ja, genau. Also es ist irgendwie so ein Konglomerat von mehreren Podcasts und
der Hauptpodcast, der am Anfang war, Pod Save America, wird im Wesentlichen
von dreien moderiert und dann gibt's halt noch Pod Save the People und keine
Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, ich höre die alle nicht.
Und ja,
Die drei waren halt Redenschreiber von Obama.
Das heißt, die waren halt im White House und haben irgendwie die Reden für Obama
geschrieben und hatten halt von daher einen sehr interessanten Einblick in diese
ganze Policy und sind überhaupt relativ findig da drin.
und sie kommentieren jetzt quasi das innenpolitische Geschehen ungefähr zweimal
die Woche, ist das sozusagen immer so top aktuell.
Dinge passieren und dann kriegst du halt Einblicke, Interviews etc.
und das ist einfach ein interessantes Podcast-Format an sich,
weil quasi an dieser Stelle Podcast wieder seine,
Kräfte voll entfalten kann, weil du willst halt den persönlichen Bezug haben
zu den Leuten, das schafft halt da irgendwie eine Nähe, Vertrauen,
die machen halt auch ihre Live-Shows, da sind die Leute auch brauchbar begeistert
und dieses ganze Projekt haben sie halt,
lostreten können und sind jetzt auch so einer der Hubs für diese ganze Widerstandsbewegung.
Nicht das einzige, aber sicherlich ein nennenswerter Teil davon.
Ich würde das jetzt gar nicht überhöhen, ist halt einfach interessant sich das
anzuhören, kann sich vielleicht auch nicht jeder geben, aber ich bin halt ein
bisschen drauf hängen geblieben.
Könnte man sagen, dass das einfach so eine Phase ist. Weil man hat ja manchmal sowas, ne?
Wo man sich halt ein paar Wochen in so ein Thema reinsteigert und dann hat man
es durch und dann sucht man sich auch was Neues.
Oder man fährt in den Urlaub und der Stream reißt ab und danach sucht man sich
was Neues. Das passiert ja auch öfter mal.
Genau, aber das hält halt jetzt schon mal ein Dreivierteljahr an.
Oh ja, ist ja auch gerade was los da.
Ja, kann man so sagen.
Ähnliches Ding hatte ich irgendwie seinerzeit mal mit Katrina,
als irgendwie da dieses New Orleans Desaster losgegangen ist.
Da war ich ja irgendwie auch zwei Wochen irgendwie von der Welt abgeschnitten, um sowas zu verfolgen.
Ja.
Kann Spaß machen.
Ich erinnere mich.
So mit Live-Shop-Cab und so. Ja, genau. Those were the days.
So.
Es macht aber auch echt Spaß, denen zuzuhören bei Podsafe America.
Die haben das wirklich ganz gut drauf, diese Mischung aus sie informieren über
ein Thema, haben irgendwie halt die Senatoren da wirklich mit Live-Schalte mit
drin und sie sind halt immer noch lustig.
Also es ist, ich glaube, das ist der einzige Podcast, wo ich die Werbung nicht
wegskippe, weil man einfach immer lachen kann.
Auch bei der Werbung?
Ja.
Ich skippe die weg.
Echt? Ich finde das immer ziemlich lustig.
Also du hörst das auch?
Ja, ich höre das auch. Und es ist sehr, sehr lustig. Also ich höre die sehr gerne.
Ich kann Werbung nicht ertragen.
Ist das auch so ein bisschen Grabes Humor oder wie nennt man das?
Also so das ist schon so absurd, dass man dass man schon wieder lachen muss.
Obwohl es eigentlich nicht witzig ist.
Weißt du bei der Werbung?
Nee, die... Bei Potsdamerika. Beides, ja.
Dass man es sich anhört.
Naja, ich meine, so ein bisschen wie ich hier auch mit Linus irgendwie diese
ganze netzpolitische Situation, das ist ja auch sozusagen das permanente Vortragen
schlechter Nachrichten, aber man lacht halt trotzdem.
Podcast ist, wenn man trotzdem lacht.
Tumor ist, wenn man trotzdem lacht.
Jetzt heißt es Podcast. Und da ich meine, das ist auch so ein bisschen Comic Relief.
Also du musst dann über sowas auch lachen können, um einfach die Kraft sammeln
zu können, um dich dann dem auch noch entsprechend entgegenzustellen.
Und wenn man sich halt hier zum Beispiel diese Phase anschaut,
diese permanenten Versuche der Republikaner
jetzt da irgendwie dieses Gesundheitssystem in Trümmer zu legen.
Ich meine, das ist einfach mal krass. Die kontrollieren theoretisch die komplett,
alle Institutionen, ja, Haus, Senat und White House, alles ist jetzt sozusagen
und kriegen es nicht hin.
Und theoretisch den Präsidenten, wenn man den kontrollieren kann.
Das ist ja White House. Und das liegt nicht nur, aber auch daran,
dass sich jetzt eben sozusagen die halbwegs aufgeklärten Menschen da in den
USA halt jetzt auch zusammenschließen und gerade irgendwie krasse Netzwerke
bilden, um denen auch einfach die Hölle von unten zu geben.
Und das ist halt das Interessante.
Also man beobachtet jetzt quasi mal den Widerstand und ist halt immer so,
okay Amerika, jetzt kommt es wahrscheinlich drauf an.
Wenn ihr das Ding nicht gedreht bekommt, dann nimmt euch keiner mehr ernst.
Aber so gar nicht. Und das wissen die auch.
Also die wissen einfach, dass ihr Ruf von 100 Jahren auf dem Spiel steht.
Und das ist halt so mein persönlicher Verkehrsunfall, den ich mehr oder weniger täglich gebe. Bin ich.
Ja, den Herrn Ruf wird nicht mehr besser.
Apropos.
Wir müssen halt noch hinkriegen, dass er nicht mehr schlechter wird. Naja.
Apropos Katastrophen. Letty, du hast da auch noch eine Story.
Ich glaube Hucki. Hucki.
Eigentlich wollte ich Roddy sagen.
Aber wir sitzen in der Freakshow nah beieinander.
Hucki auf den Pucki.
Roddy und ich, das ist nebeneinander. Da kann man schon mal durcheinander kommen.
Hucki und Roddel.
Ja, Michael Roddel, der hat doch gesagt.
Ja, was?
Der Hucki.
Nee, ich habe am Donnerstag mich auch mal von der Deutschen Bahn überraschen
lassen, was so ein Unwetter heißen kann.
Und ich meine, dass irgendwie Wetter in Deutschland ist, das ist mir ja irgendwie auch klar.
Aber was ich irgendwie sehr faszinierend fand bei dieser gesamten Geschichte
ist, dass irgendwie einen Tag
vorher klar ist, dass es geht um den Sturm Xavier, Xaver, wie auch immer.
Laut Wikipedia ein Sturmtief.
Ein Sturmtief, genau.
Ich sage absichtlich laut Wikipedia dazu, weil in dem Artikel über Orkan steht
eine Windgeschwindigkeit drin,
die das Sturmtief Xavier überschritten hat und weswegen es dann trotzdem in
der Wikipedia als Sturmtief und nicht als Orkan, weiß ich nicht.
So, was wolltest du erzählen?
Dieses laue Lüftchen jedenfalls, welches über Deutschland hinwegfegte.
Naja, das Vogelau war das nicht. Hinwegfog.
Und einen Tag vorher schon fast angekündigt wurde. Ich finde es immer wieder
faszinierend, wenn man dann auf Reisen ist.
wie gut es die Deutsche Bahn im Griff hat, mit solchen Situationen umzugehen.
Das war jetzt ironisch, oder?
Nicht.
Aber mal ehrlich, vielleicht muss ich mich ja auch da zurückhalten.
Nee, aber eigentlich ist mir egal.
Wenn da so fucking Bäume auf die Strecke fallen, und nicht nur auf eine Strecke,
sondern auf mehrere, weil die haben ja auch, man könnte sagen,
ist ja kein Ding, dann kommt da so ein Einsatzwagen, so ein paar Bauarbeiter,
die machen das weg und dann ist gut.
Aber wenn das auf ganz vielen Strecke und mit ganz vielen Bäumen passiert,
ja, was willst du denn machen?
Das meine ich auch nicht. Das finde ich auch völlig okay. Darüber will ich nicht
diskutieren. Aber was ich halt
echt nicht okay finde, ist, dass man keinen Plan B hat. Also ich meine...
Wie soll der denn aussehen?
Was ist denn überhaupt erstmal passiert? Was ist dir denn passiert und woraus
ziehst du jetzt deine...
Was mir passiert ist, dass ich auf Dienstreise gehen musste und statt im schönen
Frankfurt zu stranden, wo es noch die Option gab, am Nachmittag quasi wegzukommen
aus Frankfurt mit einem Auto oder einem anderen Gerät,
sind wir in einen Zug eingestiegen, wo keine Informationen waren,
dass zu dem Zeitpunkt schon kein Zugverkehr mehr nach Berlin möglich war.
Also wirklich eine Situation, die irgendwie abzusehen war. Es lief nichts mehr,
weit nach dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie die Strecke gesperrt haben, wo man einfach sagen kann, okay, Leute.
Wo haben sie dir diese Informationen nicht gegeben?
An weder in der App der Deutschen Bahn mit diesem Navigator noch über,
ich weiß nicht, ob es auf der Webseite dann irgendwann vielleicht stand,
aber am Bahnhof in Frankfurt am Main wussten die das nicht.
Und ich saß dann in einem Zug dran, wo der Zugbegleiter sehr scherzhaft meinte,
jo, eigentlich sollten wir nach, ich glaube, Oldenburg fahren.
Wir kicken mal, wie weit wir kommen. Wir wissen es noch nicht so richtig.
und ich mir halt auch dachte, okay und meine Hoffnung war halt bis Hannover
zu kommen und von Hannover noch wegzukommen nach Berlin irgendwie so am Nachmittag,
und also ich meine, dass da irgendwie Sachen auf die Bäume auf die Strecke fallen,
darüber muss man nicht diskutieren, das ist eine Kacksache und da stelle ich
der Deutschen Bahn irgendwie nicht hier hin so,
räumt die mal schneller weg aber ich meine, wenn man weiß irgendwie,
dass die Strecken gesperrt sind, sollte man das an den Leuten an die Leute kommunizieren
und die haben halt so eine App, wo man halt wirklich sagen kann,
ey bleibt, wo ihr seid, ihr kommt nicht mehr nach Hause.
Und wir haben halt auch keine Idee, wie ihr nach Hause kommt.
Also ich finde dieses Management, wenn etwas passiert, dass man die Leute halt
irgendwo stranden lässt, irgendwie
komisch, ohne wirklich einen Plan zu haben, was eigentlich abgeht.
Also wir sind halt in Kassel gestrandet, wie sehr viele andere.
Und vor allen Dingen, also ich meine, für mich ist es jetzt nicht so schlimm,
weil ich irgendwie nicht alt und gebrechlich bin oder ein Kind habe.
Aber für die war das halt irgendwie so ein bisschen, kriegen wir jetzt hier
ein Hotel gestellt, müssen wir irgendwas selber bezahlen, fahren,
Züge und halt so nicht wissen, dass die Strecke gesperrt schon war seit Mittags.
War halt so eine Situation, wo ich mir denke, das könnte man vielleicht mal,
Darüber nachdenken, ob man sich dafür so ein Setup baut mit,
okay, wir wissen, dass die Strecke gesperrt ist, wir müssen den Leuten sagen,
ihr könnt ja nicht schlecht am Bahnsteig bleiben, auch wenn sie irgendwie so
Züge hingestellt haben, damit die Leute sich da drin aufwärmen können.
dass man irgendwie sagt, okay, wir müssen die Leute halt irgendwie verteilen,
vielleicht ein bisschen flächendeckender, weil, oh Wunder, in Kassel sind die
Leute gestrandet und was machen die Hotels? Richtig, Messepreise auffahren.
Das ist halt dann auch immer so eine Sache, wo man sich denkt,
das könnte man vielleicht ein bisschen besser lösen.
So Sachen treten halt nicht häufig ein oder hofft man jedenfalls.
Aber dass man so mit so einer Situation
nicht umgehen kann, das fand ich irgendwie sehr, sehr eigenartig.
Und eben so dieses, okay, wir haben einen Plan, wie wir mit diesen Massen umgehen.
Also sozusagen die Kommunikation der Bahn an dem Tag war schlecht.
Genau, auch untereinander. Die wussten dann echt gar nichts,
die Leute, die dann bei der Deutschen Bahn irgendwie versucht haben,
die Leute irgendwie einen Taxigutschein oder sowas zu geben oder ihnen zu sagen,
fahrt in die Stadt zurück, wo ihr hergekommen seid oder so eine Sachen.
Das fand ich irgendwie so ein bisschen eigenartig.
Es gab ja Hotelzüge, ne?
Genau, es gab, also das.
Das habe ich auch gehört, die Hotelzüge.
Genau, das hieß, so Aufenthaltszug hieß das, also in Kassel war das so,
es gab ein Intercity und ein ICE direkt,
die auf dem Gleis einfach standen, man konnte sich da reinsetzen,
man hat irgendwie was zu trinken und was zu essen bekommen, konnte halt da drin auch pennen,
in der Tat, aber der stand halt einfach nur auf dem Gleis in dem Bahnhof und
man hatte eine Möglichkeit, sich irgendwo hinzusetzen, weil in dem Bahnhof war
das extrem zugig und kalt und es waren dann halt echt nicht so angenehme Temperaturen und Regen.
Das fand ich aber schon mal eine ganz gute Idee.
Das war eine super Sache, also das war immerhin etwas, aber sie konnten halt
den Leuten auch nicht sagen, also waren irgendwie ältere Leute,
die irgendwie nach Hause wollten, konnten sie ihnen halt nichts sagen,
nichts anbieten, also ich meine gerade eben, wenn man älter ist,
hat man vielleicht jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so seine gesamte Tablettenvorrat vielleicht dabei.
Also ich meine, es ist halt echt so ein Ding, wo ich mir dachte so,
wow, ich kann ja nicht schlecht, also man kann ja nicht davon ausgehen,
man hat immer so sein komplettes Setup irgendwie dabei, wenn man mit der Deutschen
Bahn unterwegs ist oder mit einem anderen gerät.
Wo wir wieder beim Survival-Training wären.
Da wären wir wieder beim Survival-Training, wahrscheinlich ist das mal eine
ganz gute Maßnahme, aber diese Art und Weise, wie man so Situationen irgendwie
nicht bewältigen kann und scheinbar auch keine richtige Strategie darüber fährt, boah.
Ja gut, zumindest war das jetzt deine Wahrnehmung in Frankfurt.
Gibt es noch Anlass zu glauben, dass das überall so war?
Wenn man sich so umgehört hat, schon. Also auch wohl die Berliner S-Bahn standen
tausende Leute rum, da war es keiner, der irgendwie den Leuten gesagt hat,
ja nee, sorry, hier fällt alles aus, die nächsten Stunden geht hier gar nichts
oder sonst wie, sondern da war einfach niemand.
Die haben sich da verdrückt, weil sie wahrscheinlich den Ansturm gar nicht ausgehalten
haben, die drei Mitarbeiter, die da so rumstanden oder weil sie schon heiser
waren und sind wahrscheinlich einfach weggegangen.
Vor allem haben die gar keine Mitarbeiter mehr.
Das kommt auch noch dazu.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, also die...
Ich war ja in Dreilinden Donnerstag, ganz normal, tagsüber.
Also für Nicht-Berliner, da wo früher mal der Übergang zur DDR war.
Also kurz vor den Toren von der Stadt, da kommt man eh schlecht hin.
Und wenn dann weder die S-Bahn fährt, noch der Bus, also zu Fuß hätte ich es
noch bis zum S-Bahnhof geschafft, aber die S-Bahn fuhr ja nicht,
die Regionalbahn fuhr ja auch nicht. Mich hat dann ein Kollege mitgenommen.
Da sind wir dann einmal kurz durch die Stadt gefahren, kurz,
sind wir dann einmal quer durch die Stadt gefahren, weil die Autobahn war auch dicht.
Keine Ahnung, ob da auch ein Baum drauf gefallen ist. Auf jeden Fall quer durch
die Stadt sind an einigen S-Bahnhöfen vorbeigefahren, die tatsächlich zu waren.
Und da waren Leute mit gelber Jacke davor, aber nicht alle.
Und dann die U-Bahn, die fuhr weitestgehend noch. Das ist selbst die oberirdische.
Die haben sie aber einen Zeitpunkt.
Glaube ich, da hast du auch die Bilder von Alex auch gesehen, von der U5.
Also das...
Naja, der ganze Bahnsteig einfach voll und Leute standen da schon alle mit Telefon.
Ich stehe hier schon eine halbe Stunde.
Ich weiß von ein paar Leuten, die da auch nicht begegnen wollten und dann am
Ende zwei Stunden durch die Stadt gelaufen sind, weil halt nichts vor Sinnvoll.
Wo ich dann richtig angepisst war, war halt, dass sie den Schienenersatzverkehr
halt einfach mal gestrichen haben, weil sie halt auf der Ringbahn bauen.
Die Ringbahn fuhr dann irgendwie einen Tag später wieder, aber der Schienenersatzverkehr
war einfach für drei Tage gestrichen.
Also, aber dann halt auch ohne, dass an der Haltestelle was stand,
ohne dass an der Anzeige was stand, ohne dass an der Haltestelle jemand stand,
der gesagt hat, hier kommt jetzt kein Bus.
Vor allen Dingen, da standen halt vor allen Dingen, da standen relativ viele
Leute, die sahen halt so nach Flüchtlinge aus dem arabischen Raum aus,
die kein richtiges Deutsch konnten,
die standen halt an der Bushaltestelle und warteten schon eine halbe Stunde, dass da kein Bus kommt.
Und es war kein Hinweis, kein nix.
Also das war schon, also gerade die S-Bahn Berlin hat sich da nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich die Frage, inwiefern ist das jetzt ein systemisches
Problem? Also inwiefern hat die Bahn nicht die Prozesse, um das zu machen?
So wie sie den Schienenersatzverkehr vorher schon durchgezogen haben,
ist das ein systemisches Problem. Weil wenn du dir anguckst,
wie die BVG Schienenersatzverkehr macht, das ist echt ein anderer Schnack.
Da hast du Busfahrer, die, na gut, freundlich müssen sie von mir aus nicht unbedingt
sein, aber wenigstens kompetent.
Die sind kompetent, die sagen auch die Haltestellen an, die haben Busse,
die sind für öffentlichen Nahverkehr brauchbar. Also du kannst keinen Schienenersatzverkehr
mit einem Reisebus machen, besonders wenn dann zwei Leute mit dem Fahrrad einsteigen.
Also das ist halt irgendwie, und dann sind die Leute kurz davor,
sich zu kloppen, weißt du, so, ja.
Also das Ding ist halt, weil was ich daran nicht verstehe ist so dieses,
man weiß, dass dieser Sturm kommen könnte, man weiß ja wahrscheinlich auch,
weil irgendwie weiter oben in Hamburg der Sturm wahrscheinlich als erstes angekommen
ist, so es kommt demnächst auf uns zu.
Naja, Sie haben ja präventiv eigentlich über die Medien das schon quasi verbreitet?
Genau, also über die Medien scheinbar, aber bei mir ist das halt,
also in dieser App ist das null angekommen und da war ich halt so irritiert,
ich war halt voll der Meinung, okay fährt.
Also das ist die eine Sache, aber warum man halt vielleicht auch nicht irgendwie
sagen kann, also jetzt mal BVG das Beispiel oder S-Bahn, wenn man irgendwie
weiß, dass es ankommt, schon mal sozusagen, ey Leute, schnapp vielleicht mal
ne Zug eher oder ne Stunde eher.
Also ob man sowas nicht irgendwie bauen könnte, fast jeder hat diese komischen
Apps irgendwie drauf von der BVG, um zu wissen, wie man von A nach B kommt.
Ob man sowas nicht darüber lösen könnte. Also Push-Notifications schicken muss
man natürlich erlauben, das ist die eine Sache.
Naja, aber diese ganzen Firmen, die gerade so Apps haben, das ist ja mehr oder
weniger, ist das für die ja auch noch alles total neu, dass sie erstmal anfangen,
das auch dann für Notifications und Zeug und weiß ich nicht, was alles zu benutzen.
Also da würde ich ehrlich sagen, das traue ich denen auch gar nicht zu.
Soweit sind die einfach noch nicht.
Ja, aber Apple hat es ja halt wie gesagt geschafft. Also du hast ja keine Push-Notification
bekommen, aber wenn du versucht hast, eine Route im öffentlichen Nahverkehr zu bekommen,
dann hast du erstens keine sinnvollen Treffer bekommen Und zweitens diesen Hinweis,
wo dann drinsteht, keine S-Bahn, keine Regionalbahn und auch kein Bus.
Und dann weißt du halt Bescheid, ja.
Also ich frage mich halt echt so, wie man das mal irgendwie ordentlich optimieren
könnte, damit eben so diese...
Das wären wir halt gewesen, wenn man am Tag vorher nicht einfach,
also wenn man vielleicht auch irgendwie schon so eine Unwetter-Notification
bekommt, dass jeder weiß, okay, das Wetter wird sehr schlecht und vielleicht
werden sie auch noch ein bisschen konkreter werden und wenn sie sagen, ja hier,
also rechnet damit, dass halt Sachen auf die Gleise fallen, dass Züge nicht
fahren, also dass wenn jemand morgen reisen will, dann ein eigentlich,
mehr oder weniger, vergesst das. Wenn es geht, dann macht das morgen nicht.
So, wenn ihr es anders machen könnt. Aber das sowas...
Katwarn, weil es hier gerade jemand im Slack schreibt, Katwarn hat tatsächlich
einen Tag vorher die Push-Notification rausgeschickt, dass es zu orkanartigen Sturmböen kommen kann.
Was heißt Katastrophen? Also Katwarn ist Katastrophen-Warning,
aber wann, wer, wie kriegt die?
Das ist eine App, die kannst du installieren. Katwarn heißt die.
Katwarn ist so das vom...
Vom DWD, Deutscher Wetterdienst oder so?
Das hat schon so ein bisschen mehr...
Aber die nehmen auch die ganzen offiziellen Meldungen mit auf.
Jaja, also wenn bei Katwan steht...
Wenn das ein Problem ist, dann ist es ein Problem.
Ich verstehe.
Das ist ziemlich sicher. All die großen, diese ganzen, diese krassen Regenwetterlagen,
die wir jetzt im Sommer hatten.
Diese App, weil gibt es wahrscheinlich eine Menge.
Genau, die ist so rot.
Die ist so grau mit so einem roten Punkt in der Mitte.
Ja, das ist Katwan.
So, laden wir das alle mal schön runter.
Genau, wir laden alle mal Katwan runter. Ich habe das schon drauf.
Ich meine, es nützt ja nichts, wenn drei Prozent der Bevölkerung wissen,
dass irgendwie ein Sturm kommt. Also eigentlich sollten es ja irgendwie alle wissen.
So, weil dann bringt es ja vielleicht auch was. Weil ich meine,
diese ganze, dieser volle Bahnhof, der auf dem Bild da zu sehen war,
der ist halt auch vermeidbar, wenn viele Leute halt einfach zu Hause bleiben.
Aber die Nachrichten, die kamen erst, ja, als der Strom schon da war,
dann kam irgendwie im Radio oder im, ja, habe ich alles eigentlich nicht,
aber per Internet irgendwie, wo sie dann sagen, ja, am besten bleibt man zu
Hause und geht nicht raus und so.
Im Chat hat gerade einer noch eine URL gepostet, fahrwegdbnetze.com.
Das ist jetzt ein File, was er verlinkt hat auf den heutigen Netzreport und
meinte halt, es wäre da relativ aktuell gewesen.
Aber ja, das ist halt auch so eine Seite, die muss man halt erstmal finden.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, das ist so ein PDF, was unter einer kryptischen URL irgendwo
liegt. Also wenn du, wie soll ich da hinkommen?
Naja, ich versuche gerade auch über die normale Einstiegsseite das zu finden.
Das ist irgendwie alles nicht so easy.
Ja, also ich denke, dass das alles verbesserungswürdig ist. Das hat die Bahn auch gemerkt.
Andererseits, ja, die Ansprüche steigen offenbar auch.
Naja, was ich einen ganz interessanten Aspekt fand war,
dass der Sturm wohl zu einem relativ frühen Zeitpunkt im Herbst kam und alle
Bäume noch die Blätter hatten, weswegen die Sturmschäden an den Bäumen halt sehr stark waren.
Also von abgedeckten Dächern hat ja keiner geredet, es war ja auch kein riesiger
Sturm, er war ordentlich, aber es war halt kein fetter Orkan oder so.
Aber er hat halt deswegen sehr viele Bäume umgepflügt, weil die halt alle die Blätter noch hatten.
Also abgesägte Dächer gab es. Auch hier in Berlin, auch hier um die Ecke und so.
Ja, ich habe auch zwei Dixi-Klos auf der Straße liegen sehen.
Die liegen auch so öfter mal.
Ja, aber nicht auf der Gegenfahrbahn. Aber nicht auf der Gegenfahrbahn auf der linken Spur.
Manchmal angezündet.
Naja.
Also es gibt wohl Nina und Katwan. Katwan sei Deutscher Wetterdienst und Feuerwehr.
Nina ist Deutscher Wetterdienst und Katastrophenschutz.
Das heißt, man braucht dann zwei, da gibt es aber noch eine dritte, kann das sein?
Warnwetter.
Nee, da unten gab es noch was mit B gerade.
Mit B, BWAP.
Keine Ahnung, wie die jetzt alle im Zusammenhang stehen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es solche Apps.
Ich kenne nur Katwarn. Bisher hat mich Katwarn vor allen größeren Dingen bewahrt.
Wobei ich jetzt auch dieses Xavier Ding auch unterschätzt habe.
Ich habe zwar auch gesehen, hier Warnung, lalala, dann gucke ich so auf Regenradar.
Wieso? Ist doch gar kein Regen. War er auch nicht.
Ne?
Es war einfach nur fucking windig. Aber das ist immer auch das Problem, dass dieses Cut war.
Da muss ich auch sagen, Leute, echt, vielleicht hört ja jemand zu.
Ihr wollt Leute warnen. Okay.
Aber wenn das immer nur so eine binäre Geschichte ist mit Ja, Warnung.
Und dann so hier Region rot eingezeichnet. Und es ist vollkommen egal, was da ist.
Es sieht immer gleich aus. Das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen,
keine Ahnung, ein bisschen mehr Drama wäre dann vielleicht ganz gut.
Naja, also ich finde es ehrlich gesagt nicht so schlimm, weil diese Warnungen
haben halt eine gewisse Ortsgenauigkeit.
Und wenn du sagst, halt der Postleitzahlenbereich von dem Ding...
Nein, das ist ja in Ordnung, dass du das auf der Karte anzeigst,
aber du könntest ja auch ein bisschen zum Ausdruck bringen, was da bedroht.
Droht da Wasser? Droht da Regen? Ist da gerade Giftgasalarm?
Ich meine, das sind doch alles solche Dinge, von denen sie da gerade machen.
Wenn da immer nur rot ist, dann stumpft das halt auch ab, wenn dich irgendwas nicht betrifft.
Und dann irgendwelche Windgeschwindigkeiten sagt mir auch nichts.
Eigentlich müsste beim nächsten Mal, wo irgendwie hier ein bisschen Sturm ist,
müsste sagen, das ist jetzt noch ein bisschen mal mehr als letzte Maxjavier,
weil da kann man sich noch dran erinnern.
Weiß mal, uh, alles klar, es wird nochmal eine Runde schlimmer,
dann kann ich das ungefähr vergleichen. Aber so, wenn da steht ja 80 kmh Wind
oder 120 kmh, dann denke ich mir, 120 kmh, da fahre ich ja mit meinem Moped
doppelt so schnell sein.
Ist ja nix. Und man kann das halt schwer einschätzen, wenn man keine Ahnung
hat. Und die haben wir ja nun eigentlich mal alle nicht, weil kommt ja nun mal nicht so oft.
Ja, also 120 kmh.
Macht doch platt. Könnt ihr euch noch erinnern, dass vor ein,
zwei Jahren gab es schon mal einen Orkan Xavier oder Xavier oder wie auch immer?
Xaver.
Ach, der hieß anders, ja?
Das ist jetzt Xavier gewesen.
Xaver Never Forget, war das der?
Ja genau, der wurde halt groß angesagt und das war halt irgendwie nichts.
Da hatten die die Fernsehkameras in Hamburg und was nicht alles genau, ja.
Ah ja, Xaver, ja. Hier ist das Image, genau.
Ich poste das im Chat.
Oh, dieser Gartenstuhl.
Ja, weil da hatten die wirklich so einen mega Alarm gemacht und Kamerateams
und was nicht alles und ja, dieses Mal war es ein bisschen anders.
Ja, vielleicht auch deswegen haben die Leute das unterschätzt,
ne? Weil, ja, da war ja auch schon nichts, was soll diesmal schon sein?
Heißt ja fast genau.
Ne, aber was ich halt auch sehr spannend fand in dem Zusammenhang war,
ähm, dass da halt der Ebay-Standort da unten in Dreilinden, da sind halt ungefähr tausend Leute.
Und die kommen natürlich nicht alle mit dem Auto. Viele kommen mit dem Auto,
aber eben nicht alle. Und, äh,
Es gibt Leute, die fahren da tatsächlich jeden Tag mit Car2Go oder Drive,
Car2Go nicht mehr, aber DriveNow hin.
Und genau an dem Punkt merkst du dann halt, wie so dieses Carsharing nicht mehr funktioniert.
Wenn plötzlich alle aus dieser Situation heraus ein Carsharing-Auto haben wollen,
dann dauert es halt genau drei Minuten, dann sind alle weg.
Taxi ist genauso. so.
Und irgendwie, das fand ich, das, ja, das ist halt dann wieder so ein Gegenargument
zu diesem, wir machen alle nur noch Carsharing.
Warum gibt es jetzt keinen Car2Go mehr?
Weil Car2Go ihr Geschäftsgebiet verkleinert hat und Drei Linden nicht mehr drin ist.
Das mit den Taxis war auch sehr lustig.
Und warum das so ist, musst du die fragen.
Ach so, mit den Taxis?
Als wir dann in Kassel gestrandet sind, hatten wir noch so eine kleine Hoffnung
von, es bringt uns ein Taxi nach Berlin.
Irgendwann hatten wir auch endlich einen Gutschein dafür.
Waren keine Taxis da?
Nee, wollte keiner nach Berlin fahren. Es gab einige, die dann halt natürlich
auch am Ende der Schicht waren und dann nicht nach Berlin gefahren sind, irgendwie klar.
Aber es gab halt auch keine Taxis halt mehr und dafür gab es dann irgendwelche
komischen Leute, die dann angeboten haben, also sich als Fahrer angeboten haben.
So shady Überfahrer.
Ja genau und das war dann auch sehr interessant zu beobachten.
Annot und Nachfrage und so. Bei den Preisen dann. Wir hatten Taxifahrer auch,
an dem Tag bin ich auch Taxi gefahren.
Hatte zum Glück, dass gerade der sozusagen mit einem Gast vor meinen Füßen sozusagen
angehalten hat und der ist raus und ich bin gleich rein, sonst hätte ich auch
keins bekommen. Das war sozusagen Glück.
Und der meint, es gibt auch deswegen in Berlin keine Taxis, weil ganz viele
sind unterwegs in Richtung Hamburg und so weiter, weil die eben für diese Bahngutscheine da fahren.
Und der Preis wäre 1,7 Euro pro Kilometer. Und, äh,
Den Rückweg zahlen die nicht, das ist dann so mit drin, meint er.
Also es sind irgendwie Hamburg so, sagen wir mal 300 Kilometer,
irgendwie mal 1,7 macht 510 Euro und dann fährt er da nach Hamburg und zurück für 510 Euro.
Für die Stunden, die er da im Auto sitzt.
Genau, er meint manche machen das, weil die denken sich, ja sie haben dann halt
auch die ganze Zeit ihre Ruhr und müssen nichts machen und so weiter,
aber Leute, die halt so ein bisschen aktiv fahren und einen Kunden nach dem
anderen haben und die so das drauf haben, so die Profi-Taxifahrer,
die mögen das nicht, weil da verdient es halt nichts.
Was ich mich gefragt habe, ist, die Deutsche Bahn hat ja auch so ein Busunternehmen.
Flixbus? Nee, das war das andere.
Nee, Flixbus ist das andere. Bahnbus, Postbus, wie auch immer.
Haben die sich da irgendwas mit wem zusammengedingst?
Weiß ich nicht.
Da hat sich doch schon ultra konsolidiert, der Markt. Da ist doch gar nichts mehr übrig.
Ja, Flixbus hat sich mit einem anderen.
Mit meinem Fernbus.
Mit meinem Fernbus. Das ist jetzt mein Flixbus oder wie auch immer sie heißen.
Flixbus heißen die, glaube ich. Also mit denen sind wir dann auch zurückgefahren,
weil anders ist man ja nicht weggekommen.
Aber dass die halt da irgendwie nicht ...
Haben die dann auch Hotelpreise?
Aber mal ehrlich.
Nee, ich habe super günstig für zwei Personen die Fahrt von Kassel nach Berlin
für 36 Euro bekommen. Also da dachte ich dann so, okay, nochmal Glück gehabt.
Aber das an so einem Sturm, wenn wirklich alles zusammenbricht und die ganze Normalität, das ist ja,
also das ganze öffentliche Leben, die Bahn, die Taxis, die Busse haben sich
ja auch eingependelt auf so eine gewisse Menge, die halt gebraucht wird,
weil du hast natürlich nicht mehr Busse, weil die stehen rum,
also das passt ja alles genauso,
wie es gebraucht wird und natürlich ist dann, wenn so ein Tag mit so einem Strom
kommt, wo alles ein bisschen schief geht,
dann geht halt nun mal alles drunter und drüber und dann ist das halt nun mal so.
Also eigentlich würde ich schon sagen, dass das alles so scheiße und schlimm
ist, das würde ich einsehen, aber du hast schon recht, wenn die Bahn halt nicht
mal sagen kann, Jungs, hier, da fährt nichts, da ist nichts und so weiter,
das könnte ein bisschen besser gehen, die Kapazitäten sollten schon noch da
sein, dass die Information ordentlich rüberkommt.
Ich meine, es muss ja auch nicht am selben Tag dann irgendwie eine Lösung da
sein, aber am nächsten Tag wäre irgendwie nett gewesen.
Ja.
Also die haben halt auch am nächsten Tag noch Leute nach Fulda oder so geschickt
mit dem Hinweis, ja, dort fahren auf jeden Fall dann Züge.
Und dann später stellte sich halt auch aus, auch da fuhr nichts.
Also es war ein bisschen… Hat auch ein.
Paar Tage gedauert, bis das alles abgebaut war, oder? Da waren ja noch über
das ganze Wochenende irgendwie Probleme beim… Naja.
Wenn es die Oberleitung erstmal runtergerissen hat… Stimmt.
Das kommt ja auch noch dazu, sind eben nicht nur Bäume, die auf der Strecke liegen.
Sondern… Gut, diese ganze Diskussion, wie viel Abstandsfläche zum Gleis hatte
man früher, wie viel hat man jetzt, keine Ahnung, da gibt es so unglaublich viele Meinungen zu,
da habe ich alles schon gelesen von, das war früher genauso wie,
das war früher ganz, ganz anders, keine Ahnung, da habe ich keine robusten Informationen
zu, wäre mal schön, wenn es die irgendwo gäbe.
aber halt so einfach gefühlt hat es das irgendwie vor, also in den 80ern oder
so nicht gegeben und es war nicht so In 80ern hast du.
Aber auch andere Geschwindigkeiten gefahren.
Ja, aber du hattest, die Elektrifizierung war aber vergleichbar hoch und auch
in den 80ern, wenn es da die Oberleitung runter reißt, fährt nichts mehr Die Elektrifizierung.
War vergleichbar hoch?
Ja
Wir haben ja in den 80ern ja schon über die Engländer gelacht,
dass die jetzt ihre erste elektrifizierte Strecke von London nach Birmingham gebaut haben.
Also das war ja, wo Deutschland doch eine sehr hohe Elektrifizierungsrate,
also zumindest auf den Fernstrecken, alle diese Sachen, also Hamburg,
Berlin war elektrifiziert.
Fahrkarten!
Das hat nichts mit Elektrifizierung zu tun.
Nein, aber diese Vorstellung, diese romantische Vorschau, dass früher bei der Bahn alles okay war.
Nein, das habe ich ja nicht gesagt.
Das ist einfach so falsch.
Die Bahn war früher langsamer.
Die unfreundlicher.
Die Anschlüsse waren in der Regel mit längeren Wartezeiten.
Die Fahrten waren auch mit längeren Wartezeiten verbunden.
Ja, aber die haben auch wenigstens mal einen Bahnhof gehalten, wo man hin wollte.
Die waren gemütlicher unterwegs, dafür konnte man das Fenster aufmachen,
man konnte das eine gegen das andere jetzt ausspielen.
Wie ich schon sagte, du redest dir das schön.
Ein paar Sachen waren toll damals. Die waren nur, wo die angefahren wurden.
Das war ein ganz anderes Reisen. Natürlich, klar hast du zehn Stunden von Berlin
nach München gebraucht, wo es jetzt nur noch fünfeinhalb sind. Ja.
Nein, ich rede mir das nicht schön.
Doch, du redest dir das total schön.
Nein.
Ach, das war eine Katastrophe damals mit der Bahn zu fahren.
Da bist du noch Tage unterwegs gewesen, bis du da irgendwann mal irgendwo gelandet bist.
Ja, wenn du nach Griechenland gefahren bist.
Das ist mir ja auch passiert.
Auf dem Rückweg ist dann die Lok kaputt gegangen.
Bitte dich.
Da habe ich zwei Nächte im gleichen Zug geschlafen. Das ist mir nur einmal passiert.
Eltern sehen.
Was warten wir jetzt an Thema nochmal?
Um vielleicht mal auch mal was Gutes zu sagen über die Bahn.
Ich finde viele Entwicklungen, die die Bahn so eingeleitet hat in den letzten
20 Jahren, finde ich ehrlich gesagt ganz gut. Ich bin auch voller...
Weil du eine Steckdose am sitzt.
Zum Beispiel. Das hat alles irgendwie gedauert und so, aber es kommt auch...
Und 600 Megabyte Netz.
pro Tag.
200.
200? Nicht 600?
Wobei ich komischerweise dieses Limit noch nicht erreicht habe,
aber es liegt eher daran, dass das irgendwie so runtergedrosselt wirkt,
dass man sich auch nicht so richtig anschauen kann.
Also es gibt in der Wikipedia die Chronik der Elektrifizierung der Eisenbahnstrecken
in Deutschland, falls jemand mal,
genauer nachlesen wollte.
Aber nur bis 45?
Nee, nee, das geht ja hier weiter.
Achso, seit 94. Aber dazwischen ist irgendwie...
Wurde nichts elektrifiziert vielleicht.
49 bis 38, also das ist DDR.
Im Gebiet der DDR.
Und hier von 49 bis 93 in Westdeutschland.
Alles da. Auf der deutschen Bündnisbahn.
Alles da. Chronik der Elektrifizierung. Kannst du jetzt nochmal genau nachschauen,
wie das so war mit den Dampfloks und den E-Loks.
Ich habe noch Dampfloks gesehen.
Beziehungsweise nicht Dampfloks D-Züge.
Dampfloks habe ich auch noch gesehen im produktiven Einsatz,
allerdings nur in der damaligen DDR. nicht in Westdeutschland.
Ich habe auch noch eine im Westen gesehen.
Ja, vielleicht so Museumsbahnen, aber keine echt, im echten produktiven Einsatz.
Nee, es war so irgendwas mit die letzte Fahrt und so.
Die letzte Fahrt.
Das habe ich noch irgendwie mitbekommen am Rande. Ansonsten viel Diesel,
viel Viel Diesel, viel R? Viel Diesel.
Ja, sag das mal. Sag das mal VW. Viel Diesel, viel R.
Und lange, lange Fahrten. Lange, lange, lange, lange, lange, lange, lange Fahrten.
Ja, man ist da mit einer ganz anderen Ding Müdlichkeit rangegangen.
Genau.
Probier's mal mit dem Trummel. Gut.
Thema Bahn abgehakt.
Abgehakt.
Abgehakt, genau.
Erzähl doch mal was Schönes, Roddy, über Bier.
Über Bier? Sehr gut, dass du das sagst.
Ich habe ich habe jetzt seit das erste Mal selber ein Bierrezept kreiert.
Oh, oh, oh, genau.
Oh, oh, aber irgendwie das Jungbier, also sprich das, was man mal so probieren
kann, nachdem es gegärt hat,
bevor es dann in die Flasche kommt, das war eigentlich schon ganz ordentlich,
also es war vor allen Dingen auch ordentlich auf die Geschmacksknospel, aber ja,
und zwar, weil das letzte Mal, das letzte Mal, als ich hier war und Letty war
auch da, hat sie da mein Rezept gesehen und sah,
das Wort Chocolate Malt oder Chocolate Malz und da dachte ich,
da bringe ich doch jetzt mal was mit.
Ich habe hier zwei Tütchen, da ist einmal Farbmalz drin, was eher so kaffeemäßig
riecht und auch so ein bisschen so schmeckt und dann gibt es einmal das Chocolate Malt,
was eher nicht so nach Schokolade riecht, aber ein bisschen so schmeckt.
Also könnt ihr probieren, wenn ihr wollt.
Und was ist dann damit?
Wie, was ist dann damit? Dann kannst du dann sagen, wie es riecht und schmeckt.
Also man kann das essen.
Also davon ist von beidem in dem Bier, das ist ein Stout.
Ja.
Ein schönes dunkles schwarzes Stout.
Mit cremigem Schaum.
Hoffentlich, wir werden es dann sehen. Also um den Schaum cremig zu machen,
tut man üblicherweise noch unvermelztes Getreide dazu.
Ich habe also irgendwie ein halbes Kilo Haferflocken irgendwie im Rezept, also im Rezept,
ja in dem einen Rezept, was ich gefunden habe, da sprachen die von 40 Minuten,
das habe ich nicht geschafft, weil es relativ schnell angebrannt ist,
also irgendwie Haferflocken in Wasser kochen ist gar nicht so einfach.
Ja, was war ich? Hier gibt es noch das Rezept.
Ich habe das vor der Sendung noch ganz schnell irgendwie, habe ich das Ding
nach Markdown verfasst, genau,
und in ein Git-Repository zu GitHub hochgeladen, damit man dann da auch mal
Änderungen machen kann, wenn man der Meinung ist, die zweite Variante muss irgendwie anders sein.
Ich packe das mal in den Schätzleck.
Ja, genau. Jetzt habt ihr alle mal das Malz probiert. Und? Lecker, sagst du?
Das Schokomalz ist auf jeden Fall leckerer als das Kaffee. Also das Färbermalz
finde ich jetzt ein bisschen herb.
Ja, ja. Aber das Interessante ist, die beiden, die sehen total gleich aus und
schmecken und riechen total anders. Ich weiß nicht, wie die das machen.
Also riechen fand ich, die haben jetzt beide nach Plastikbeutel gerochen.
Ja, außer dem Plastikbeutelgeruch natürlich. Aber ja, sie schmecken unterschiedlich.
Also ich fand dieses Schokoladenmalz, das kann man ja so nebenbei knabbern gefühlt.
Ja, Malz kann man sowieso nebenbei knabbern. Also das ganz normale Malz ist total lecker.
Ich habe den Irrsinn begangen und habe gedacht, ach so, naja,
bei den Preisen, wenn du den ganzen 25 Kilo Sack kaufst, dann ist es ja viel günstiger.
Dann kriegst du es ja für fast einen Euro irgendwie pro Kilo.
getan gemacht, da stand dann dieser 25 Kilo Sack in der Firma und ich so das
war jetzt irgendwie eine dumme Idee 25 Kilo ist ganz schön viel.
25 Kilo halt, ne?
Ja, 25 Kilo, ja gut, aber ich meine, man macht sich ja keine Vorstellungen.
Bis man dann den Sack dastehen hat und sich dann denkt, oh.
Wo soll ich den eigentlich hinstellen?
Ja, vor allen Dingen ist das ja so fluffiges Material, also einer meiner Gitarrenverstärker
wiegt auch 25 Kilo, aber das ist hochkomprimiertes.
Mit einem ordentlichen Griff dran.
Ja, und da ist so, das schwerste wahrscheinlich die Magneten und Transformer
und so, und da hast du halt so, ja.
So ein Sack ist halt wie so ein knutschiges Kissen. Ja, aber ich habe ihn dann
doch irgendwie nach Hause gekriegt.
In der S-Bahn?
Nee, da habe ich dann tatsächlich zu einem Carsharing-Auto gegriffen.
Was den Preisvorteil dann natürlich total zunichte gemacht hat.
Hätte man sich auch vorher überlegen können. aber sei es drum.
Apropos Kilos und Gewicht, wisst ihr eigentlich diese Goldbarren,
die man in den Filmen sieht, die dir da immer so ganz easy durch die Gegend
tragen, wisst ihr eigentlich, wie schwer ein so ein Ding ist?
Schwer.
Ja, aber wie schwer?
Genau, weiß ich es nicht.
Also ist das so ein Kilo Goldbarren?
Weiß nicht genau welchen.
Zwei Kilo Goldbarren?
Also ich hatte mal einen in der Hand.
Der hatte glaube ich 5 Kilo. Also diese Standarddinger, die die da so haben.
4 oder 10.
Bonn-Film oder wo auch immer.
Ich hatte von Pavel ja mal seine kleine Mini-Sammlung da in der Hand und das
war schon relativ massiv bei kleiner Größe.
Ja.
Tja, so 5 bis 10 Kilo kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Also die internationale Einheit, und das sollte ja wohl sein in diesen Filmen,
wenn man diese größeren Dinger da sieht, sind 400 Unzen, das sind 12,5 Kilo.
Das heißt, wenn da in dem Bonn-Film die da sich da 10 Stücke in ihren Koffer packen.
No way.
Da ist der Griff ab.
Oder wenn du siehst, das sind so Dinge, die in die Jackentasche stecken oder
so, der würde gleich durchrutschen, die Naht auf Reißel unten wieder rausfallen.
Also 400 Unzen.
Apropos schwere Elemente, ich war diese Woche, ja also ich habe gerade eine
neue Folge für Raumzeit aufgenommen die wird auch relativ bald erscheinen und
da geht es unter anderem um schwere Elemente,
richtig schwer.
Und ich nehme mal ein schwerere als Gold? Nicht unbedingt Plutonium oder so?
Nö, es geht mehr so um all das, wo Gold so herkommt.
Achso alles was schwerer ist als Eisen ist doch irgendwie, oder?
Alles was schwerer ist als Eisen ist nicht so ohne weiteres herzustellen.
So, dann bedarf es halt einer Supernova.
Einer handelsüblichen.
Ja, genau. Da muss man sich mal klar machen. Jedes Stück Gold gibt es halt nur,
weil Sterne explodiert sind. Früher mal.
Ja, weil Weil aus der Kernfusion kommt nur Energie raus bis Eisen.
Und danach musst du Energie reinstecken, damit du schwerer wirst.
Genau, und die kommt sozusagen nur durch diese Explosion.
Und dann hast du das.
Und durch den Druck oder wie.
Genau, und da war ich an der Uni Mainz beim Institut für Kernphysik und konnte
mir auch das erste Mal so einen Kern, so einen Teilchenbeschleuniger anschauen.
Die haben da nämlich einen.
So ein Synchrotron oder was?
Nee, das ist so ein einfaches Ding. Also die schießen da einfach nur so Elektronen
aus so einem längeren Rohr.
Aber ist trotzdem schon ganz beeindruckend. Also es war so ein größerer Raum,
ist schon fast ein bisschen untertrieben. Also das war so eine Halle.
die war vor allem sehr hoch, so 3, 4, 5 Etagen und dann kam so von der einen
Seite so ein Rohr irgendwie so 10 Meter lang, da ist halt quasi so eine,
Elektronenstrahlröhre wie beim Fernseher halt.
So ein Linearbeschleuniger.
Genau, die schießen da einfach so ein Ding rein und in der Mitte trifft das
dann halt irgendwie auf und dann haben sie da so drumherum so Monstranzen von
so Magnetablenkern wo dann halt die ganze Detektor-Geschichte drin ist und das,
ja war einerseits ganz interessant andererseits eine Gelegenheit meine nächste
Raumzeitfolge zu plangen,
und ich weiß gar nicht, ob es noch einen anderen Aspekt gab,
den ich noch anbringen wollte oder ob ich eigentlich nur, ich wollte sozusagen
nur mein Erlebnis noch ein bisschen, ich habe nämlich gerade mal so ein bisschen
geblättert, was ich in den letzten zwei Wochen so getan habe,
weil ich die ganze Zeit irgendwie so ein bisschen themenarm bin,
und das war auf jeden Fall,
eins meiner Themen.
Eine Sache zum Thema Gold, die mich auch sehr fasziniert dass ich mich mal damit
beschäftigt habe, war die Tatsache,
dass alles Gold, was jemals gefördert wurde, wenn man das in einen Würfel packen würde.
Ich weiß es.
Weißt du schon, hat man schon mal hin, ne?
Nee, aber habe ich auch gelesen.
Was die Kantenlänge dann von diesem Würfel wäre, wenn man alles...
Alles Gold der Welt.
Nee, was jemals gefördert wurde. Also nicht das, was noch in der Erde ist,
sondern nur das, was seit Anbeginn der Zeit sozusagen aus der Erde geholt wurde.
Bekanntermaßen.
Ja, nicht so wirklich riesig, ne?
100 Meter?
40 mal 40 mal 40 Meter.
Ich habe gelesen, dass es in ein Olympia-Schwimmbecken passen würde,
also mit Olympia-Lizenz oder wie auch immer Maßen.
Also 40 Kubikmeter. Ja.
Was nicht daran liegt, dass es nicht mehr gibt, sondern es gibt ja genug Gold auf der Erde.
Es wird ja halt auch künstlich quasi verknappt, um den Preis stabil zu halten,
aber fand ich auch ganz interessant.
40 Meter ja mal ausrechnen, wie viele Kilo oder Tonnen das sind und dann kommt
was ja auch in der Riesenmonsterzahl raus.
Jetzt kannst du in Wolfram Alpha so solche Sachen prima machen.
Die Dichte von 21 irgendwo in dem Dreh reicht ja plus minus und dann kann man das ausrechnen.
Spannend fand ich ja, dass es ein Metall gibt, was genau die gleiche Dichte
wie Gold hat, Niob oder so, ist das das?
Weiß ich nicht.
Und dass es wohl in China da so Buden gibt, die sich drauf spezialisiert haben,
Goldbahnen zu fälschen.
Ja, aber es gibt auch Geräte, die sich spezialisiert haben, das rauszufinden.
Die machen dann da Ultraschall drauf oder zwei so nur.
Ja, aber erst seit kürzerer Zeit und es ist wohl so, dass in relativ vielen
so Goldlagern und dass die gar nicht so genau nachgucken, was ist eigentlich in den Goldbahnen drin.
Das ganze Fort Knox ist alles geschummelt.
Das können sich als geschummelt herausstellen.
Niemand kann ja reingucken.
Dann mal jetzt schon mal bei Gold sind. Okay, habe ich ja jetzt selber aufgebracht,
das Thema, aber es passt trotzdem gerade, weil da könnten wir wieder über Bitcoin reden.
Woher wusste ich das nur?
Das ist aber jetzt super.
Erstens gibt es da irgendwie, ich sage das jetzt einfach mal so,
die können mich ja gerne verklagen, gibt es da so ein paar Spinner,
die demnächst was rausbringen, was Bitcoin Gold heißt.
Also die wollen irgendwie forken, wollen auch den Algorithmus ändern,
dass man auch keine ASICs mehr nehmen kann, sondern wieder mit Grafikkarten
und weiß nicht was alles.
Aber die werden eigentlich von allen Seiten vorn und hinten auseinandergenommen.
Also das irgendwie Scam, um schnell mal irgendwie fett Geld zu verdienen.
Ich glaube, da braucht man nichts drauf geben und sich nicht drum kümmern.
Das ist Bitcoin Gold. Also lasst einfach die Finger davon. Vor allem,
wenn man keine Ahnung hat, dann grundsätzlich nicht anfassen.
Dann aber so im späteren November gibt es mal wieder einen angekündigten Hardfork von Bitcoin.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt schon 10 Bitcoins hat, wird man dann höchstwahrscheinlich
Ende November, so 2024 oder irgendwo ist das, wird man dann auch 10 Bitcoin mit Segwit2x haben.
Und das ist sozusagen exakt der gleiche Code, weil Bitcoin hat jetzt auch schon
diese Segregated Witness, was Segregate abgekürzt heißt, bloß,
dass die dort wieder doppelt so große Blöcke machen und dann folgt sich das Ganze.
So und das kann sich aber, man kann diese Coins nur doppelt haben,
wenn man seinen Key dafür selber verwaltet.
Also das heißt, man sollte seine Coins nicht bei irgendeinem Exchange liegen
haben, weil da muss man sich mit denen rumärgern, ob man jetzt auch seine Coins
in dieser geforgten Währung kriegt oder nicht.
Deswegen, man sollte das immer bei sich selber verwalten, dann kann man das später besser managen.
Und die zweite Sache ist, wenn man aber jetzt zum Beispiel seine Coins,
auch so wie ich zum Beispiel, auf dem iPhone hat, dort habe ich die in Bread Wallet.
Bread Wallet ist ja ein sogenannter SPV-Client, das heißt Simple Payment Verification.
Das heißt, der hat nicht die ganze Blockchain auf dem Telefon,
sondern der macht nur so Connections zu Bitcoin-Nodes, fragt die,
ob diese Transaktion okay ist oder wie viel Geld da drauf liegt,
holt sich die Informationen und arbeitet dann damit.
Das kann natürlich sein, dass der dann, wenn das geforkt ist,
zu dem falschen Node irgendwie connectet, dass dann irgendwie so ein Segway
to Access und nicht mehr das normale Bitcoin und dann die falschen Informationen kriegt.
Und damit das nicht passiert, kann man sich die Node fest eintragen.
Und ich habe ja ein Bitcoin-Node laufen. Und das heißt, ihr könnt jetzt bei
eurem Bread-Wallet oder auch hier von dem Andreas Schildbach,
die Android-Wallet, könnt ihr meine Node eintragen.
Wenn ihr mir dann vertraut, müsst ihr das selber wissen. Aber das ist dann rr.btcmp.com.
Dort läuft Bitcoin Note, der ist offen. Da könnt ihr euch hinkonnecten und könnt
eurem Brad Wallet sagen, hier, wenn der da die Transaktion checkt,
dann soll der das dort machen.
Dann könnt ihr garantiert sein, dass ich dort kein Segwit2x laufen habe,
sondern den Originalen von den Bitcoin Core Developern und dann, dass da alles gut geht.
Ja, wollte ich mal gesagt haben. Aber wahrscheinlich machen wir das an der nächsten
Sendung noch ein bisschen genauer oder an der übernächsten, jedenfalls kurz
bevor dieses Ereignis dann stattfindet.
Weil dann kann man vielleicht nochmal Tipps geben, was man machen muss,
damit man, wenn sich das trennt, dass man seine Coins auch doppelt hat und zur
Not da irgendwie doppelt abkassiert und die Hälfte, die man nicht meint,
die überlebt, dass man die gleich verkauft.
Oder man behält beide und macht nichts, je nachdem, wie man will.
Ja, soviel dazu.
Okay. 1,24 Teragramm.
So viel wiegt dein Gold. 40x40 Meter.
Teragramm.
Teragramm, schöne Einheit.
Also 1,4 Gigakilo. Also 1,4 Megatonnen.
1,24, ja. Kann ich mir auch nichts darunter vorstellen, aber ist so wie eine
Menge. Verdammt schwer.
Naja, okay.
Dann habe ich mir noch zwei Geräte gekauft diese Woche, nachdem ich erstmal
festgestellt habe, das ist mein letzter Kauf.
Stimmt, ich habe gar nichts gekauft.
Nach hinten. Ich habe mir diesen alten iMac gekauft, in der wirrigen Annahme.
Das wäre ein Gerät, was noch das für mich leisten könnte, was ich hier brauche.
hat sich natürlich herausgestellt, war alles Humbug. Ich habe mir natürlich
einen iMac gekauft, der schon Thunderbolt hatte, womit ich ihn halt auch nicht
als Mini-Display verwenden kann, also als externes Display, wie ich das hier
mit meinem iMac mache. Ist aber nicht so schlimm.
Es war eh ein Privattausch mit einem alten Mac gedacht und das ist halt jetzt der.
Passt auch, performt zumindest ordentlich. Das war so ein bisschen daneben.
Dann habe ich irgendwie noch eine, wenn auch nicht sonderlich,
kreative Lösung für Fernseher kaufen gefunden. Ich habe mir dann halt mal einen Fernseher gekauft.
Wow, du Rebell.
Ich bin mal so richtig so Revoluzzer.
Ja, ich bin wirklich der Jane Steen des Media Marks.
Und naja, ich habe dann so Zeit verbracht in so einem Markt.
Ich sag den Namen nicht, egal.
Du hast jetzt nicht online dich erkundigt, sondern im Markt.
Doch auch, aber ich hab halt irgendwie festgestellt, am Ende...
Muss man aber das Bild sehen.
Muss man einerseits das Bild sehen, aber was mich noch sehr viel mehr interessiert
hat, ist halt einfach, funktioniert die Scheiße eigentlich auch so User-Interface-mäßig
oder würde mich das halt irgendwie total nerven?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, und dann engere Wahl war dann irgendwie Sony, Panasonic,
Samsung und theoretisch noch LG.
Ja, was sonst.
Und dann war ich aber mit meinen Bluetooth-Kopfhörern vor Ort und fand halt heraus… Da sind.
Schon alle da dran gescheitert.
Ja nahezu, alle bis auf Samsung. Sodass es am Ende dann auch auf Samsung rausgeht,
weil mir dann auf einmal auffiel, dass das wirklich ein Feature ist,
was ich bei deinem Fernseher schon immer vermisst habe,
dass man da einfach mal auf geile Soundanlage und was weiß ich, dann nervst du alle.
In der Nacht willst du mal irgendwie was kriegen.
Man hat ja geile Bluetooth-Kopfhörer eigentlich.
Man hat ja geile Bluetooth-Kopfhörer, warum funktioniert das nicht einfach damit?
Und mit Samsung ging das halt irgendwie so fort.
Ja, aber danach würde ich mir meinen Fernseher nicht aussuchen,
weil zur Not hängt man sich dann für 10 Euro da irgendwie so einen Bluetooth-Adapter
ran und fertig. Weil Ausgang haben sie ja alle.
Wie ich ihn auch habe.
Ja, und wie paierst du dann irgendwie den mit verschiedenen...
Ob du das mit dem Fernseher machst oder mit dem Adapter, ist doch noch egal.
Ja, aber dann wann...
Also ich sehe schon ein, dass das schicker ist, wenn der Fernseher das kann.
Aber ich nehme kein Shit.
Die Fernseher...
Ja, aber wann sendet der Fernseher dann halt da drauf auf das Signal,
du musst das dann immer rein stöpseln, egal,
kann man irgendwie sicherlich auch alles irgendwie machen, aber das war dann
so für mich so ein Moment mit, das ist etwas, was funktionieren muss,
so das war einfach so ein bisschen mein Anspruch und Sony irgendwie,
ja, can't connect so, weißt du schon, so dieses,
äh, das ist mir gut, ich bin jetzt hier bin hier nicht zu Hause so,
aber der andere hat es ja auch hinbekommen,
so fünfmal probiert, nicht funktioniert und dann die anderen haben es halt teilweise
gar nicht diese Funktionalitäten, dachte ich mir auch so, okay, alles klar.
Also so richtig besonders überzeugt bin ich davon jetzt irgendwie nicht,
dass das ein grandioser Kauf ist, aber es ist schon bemerkenswert,
dass man jetzt so relativ brauchbare
4K-Ware im Plastikformat doch für ein paar hundert Euro bekommt.
Das ist dann am Ende halt so mehr oder weniger das günstigste Modell dieser
aktuellen 4K-Generation geworden.
Und ist das jetzt ein Smart-TV oder ein Dump-TV?
Ja, nee, das sind halt alles dann auch so Smart-TVs und das ist sicherlich,
naja gut, ich meine, immerhin merkt man dann daran, dass Apple dann doch noch
so seine Probleme haben wird mit diesem Markt,
weil wenn du dir halt heute für 600 Euro also dem dreifachen Preis eines Apple
TV dir quasi so einen Fernseher da hinstellst und der kommt halt so serienmäßig
schon so mit den großen Diensten als App daher.
Was geht eigentlich?
Ja, so Netflix, Mediathek etc. alles eingebaut, Teilweise Sachen,
die halt bei Apple TV vor kurzem noch gar nicht da waren.
Amazon, Prime, der ganze Klimbim. Nicht, dass ich da jetzt besonders drauf stehen
würde, aber es ist halt einfach da.
Überhaupt alles irgendwie extrem internetmäßig ausgelegt. Für meinen Geschmack
auch ehrlich gesagt schon ein bisschen zu viel.
Naja, dann halt so mit so passablen Sound und passablen Bild und geht schon irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht so richtig, ob da...
Ja, mir ist auch unklar, warum eine Apple TV immer noch keine Bildröhre eingebaut hat.
Also ein Display. Es ist irgendwie, weil das, damit würden sie den Markt auf jeden Fall aufmachen.
Weiß ich nicht, glaube ich nicht.
Wenn das Ding richtig gepreist ist schon.
Ja, das könnten sie auch jetzt schon machen.
Wenn sie dafür anderthalb K verlangen, natürlich nicht.
Naja, du kennst ja Apple.
Ja, natürlich kenne ich Apple.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist das so ein brauchbares Einsteigermodell im 49-Zoll-Bereich.
Ist nämlich ein bisschen klein.
Für den Ort, wo der steht und für die Bedeutung, die der am Ende hat.
Küche.
Ist das... Nee, das ist egal, aber größer wäre Pointless gewesen.
Aber es ist schon eher die kleinere Größe da so im Supermarkt oder wo du warst,
im Saturn 49 Zoll, oder? die Standardgröße jetzt hier so 55, 60 oder so?
Ja, interessanterweise also die ganze High-End-Geschichte geht tatsächlich erst
bei 55 los also wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt,
so Geld spielt keine Rolex mäßig unterwegs bist, dann willst du natürlich so
ein OLED Fernseher haben, weil irgendwie schwarz,
Kontrast, pipapo die gehen ja dann erst bei 2000 irgendwas los,
aber du kriegst die halt auch nie unter 55 Zoll.
Also das ist sozusagen die Größe, ab der überhaupt etwas losgeht.
Und diese 49, 50 Zoll, das ist da sozusagen das Ende des Midrange.
Also du hast natürlich auch Midrange in größer, aber der Midrange steckt halt
diesen Bereich als einzige ab.
Ich gucke auch schon seit immer mal wieder so ein bisschen im Supermarkt im Saturn,
nicht Supermarkt, bei diesen TV's, aber es sind irgendwie so viele und ich weiß
auch gar nicht, auf was meine Acht müssten ich bin jedes Mal frustriert dass
ich mich auch irgendwie gar nicht auskenne und es ist mir auch viel zu komplex,
mich da einzuarbeiten und bin jedes Mal dann so, naja ich mach das nächstes Jahr,
und das bestimmt schon seit 3-4 Jahren aber immerhin.
Man kriegt jetzt so 4K-Bildschirme die ordentliches ordentliche Auflösung,
ein brauchbares Bild haben. Ich habe jetzt noch keinen Rechner angeschlossen.
Das wäre aber der erste Test. Alles andere ist mir eigentlich schnupp.
Ja, aber ich habe halt noch keinen Rechner, der HDMI 2.0 hat.
Der kann das ja wohl hier, der Scheißer, oder?
Ja, deiner. Aber ich habe ja nur, mein neuestes Gerät ist von 2013.
Ja. Holst du einfach so ein Amazon Fire-TV und hängst dir da rein. 20 Euro oder 30 Euro.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Das ist ja kein Computer.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich will da schon mal mit dem Mac testen.
Was hast du überhaupt vor mit dem Fernsehen? Willst du Filme gucken mit irgendwie
Fire TV, Google, was auch immer oder Apple, sonst wie?
Oder willst du deinen Rechner da ranhängen und den wirklich auch für deinen GUI benutzen?
Nein, das ist...
Oder hast du Kabel dran?
Oder ja.
Das ist ja im Wohnungsbereich. Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie...
Also dann würde der hier stehen in der Mitte eben.
Ja, das ist ja mal cool. In der Größe so. Nee, ein bisschen breiter noch.
Habe ich auch geguckt, aber...
Wie viele Zoll sind das denn?
Das sind viele Zoll. Hier müsste ich dann irgendwie so ein 80 Zoll.
Das ist mal der Zollstock rausholen.
80 Zoll. Also hier bringt es wahrscheinlich mehr, mal eine Leinwand hinzuhängen,
damit der Beamer, auf den wir hier immer alle schauen, nochmal ein bisschen besser zu erkennen ist.
Was hast du gegen Graufasertapel?
Oh, so einiges. Don't get me started.
Also ihr habt euch ja noch nicht beschwert.
Nee doch, ganz am Anfang haben wir aber irgendwann...
Aber ich wollte halt nicht einen Bildschirm kaufen, der nicht auch als,
der nicht mit HDMI 2.0 kommt und so weiter und potenziell als Bildschirm zu verwenden ist,
weil auch das ist ja absehbar, dass der vielleicht irgendwann mal einer Zweitverwertung
zukommt und dann will man nicht unbedingt immer gleich was haben, was wegzuwerfen ist.
Also ich werde das jetzt erstmal beobachten, das ist jetzt alles noch neu,
keine Ahnung, aber das Ding habe ich jetzt irgendwie gekauft und jetzt werde
ich mal gucken, wie das so ist.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch alles ganz furchtbar und wir müssen den bald wieder verkaufen.
zweiten Shopping Moment hatte ich dann noch wo ich dann beschlossen habe ich brauche auch,
Man braucht halt einen Schredder, aber manchmal braucht man auch zwei.
Musst du dann nochmal nachschreddern oder was?
Ich habe ja immer so die Wohnung und die Mitte eben so als tägliche Pendelstrecke
und ich hatte ja hier immer einen Schredder und jetzt wollte ich halt auch mal
zu Hause einen Schredder haben.
Dann habe ich halt irgendwie geguckt, was will man denn jetzt haben und ehrlich gesagt,
ich habe einen Schredder, der läuft seit 15 Jahren ohne Probleme und bin mehr
oder weniger bei der Marke treu geblieben und habe mir sozusagen nur so mit Finessen,
noch weiteren kleinen Finessenverbesserungen mehr oder weniger dasselbe Teil
mit etwas mehr Kapazität gekauft und bin auch nach wie vor der Meinung,
dass ich da Gold richtig lege.
Und ich kann euch sagen, wenn ihr irgendwie nach einem Schredder sucht,
der was taucht und der hält und der funktioniert, dann ist einfach die Marke ideal, ideal.
Will it shred?
Ich stehe auf Berlin.
Ja, genau. Wobei die glaube ich nicht aus Berlin sind. Ich weiß gar nicht, woher die kommen.
Aber ich bin beeindruckt. Also das ist einfach gute Hardware.
Das sind so Teile, die ich meine,
Schredder, ja bist schon dabei,
Schredder, das ist ja so diese Kategorie Gerät das kauft man sich halt nicht
alle Tage und dann geht man mal los und dann so, ja was gebe ich denn für einen Schredder aus?
Ja, das gibt, habe ich auch vor kurzer Zeit gehabt, dieses Thema.
Genau, und dann denkt man sich so, das muss doch so ein, das muss doch so ein
Billig-Ding sein, dann kann ich halt nur vorwahren.
Ja, ich auch.
Das ist einfach sozusagen, Schredder ist definitiv das, was ihr nicht in Billig haben wollt.
Also ich habe so ein Billig-Ding, aber das pfeift auch so auf dem anderthalb
letzten Loch. Also das ist so.
Der macht es nicht mehr so lange. Also auch von den guten Marken,
von denen es ja nicht nur Ideale gibt, da gibt es noch eine andere,
deren Namen ich gerade vergessen habe, aber die haben üblicherweise auch nochmal
so ein Consumer-Modell,
aber auch selbst von den Marken.
Also ich glaube so ab 600 Euro oder so fängt das an mit den ernsthaften Schreddern, oder?
Naja, also das Modell, was ich jetzt nicht mehr gekauft habe,
der quasi der Nachfolger von dem, den ich vorher hatte, der hat mich jetzt irgendwie 400 Euro.
Ah, 400.
Leistung und Bedienkomfort am Schreibtisch. So muss es sein.
So muss gestrittert werden, ja. Ich muss da nochmal upgraden,
weil ich habe nämlich auch gedacht, ah, also ich will so eine gewisse Schnittfeinheit
haben und Crosscut und so, aber da habe ich das günstigste Modell, was das hatte, gekauft.
Du machst nicht nur Streifen, sondern der Schnitt wird dir auch nochmal,
okay, weil sonst ist das ja nichts.
Aber das trotzdem, also der Motor, also man merkt einfach dieses Ding,
das ist nicht so Also wenn du da zwei Seiten auf einmal reinsteckst,
dann ist er manchmal schon überfordert und das will man halt nicht.
Das geht gar nicht und vor allem die Dinger dürfen halt sich nicht erhitzen,
wenn du jetzt mal wirklich so einen ganzen Sack weghaust, hast du irgendwie
aussortiert, hast da mal richtig aufgeräumt, hast da so einen dicken Stapel
und denkst, jetzt hast du noch wegschreddern.
Und dann sitzt du da und musst halt irgendwie alle 30 Blatt fünf Minuten Pause
machen, damit dieses Ding sich wieder abkühlt.
Und wenn du es halt nicht machst, dann zerlegen die sich dann halt auch schnell
mal selber. Die werden dann einfach zu heiß und dann ist irgendwie alles vorbei.
Und das passiert dir halt so in dieser Kategorie nicht. Also und vor allem,
man steht ja dann immer so vor dieser Produktmatrix und denkt sich so,
ja, brauche ich jetzt irgendwie Linearschnitt oder Partikelschnitt und wie klein
soll es denn sein und welche Sicherheitsstufe brauche ich denn und so.
Also wenn Sicherheit euer Problem ist, dann schaut in eure Vorgaben für eure
Firma oder eure Branche, welche Sicherheitsstandards ihr einzuhalten habt und dann ist es das.
Wenn euer Problem im Wesentlichen ist, ihr wollt so halbwegs sensitives Material
oder Sachen, die einfach nur klein sein sollen, damit sie nicht zusammenpuzzlebar
sind von irgendeinem Dödel.
Genau, oder manchmal, ich zerschredde hier manchmal.
Und noch so ein bisschen Füllmaterial dazu.
Ja, ich zerschredde halt auch, ja genau, du kannst es einfach auch wunderbar
als Füllmaterial danach benutzen, du kannst es auch noch als Konfetti benutzen.
Das Schöne am Schredder ist vor allen Dingen, du tust das Papier rein und wenn
es durchgeschreddert ist, dann ist es wirklich weg.
Dann liegt es nicht irgendwo noch am Altpapier und dann vielleicht hole ich
es nochmal raus. Nein, es ist weg.
Es ist weg und es ist so von der Seele. Es ist weggeschreddert.
Und wenn du noch zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt geglaubt hättest, würdest du dir das
später dann nochmal anschauen, ob das jetzt wirklich wichtig war,
in dem Moment musst du dich entscheiden.
Commitment.
Genau, es ist einfach Commitment und dieser wunderbare Sound eines Spredders,
der sich durch so deine Vergangenheit durchfrisst, der ist einfach unbezahlbar.
Also meine, um es mal kurz zu Ende zu bringen, ich bin sehr glücklich mit der
Partikelgröße 4x40mm, Crosscut.
Also der schneidet nicht nur Streifen, sondern schneidet die Streifen halt auch noch ab.
4 x 40 mm.
Na, der ist 4 x 4 mm breit und ich kann dir das mal zeigen.
Das ist ja relativ grob.
Ja, ich glaube, meiner macht auch ein bisschen kleinere Schnitzel.
Ja, du kannst das halt auch anders haben. Hier, wenn ich dir das mal kurz zeigen darf, das ist 4x40.
Oh, wir dürfen Schrad gucken. Nee, viel anders sehen die bei mir auch nicht.
Bei mir ist das kleiner auf jeden Fall.
Bei mir auch. Halb so lang, halb so oder drittel so breit.
Klar, gibt es auch kleiner. Aber umso kleiner, umso weniger auf einmal können die halt fressen.
Ja, kommt auf den Motor an.
Ja, kommt auf. Also dann geht dann halt der Preis hoch. Also wenn du halt sehr
klein haben willst und so. Aber für mich reicht das.
Okay, für dein persönliches Paranoia-Level ist das gut genug.
Für mein Paranoia-Level ist das vollkommen ausreichend und vor allem ist es
halt auch so wunderschön. Du kannst halt auch, ich hau halt eigentlich auch alles da rein.
Der Trick ist, du staust die Wanne, die du da handhältst, einfach mit Wasser
füllen, Spüle hier rein und dann löst sich das auch schön mit der Zeitaufwände, dass da so reingeht.
Ja, dann hast du Packmaschee oder was.
Ja, aber das kann keiner mehr zusammensetzen. also zerlöst sich ja.
Ja, dann kannst du ja auch eine Feuerschale hinlegen.
Ja,
aber so ein bisschen Wasser und Spüli ist halt kein Problem für zu Hause und
das ist auch nicht umweltschädlich so.
Also nicht mehr als Feuer. Ich finde ja interessant hier im Amazon-Vergleich,
wie die Konkurrenzprodukte heißen.
Da gibt es einmal Shred Cat und einmal Fellows Power Shred.
Wow.
Shred Cat ist doch ein schöner Name. Auch wenn der nicht so aussieht, als wäre er gut.
Die Marke von im Club, da haben wir doch auch so einen Schredder seit eh und
je. Ist das das Gleiche? Ich glaube, es war was anderes.
Keine Ahnung.
Wie auch immer.
Kachelofen schreibt hier noch jemand.
Ja, das habe ich jetzt zu Hause.
Ja, hatte ich auch mal. Das ist auch ganz gut.
Also, nicht als Hauptheizung, aber ich habe noch einen Kachelofen in einem Zimmer
stehen, der auch noch potenziell funktioniert.
Ach, und hier macht noch jemand hier mit auf Festplatten. Das kann man natürlich
auch noch machen. Vielen Dank.
Ähm, ja.
So, und jetzt?
Also ich könnte jetzt nochmal kurz hier, aber wirklich dann hoffentlich nur,
ja doch, relativ kurz, eine Buchempfehlung abgeben, die mir der Ron eigentlich
über Twitter hat zukommen lassen.
Ihr wisst schon, Security Nightmares vom Kongress und so, der Ron.
Und zwar habe ich mich irgendwie in meinem,
also der Anlass war, dass ich im gegenwärtigen Projekt, in dem ich so arbeite,
das Gefühl habe, dass da alles falsch läuft, was man so falsch machen kann und
habe mich da auf Twitter zu einem frustrierten Tweet hinreißen lassen.
Genau, und dann hat der Ron irgendwie dieses Buch erwähnt, was wohl auch ein
Klassiker des Projektmanagements ist.
Was war denn der Inhalt deines Twits?
Ja, einfach so Gesamtsituation, Table Flip.
Linken, kannst du den Tweet verlinken.
Ja, ich guck mal.
Gesamtsituation, Table Flip.
Ja, naja, wie das halt so ist, wenn alles im Argen ist.
Und genau, dann hat er mir dieses Buch empfohlen, was wohl auch ein Projektmanagement-Klassiker ist.
Der ist, glaube ich, die Ersterscheinung oder die Erstausgabe war 1978.
1978 und wurde seitdem so etwa alle zehn Jahre nochmal neu aufgelegt mit aktuellen Erkenntnissen.
Das Buch heißt Peopleware mit dem Subtitel Peopleware, lass mal nochmal kurz
gucken, Peopleware, ich gucke gerade nach dem Link.
Productive Projects and Teams. Klingt jetzt erstmal sehr bedeutungsschwanger
und ich kann euch sagen, ich habe eine relativ große Allergie gegen solche Besserwisser Bücher.
Besserwisser Bücher, aber ich habe das dann doch mal geklickt und,
achso, du hast es auch, okay,
habe das angefangen zu lesen und es ist wirklich akkurat alles,
was in diesem gegenwärtigen Projekt schiefläuft, so zusammengefasst und sehr...
Also ohne große Wiederholungen, ganz viele von diesen Büchern,
gerade so aus dem amerikanischen Sprachraum, die haben dann auch,
leben auch von so ganz vielen Wiederholungen, die Message so 23 Mal in verschiedenen
Farben und Formen nochmal reinreiben.
Was war ein Beispiel denn?
Für so ein Wiederholungsbuch?
Endlich, nichts Bauchver.
Was so schief gelaufen ist.
Ach so, naja, also die schon die Eröffnung oder das Intro, die Einführung fand
ich ganz trefflich, weil sie meinten, also die kommen aus einer Consultancy aus Amerika,
das heißt die sind so, betreuen andere Firmen und helfen denen bei ihren Projekten, meinten so,
seit 20 Jahren machen wir Software, wo es darum geht irgendwas zu verkaufen,
eine Rechnung auszustellen und Geld einzusammeln quasi oder so,
so ein Warenwirtschaftssystem im Wesentlichen.
Und von den Projekten, die sowas machen, von denen, die dann gescheitert sind
oder viel zu lange gebraucht haben, bei denen lag es nicht an technischen Problemen,
weil das Konzept ist verstanden,
wenn überhaupt, dann wird es eigentlich einfacher mit neuen Technologien und
so weiter und haben sich sozusagen in dem Moment gefragt, okay,
woran liegt das, dass so ein verstandenes Problem und beherrschtes und schon
tausendfach umgesetztes Problem trotzdem scheitern kann.
Und sind eher darauf gekommen, dass es halt natürlich soziologische Gründe eher
hat, also Kommunikation und was nicht noch alles, Organisation und im Prinzip
ist das so die Einleitung von...
Worum es dann in dem Buch geht und sie betrachten einfach verschiedenste Elemente, zum Beispiel Qualität,
ob man die Qualität seines Produktes sich vom Markt diktieren lässt,
also beliebtes Beispiel,
ja der Markt will jetzt unser Produkt und Time to Market und der Kunde sagt
auch, ist uns scheißegal, wenn da jetzt noch ein paar Bugs drin sind,
wir brauchen das jetzt oder ob man sozusagen sagt.
Also von sich aus die Qualität diktiert und was Qualität auch für die Softwareentwicklung
und die Menschen, die das umsetzen, bedeutet.
Und das Selbstwertgefühl und der Spaß und so weiter und die Produktivität.
Es geht ganz viel um ganz viele Sachen, die, wenn ihr Softwareentwickler seid
und in so Projekten mal wart, ganz vieles davon wird euch sofort bekannt vorkommen.
Sie sprechen zum Beispiel auch über Open Office Spaces.
Also genau, dein Hassthema. Sie sind auch keine großen Fans und sie bringen
das auch alles sehr prägnant auf den Punkt, weil sie haben dann halt auch so eine Studie,
wo sie in einer Firma gefragt haben, was ist so der Top Nummer 1 Produktivitätskiller
und dann gab es in einer Firma so 90% der Mitarbeiter haben gemeint,
so ständige Unterbrechung und dauernd kommen Leute,
neues Level und so weiter und so fort und sind dem im Laufe der Zeit noch weiter
auf den Grund gegangen und haben so Coding Challenges gemacht und haben vorher,
also in verschiedenen Firmen gleichzeitig und haben vorher die Leute befragt,
Unter anderem war eine Frage, findet ihr das Noise-Level in eurem Büro akzeptabel oder ist es zu laut?
Und dann gab es diese Coding-Challenge, wo dann aufgezeichnet wurde,
wie viele Defekts hatte die Software.
War so eine Standardaufgabe, alle die gleiche. Hinterher geguckt,
wie viele Bugs waren drin und wie viel Zeit haben sie gebraucht,
um sie fertigzustellen.
Und dann so schöne Korrelationen wie die Leute, die gesagt haben,
es ist zu laut im Büro, hatten auch immer mindestens einen Defekt in ihrer Software,
haben mindestens irgendwie doppelt so lange gebraucht und so weiter, während die anderen...
Auf der anderen Seite waren und so sehr viele schöne, also nicht nur einfach Überlegungen,
sondern auch Studien oder empirische Daten hinterlegt,
weil ich glaube nach dem ersten Release von dem Buch haben wir schon gemerkt,
dass da die Response relativ gut war oder die Rückmeldung und haben halt in
den Folgejahren relativ viel Aufwand betrieben,
sozusagen ihre ganzen Thesen auch mit Daten zu unterfüttern und viele Firmen
zu befragen und so weiter.
und ich fand das wirklich sehr schön, nicht weil es mir viel Neues erzählt hat,
sondern einfach, weil es recht gut so Argumente zusammenfasst und auch eine
argumentive Grundlage gibt, wenn man selber in so einer Situation ist und schon merkt,
irgendwas läuft hier schief und kann dann anhand derer Argumente und Studien
vielleicht etwas besser argumentieren,
dass man ein paar Dinge geändert haben möchte. Aber es ist wirklich...
Ist dir das auch schon gelungen jetzt?
Ich bin noch gerade dabei, also ich lese gerade hier in Kindle,
das sagt ja keine Seitenzahl, sondern die Prozentzahl, Saving Furthest Read
Location, wo ich bin, 27 Prozent.
Also das ist noch ganz am Anfang.
Ich werde das erstmal noch weiterlesen und dann...
Flugscheißen.
Wie gesagt, das ist...
Gibt es auch als iBook.
Ja, wie gesagt, im Prinzip bisher lese ich das so und denke mir so, Ja, genau.
Aber ich wäre nie in der Lage gewesen, das so klar auf den Punkt zu bringen,
wenn mich jetzt einmal jemand direkt gefragt hätte.
Und insofern mag ich das Buch schon jetzt sehr, weil das so ein bisschen die Pfade vortrampelt.
Von demselben Autor gibt es auch noch ein anderes sehr gutes Buch und zwar The
Deadline, wo es direkt auch über Projektmanagement in der Softwareentwicklung geht.
Also ich habe das irgendwie im Studium, hat das eine Professorin halt auch irgendwie
empfohlen, die Bücher von ihm, weil die wirklich nachhaltig gut sind.
Tom DeMarco sollten wir vielleicht mal sagen. Viel glaube ich noch nicht.
Genau, um Deadlines geht es dann natürlich auch in dem Buch.
Das ist wirklich ein sehr facettenreiches Themenspektrum, da ist vermutlich
dann so ein bisschen fokussierter.
Ja, es ist vor allen Dingen halt auch ein Roman über Projektmanagement.
Er hat sich halt drei der größten...
Oder Software-Riesen genommen. Ich glaube, das eine war Photoshop,
also quasi fiktiv, was müsste man machen um Photoshop und ich weiß nicht,
was die beiden anderen waren.
Ich glaube, Word, so einen Word-Abklatsch und das dritte weiß ich.
Wirklich nicht mehr.
Wie man rangehen müsste, wie man effektiv so seine Deadlines setzt,
wie man mit Teams umgeht, wie man halt auch,
also dieser Irrsinn, dass halt irgendwann ein Team halt auch die Maximalgrenze
an Mitarbeitern halt auch einfach erreicht hat und man nicht unendlich wachsen
kann, weil man sich dann wieder auf die Füße tritt.
Also das war schon ziemlich cool, ich muss das nochmal lesen bei Gelegenheit.
Also auch das Kapitel da zum Thema Qualität fand ich sehr spannend,
weil ich bin gerade in so einem Projekt, wo die These ist, lieber ein schlechtes
Produkt als gar kein Produkt.
Und mit genau allem, was sie da beschreiben, ist in diesem Team zu beobachten,
die ganze Frustration der Developer, dass es einfach null Drive so ist.
Oder stolz von dem, was man da so gebaut hat, alle so ja nee,
nee, wir wissen, das ist Schrott und so und dann haben sie so ein paar Beispiele zum Beispiel aus Japan,
weil so damals halt auch Japan schon als hohe Qualität und schnelle Ausführung
sozusagen als gutes Beispiel bekannt war und dann haben sie so Beispiele aus
den frühen Hitachi und Fujitsu Zeiten, wo sogar das Team,
ein Veto hatte auf die Deadline.
Also selbst wenn der Kunde gesagt hat, ich nehme das jetzt mit Fehlern,
aber ich brauche es jetzt.
Sozusagen hatte das Team noch das Veto und zu sagen, nee, wir machen jetzt noch
drei Wochen länger und dafür wird es richtig gut.
Das ist natürlich dann schon sehr extrem ausgespielt, aber auch,
dann hatten sie so ein Interview mit so einem Projektleiter aus den goldenen
Hewlett-Packard-Zeiten, der dann auch meinte.
Das nach Qualität zu streben, sie eher schneller macht als langsamer,
was natürlich auch total logisch ist, dass wenn du nicht irgendwie so einen
totalen Spaghetti-Code-Haufen baust,
sondern das ordentlich Designs, dass dann hinterher neue Features zu bauen auch
viel schneller ist und man nicht die ganze Zeit mit Bugfixen beschäftigt ist
und so weiter und so fort.
Aber man kriegt dann halt auch mal so hier wirklich so mundgerecht aufbereitet
und eben mit echten Interviews und Daten und so weiter und erfüttert.
und nicht nur habe ich mir mal so überlegt.
Ja, das war's. Kann man mal lesen. Macht mir bisher sehr viel Spaß.
The show isn't over till the fat lady sings. Ah ja.
Genau, das ist gerade hier das Kapitel zum Thema Open Spaces und Bring back the door.
Ja, der Glaube an den Open Space und dass das die Kommunikationsförderung würde,
ist ungebrochen. Ich weiß nicht, wo der herkommt.
Ist nicht auch im Apple Ring Campus, wie heißt das, Apple Park,
deren neues Gebäude ist da nicht auch? irgendwie haben die das nicht geändert.
Vor allen Dingen ist da, ein Team hat sich doch geweigert, da hinzuziehen,
weil da Open Plan Office wollten sie nicht.
Mehrere, glaube ich sogar. Ich glaube die Forschungsabteilung.
Es kommt ja auch immer darauf an, was man macht. Für bestimmte Teams ist Open bestimmt voll super.
Design vielleicht oder so, keine Ahnung, aber für so einen Programmierer,
der sich konzentrieren muss, ist das halt eben nicht so geil.
Ich saß einmal in einem Open Office mit,
da waren Leute von Sales dabei, die den ganzen Tag telefoniert haben und den
ganzen Tag dasselbe auf ja und hier und ich wollte ihnen nochmal erzählen und
hier und sehen sie nochmal und boah.
Dafür gibt es halt ein neues Kanzler Kopfhörer, aber trotzdem ist das nicht so toll.
Das hält der bei Stimme auch nicht perfekt, ja.
Ja, ich finde es auch irgendwie unangenehm, also ich habe das halt auch gerade
in dem Büro, wo ich bin, dass es manchmal halt echt nicht passt,
sondern ich dann halt merke,
geil, ich kann jetzt zwar hier sitzen und so ein bisschen programmieren,
aber ich könnte halt viel effektiver einfach an einem Ort sitzen der ruhig ist, wo niemand reinkommt
und es ist halt immer so da kommt halt noch ein Studi rein, wo ist denn der
und der mein Gott, bin ich die Auskunft lass mich doch mal in Ruhe coden also
es ist halt echt so, wo ich denke, das klappt halt nicht immer.
Und die meinten halt dann auch in dem Buch so, dass sie bei manchen Firmen,
die so eine strikte On-Site-Policy hatten dass dann die Leute,
wenn sie wirklich was geschafft haben, schaffen mussten dass sie dann einfach
sich krank gemeldet haben und zu Hause dann das irgendwie fertig gecodet haben.
Und so Zitate wie, ja, wenn ich zwei Stunden vorher komme oder früher komme,
dann schaffe ich mehr als am restlichen ganzen Tag und so. Das hat man ja auch schon alles gehört.
Weil keiner da ist und so, ja.
Ja.
Ja, und einmal war ich in einem Office, das war auch so ein Open Space Office,
da haben sie dann das Nachbarhaus abgerissen.
Und zwar, weil das so ein Betongebäude war, jede Etage einzeln mit einem Presslufthammer.
Haben dann irgendwie sechs Wochen gebraucht.
It's not that I'm lazy, I just don't care.
Coffee cancel, Nina's speaking. Just a moment.
Ich wollte nur ein bisschen Background-Neues machen. Wir haben ja schon mehrfach
Office-Base erwähnt und ein paar von euch dürften jetzt wahrscheinlich den Film
auch schon gesehen haben, die es noch nicht gemacht haben. Auch zu diesem Thema.
Hausaufgabe zum nächsten Mal.
Office-Base, was beitragen?
If you move my desk one more time, I set this building on fire.
Didn't you get the memo?
About this.
Okay. Bin mal durch.
Ich bin durch.
I am cheating on you. Das ist mit den letzten Bissau durch.
Ich muss mich hier gerade so ein bisschen zusammenhalten, dass ich nicht einschlafe.
Unbequem der Stuhl auf Dauer, ne?
Ne, das nicht. Der Stuhl, der ist ganz gut, aber ich kann nicht so lange sitzen
gerade. Und man verheddert sich hier ständig in diesem Kabel oder ich bin gerade
einfach nicht so koordiniert wie sonst.
Wie sonst, das kann auch sein. Aber da mag ich jetzt keine Aussage drüber.
Besser ist das.
Bestimmt, bestimmt, bestimmt, bestimmt. Gab es noch irgendwas?
Achso ja, erstmal vielen Dank nochmal an Rainer, der diese Sendung das Intro
geliefert hat. das war wieder nicht David, David ist jetzt ein bisschen für
die nächsten Wochen ein wenig raus.
Der hat Dinge zu tun.
Fast okay, er hat es wirklich lange genug gemacht.
Und ja, er hat ja auch letztes Mal schon was beigetragen und es gab auch noch andere Angebote und,
jetzt versuche ich das so zu koordinieren, dass so first come, first serve,
mäßig, also wenn ihr was habt oder wenn ihr was machen, wenn ihr wisst,
dass ihr was machen wollt, auch wenn es noch nicht fertig ist,
sagt mir einfach Bescheid, dann kann ich auch den anderen dann entsprechend
Bescheid sagen, weil das wäre ein bisschen doof, wenn jetzt mehrere,
letztes Mal haben wir das ja noch elegant abgefedert, aber ich glaube bei einem
Intro, einem previously pro Sendung können wir bleiben, aber es freut mich auf jeden Fall extrem,
dass das das verfangen hat.
Hast du andere Sachen anzukündigen?
Ich weiß nicht, Ich war jetzt am Wochenende bei einer Veranstaltung,
wo ein Gebäude 30 Jahre alt wurde.
Wow.
Und im Programm dazu war irgendwie für November dein Name, stand da drin,
dass du da irgendwie einen Podcast machen würdest.
Achso, steht das schon drin?
Ja.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es schon Tickets und so, keine Ahnung.
Ja, also du redest vom Zeiss Großplanetarium.
Genau.
Und dort wird Raumzeit live stattfinden.
Mhm.
Mhm, genau.
Das Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin.
Das heißt Großplanetarium The One and Only Von hier aus da drüben Um die Ecke, genau,
Raumzeit habe ich ja schon mal gemacht live, schon ein bisschen her in Darmstadt
gab es da schon mal was, gibt leider keine Videoaufzeichnung von,
wohl aber eine Audioaufzeichnung Die.
Habe ich gehört, fand ich sehr lustig Das.
War sehr nett, da waren irgendwie 400 Leute da, das war ganz toll und ganz so
viele passen in das Planetarium leider nicht rein, von daher wird es da wahrscheinlich
eine kleine Schlacht geben, aber ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher,
wie da jetzt so der Stand der Dinge ist, aber das werde ich dann demnächst auch
nochmal genauer ankündigen.
Ja, irgendwas haben wir noch vergessen, aber irgendwas ist ja immer.
Also Leute, ihr wisst jetzt Bescheid, Schredder kaufen, auf Space gucken.
Alles wird gut.
Bier braun.
Und Bierbrauen, natürlich, klar.
Wir müssen an unserer Kampagne für die Partei noch feilen.
Oh, das stimmt.
Nächstes Mal.
Bist du Vorsitzender? Nein.
Bis dann, tschüss.
Wiederhören.
Tschüss.